A SUB COMMITTEE.
IS THE WATER PARKS WILDLIFE
COMMITTEE AGENDA FOR TUESDAY
APRIL TWENTY FOURTH.
WHEN I CALLED.
YES TESTING YES.
AND THE WE DON'T HAVE TO CALL
THE ROLL.
THAT WE DO HAVE A BILL HERE.
WELCOME ALL.
WILL BE STARTING RIGHT AWAY AS
SUBCOMMITTEE AND WELCOME MR
FRAZIER OF TO PRESENT AB
EIGHTEEN. SEVENTY SIX AS HE
COMES UP.
IF YOU'RE ANNOUNCEMENTS AB
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY TWO BY MISTER
BLOOM HAS BEEN PULLED.
FROM THE AGENDA BY THE AUTHOR.
AS A REMINDER THIS OUR LAST
HEARING ON ASSEMBLY BILL WE HAVE
A FULL AGENDA NEED TO GET TO ALL
OF THE BILLS.
TODAY
WE YOU BE LIMITING WITNESSES TO
TO.
ON EACH SIDE TWO MINUTES THAT
EACH EVERYONE ELSE CAN JOIN IN
AS A ME TOO.
WITH THAT WAS A FRAZIER PLEASED
LIKE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
TODAY I'M PRESENTING A. B.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX TO SENSE
THAT THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL AND PROVIDE THE DELTA
PROTECTION COMMISSION WITH THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF FULFILLING
THEIR DUTIES ESTABLISHED BY THE
DELTA. REFORM ACT.
THE GOVERNOR'S BLUE RIBBON
COMMISSION IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN
IDENTIFIED CERTAIN POLICIES AND
DIRECTIONS FOR EFFECTIVE
MANAGEMENT OF THE DELTA. AND
CALIFORNIA'S WATER SUPPLY.
SOME OF THERE RECOMMENDED
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE ROLLED INTO
THE DELTA REFORM ACT TO REQUIRE
REGIONAL SELF RELIANCE.
AND.
I'LL.
IF EMPHASIZE THIS POINT DECREASE
DEPENDENCE ON THE DELTA.
THAT REPORT ALSO INCLUDE
REQUIRING GREATER INPUT FROM THE
DELTA COUNTIES TO ASSIST WITH
THE DELTA PLAN.
SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT BEEN
FULFILLED UNDER THE DIRECTION OF
THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL.
IN FACT AS OPPOSITION HAS
RECOGNIZED THE COUNCIL'S GONE
OUT OF ITS WAY TO SUPPRESS INPUT
FROM DELTA INTERESTS.
THE COUNCIL IS CONTINUE TO DRAG
THEIR FEET ON PROPER FUNDING
STRATEGIES FOR FOR DELTA LEVEES
BY PUTTING MORE STRESS ON
FARMERS AND DELTA COMMUNITIES.
THERE'S NOT BEEN A STATE WIDE
APPROACH HAS MANY TRY TO ARGUE
AND THE COUNCIL TOO OFTEN HAS
ACTED AS A RUBBER STAMP FOR THE
INTEREST OF METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT. OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
TO FORCE THROUGH THE TWIN TOTAL
PLAN.
BY TRANSFERRING DUTIES TO THE
DELTA PROTECTION COMMISSION THE
STATE CAN SAVE UP TO TWENTY
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
AND PUT THE ONGOING OVERSIGHT OF
THE DELTA PLAN AND LEVY
INVESTMENT STRATEGY. WITH A MORE
ABLE BODY.
WITH ME TODAY IS SACRAMENTO
COUNTY SUPERVISOR DONNA TOTALLY
WHO IS A FORMER MEMBER OF THE
DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL.
TO PROVIDE COMMENTS ON THE
EXPERIENCE OF THE COUNTIES.
OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER FRAZIER AND
GOOD MORNING A CHORE GARCIA AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
PLANNED ON A TOTALLY I'M A
MEMBER THE SECRETARY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
I REPRESENT DISTRICT FIVE WHICH
INCLUDES THE DELTA COMMUNITIES.
OF REPORT HOOD CORTLAND LOCK
WANNA GROVE RIGHT AND I'LL THAN
IN SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
THIS AREA AS MANY OF YOU WELL
KNOW.
IS COMPRISED OF DELTA LEGACY
COMMUNITIES IT'S RICH IN ITS
HISTORY AS WELLS IS A VAST
AGRICULTURAL HUB.
I'M ALSO HERE REPRESENTING A
MITE DEL THE COUNTY COALITION
COLLEAGUES FOR THE COUNTIES OF
YELLOW SOLANO CONTRA COSTA. AND
SEVENTEEN
TOGETHER WE REPRESENT FOUR
MILLION RESIDENTS OF WHICH MORE
THAN A HALF A MILLION LIVIN
RESIDE AND WORK IN THE DELTA.
I'M HERE DALY OFFER SUPPORT FOR
SIMILAR FRASIER'S BILL. BECAUSE
REPRESENTS A STRONG NEED FOR
DELTA CENTRIC REPRESENTATION.
DON'T ISSUES ARE INCREDIBLY
DIVERSE INCLUDE AGRICULTURE
WATER TOURISM VOTING FISHERIES.
ECOSYSTEM THE ENVIRONMENT.
WHICH ALL TOGETHER MAKE TO DEL
THEY TRULY UNIQUE AND SPECIAL
PLACE.
AS A LONGTIME COUNTY SUPERVISOR
I HAVE SERVED FOR MORE THAN
TWENTY THREE YEARS IN THE DELTA
PROTECTION MISSION.
FOLLOWING THE PASSAGE OF ADULT
REFORM ACT IN TWO THOUSAND NINE.
IN MY BEEN ROLE AS CHAIRMAN OF
THE DPC AYE SIR FROM WHAT LITTLE
MORE THAN THREE YEARS AS A
MEMBER OF THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL.
IN FACT ACTIVELY PARTICIPATED IN
THE DEVELOPMENT INITIAL APPROVAL
OF THE DELTA PLAN.
THE DOE THE COUNTY'S COALITION
FOR MORE THAN A DECADE
HAS CONSISTENTLY ANTI RISLEY
WORK TO ENSURE FAIR AND STRONG
REPRESENTATION FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE COUNTIES AND THE
PEOPLE OF THE DELTA.
WE'VE TAKEN OUR CHARGE
SERIOUSLY.
AND ACTIVELY CONTRIBUTE TIME
TELL TO RESOURCES. TO THE THREE
CURRENT GOVERNMENT BODIES WHICH
GUIDED OVERSEE THE DELTA. DOES
BEING THE DUST STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL PROTECTION COMMISSION
ADULT CONSERVANCY.
AND WE CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE FOR
A GREATER DECISION MAKING ROLE
IN THE GOVERNANCE.
AND IN THE DECISIONS ON MATTERS
AFFECTING THE DELTA.
RECOGNIZE IT TO DOUBLE
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IS A
STATEWIDE BODY
WE FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT THE
CURRENT CONSTRUCT OF IDIOCY IS
NOT A TRUE REPRESENTATION OF THE
DELTA COMMUNITY.
POLICY DEVELOPMENT DECISIONS
OUGHT TO BE DONE EQUITABLY AND
FAIRLY AND THIS REQUIRES
ADEQUATE REPRESENTATION.
THE DELTA COMMUNITY IS DESERVING
OF A FAIR AND STRONG
REPRESENTATION ON ANY DECISION
MAKING BODY.
BECAUSE THEIR HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES
THEIR LIVELIHOODS IN THE WELL
BEING AND THEIR FUTURE ARE AT
STAKE.
THE STATE'S CURRENT POLICY
TRAJECTORY COULD HAVE A FAR
REACHING AND NEGATIVE IMPACT ON
THE DELTA AS WE KNOW IT.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX PROVIDES
GREATER REPRESENTATION IN THE
POLICY MAKING PROCESS.
IMPROPERLY ASSURES THE INTEREST
WAS DEALT ARE FAIRLY REPRESENTED
IN DECISION MAKING INDECISION
WHICH SERVE TO PROTECT.
AND ENHANCE THE UNIQUE CULTURAL
HISTORICAL RECREATIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL AND AGRICULTURAL
RESOURCES OF THE DELTA.
THE DELTA COUNTIES COALITION IS
PLEASED TO SUPPORT DISTILLING OR
FRAZIER IS BILL THIS IMPORTANT
BILL ABC EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX I
THANK YOU FOR ATTENTION FOR
ALLOW ME TO REPRESENT. THE COULD
COMMITTEES HEARD THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES.
TREASURES THAT WILL BE COMING
UP IF NOT THE WILL TAKE.
FOLKS I IN SUPPORT GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURN MEMBERS KAREN LAYING
ON THAT AT THE COUNTIES THE SAN
JOAQUIN YOLO SALON OF
SACRAMENTO.
AND CONTRA COSTA OWN SUPPORT
THEIR THAT FIVE COUNTIES THAT
COMPRISE THE DELTA COUNTIES
COALITION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS BARBARIC
IMPERIAL WITH RESTORED THE DELTA
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT A. B.
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS RAJI IN REYNOLDS I
LIVE IN THE SOUTH DELTA FORTY
FOUR FORTY FOUR WEST UNDYING
ROAD STOCKTON CALIFORNIA. THE
PEOPLE.
WHO LIVE IN THE DELTA SUPPORT
THIS BILL?
GOOD MORNING CAO JUST OF COPS
URKEL CALIFORNIA WE HAVEN'T
TAKEN OFFICIAL POSITION UNLESS I
BOGEYED SUPPORT THE CONCEPT OF
THE BILL IT WILL JUST BE LOOKING
AT INTO TAKING OFFICIAL POSITION
SIR THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING OCEAN RESERVE OF
LOCAL AGENCIES OF THE NORTH
DELTA WE DO SUPPORT THE CONCEPT
BEHIND THE BILL AND WOULD LIKE
TO MOVE IT FORWARD THINKING.
HI MY NAME'S DAN BARKER
COMPETITORS FISHING FOR I'M ALSO
ON THE BOARD OF THE CALIFORNIA
WATER IMPACT NETWORK AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL TO
GIVE GREATER REPRESENTATION.
TWO FISHERMEN ARM ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITIES AND THE
PEOPLE OF THE DELTA.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR. I'LL LA CALL UP
THE TWO WITNESSES THE.
WHO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION?
THERE ARE YOU I'M IN FAVOR OF
SORRY I WASN'T ABLE TO SIT DOWN
MY NAME IS BARBARA DALY I AM
WITH A GROUP CALLED NORTH DEALT
THE CARES. COMMUNITY AREA
RESIDENTS FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
STABILITY WHERE LOCALLY LOOK WE
ARE LOCATED IN CLARKSBURG. AND
WE SUPPORT THE WHOLE DELTA
REGION AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRASIER'S BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NO WELLS CAL CALIFORNIA DELTA
CHAMBERS AND VISITORS BUREAU WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT ASSEMBLY PERSON
FAVOR OF.
FRASIER'S BILL AND NO WE ALSO
SUPPORT GUITAR DELTA REGION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SIR.
IT WILL BEGIN WITH THE DO
WITNESSES YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
DOESN'T SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE CATHY COLE WITH
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
ON BEHALF OF THE FORTY THREE
SIGNATORIES TOOK COALITION
LETTER THAT WAS SUBMITTED TO
THIS COMMITTEE. I HEARD YOU KNOW
VOTE ON AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX.
THE SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN DELTA
IS OF STATEWIDE SIGNIFICANCE AS
WELL AS AN INTENSE INTEREST
UNDERSTANDABLY FOR THOSE WHO
LIVE THERE.
AB EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX FAILS TO
RECOGNIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
STATEWIDE APPROACH ADVANCING
PROGRESS IN THE DELTA AS
ENCOMPASSES IN A COMPREHENSIVE
PACKAGE LEGISLATION PASSED BY
THIS LEGISLATURE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE.
THAT HISTORIC PACKAGE ADVANCE
STATEWIDE IMPORTANCE OF THE
DELTA FOR TOMORROW MENTAL AND
WATER SUPPLY VALUES FOR
RECOGNIZING PROTECTION OF THE
DELTA ITSELF AS INVOLVING PLACE.
THE TWO THOUSAND NINE PACKAGE
CREATED THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL TO BETTER COORDINATE
ACTIONS OF SOME TWO HUNDRED
LOCAL AND STATE AGENCIES. THAT
IN SOME WAY OR ANOTHER HAD
JURISDICTION OVER ISSUES
IMPACTING THE DELTA.
TO COORDINATE THOSE ACTIONS
UNDER A SINGLE DELTA PLAN.
THIS PACKAGE ALSO RESTRUCTURED
THE DELTA PROTECTION COMMISSION
TO BE A MORE LOCALLY
REPRESENTATIVE BODY ANTICIPATED
THE DPC CHAIR TO SERVE ON THE
COUNCIL.
WE'VE YOU MISTER FRAZIER SPELL
AS AN ATTEMPT TO FRUSTRATE
EFFORTS TO MOVE FORWARD WITH
THEIR INBOUND SOLUTIONS IN THE
DELTA BY TRANSFERRING DUTIES TO
AN ENTITY THAT IS DOMINATED BY
INTEL TO INTEREST.
AND THAT LIKELY UNDO THE STATE
WHAT APPROACH TO DELTA POLICY BY
PUTTING ONE REGION'S AGENDA
BEFORE THE OTHERS.
I DO TAKE ISSUE WITH
CHARACTERIZING THE COUNCIL AS A
SHOW FOR THE DELTA TUNNELS
THIS BILL SHOULD NOT BE ABOUT
ANY GIVEN ACTION THIS SHOULD BE
ABOUT WHO'S THE BEST CRAFT AND
IMPLEMENT OVERARCHING PLANNING
DOCUMENT.
WE FEAR A MISTER FRASIER'S BILL
PUTS THE BRAKE ON ADVANCING TO
SAY POLICY AND THE STATE WHAT
APPROACH DELTA MANAGEMENT FOR
THE FUTURE AND FOR THESE REASONS
WE URGE OUR LOW FAT. THANK THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THAT BOB GREBER THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ON BEHALF
OF DESERT WATER AGENCY ROLAND
WATER DISTRICT IN THE VALLEY
ATWATER COALITION.
IN OPPOSITION TO DATA AB
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX.
I THINK WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO
THE A FORMATION OF THE DELTA
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE AS PART OF A LARGE
PACKAGE THAT REFORM TO THE
MATTER IN WHICH THE DELTA. WOULD
BE DEALT WITH.
NOT ONLY IN TERMS OF UP
PROTECTING THAT.
BUT ALSO TO RECOGNIZE THAT IT
IS A. AS MUCH AS IT'S IMPORTANT
TO THE COMMUNITIES AND RESIDENTS
OF THE DELTA.
THE DELTAS OF AN INTERNATIONAL
NATIONAL AND STATE WIDE
IMPORTANCE.
CHANGING THE GOVERNANCE MODEL
THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL
REALLY IS AN ANATHEMA TO THE
ROLE OF THE COUNCIL.
OF THE DELTA PROTECTION
COMMISSION HAS ITS PURPOSE THE
DELTA CONSERVANCY HAS ITS
PURPOSE.
AND THE OTHER TWO HUNDRED
FEDERAL STATE REGIONAL LOCAL
AGENCIES HAVE THEIR OWN
RESPECTIVE PURPOSES.
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THROUGH
THE DELTA PLAN THAT PLANNING
PROJECTS AND EXPENDITURES.
A PARK COME TOGETHER TO BALANCE
COMPETING USES
TO ENSURE THAT WATER SUPPLY FOR
OVER TWENTY FIVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS IS MAINTAINED AND
THAT THE ECOSYSTEM THE DELTAS
RESTORED.
SO WIN WIN YOU.
WHEN YOU MOVE THE VENUE IF YOU
WELL FROM THE STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL TO THE DOUBTS PROTECTION
COMMISSION. YOU SHIFTED A ON ON
RECENTLY TOWARDS A DELTA CENTRIC
FOR
FOCUS.
IT IS THE WRONG APPROACH WE WIN
WE ALSO NEED REMIND THE
COMMITTEE THIS BILL DOESN'T
CHANGE ANY OF THE STATUTORY
RESPONSIBILITIES ROLES OUR
DUTIES. OF THE DELTA STEWARDSHIP
COUNCIL THAT REMAINS AND INTACT
SO ALL YOU'RE DOING WITH THIS
LEGISLATION. IS SHIFTING THE
GOVERNANCE IN THE FOCUS FROM A
STATEWIDE FOCUS TO DELTA CENTER.
AND IT'S INAPPROPRIATE TO DO SO
AND WE WERE RESPECTFULLY QUEST
IN ABOUT THANK YOU BY THOSE WHO
LIKE TO.
.
I HAD.
THE OPPOSITION THE STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEM.
REPRESENTATION OF ORGANIZATION.
GOOD MORNING NAM MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS SAID MANNING WITH KP
PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF
MOJAVE WATER AGENCY IN WHAT
SENSE WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN
O'MALLEY WITH CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF MESA
WATER DISTRICT.
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
CHRISTY BOY WITH ARNOLD AND
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THREE
VALLEY'S MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION.
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ON
RUN DAVIS ON A WITH RUN DAVIS
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF ALAMEDA
COUNTY WATER DISTRICT IN EASTERN
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION EMERGING YOUR NO
VOTE.
GOOD MORNING BETH A LOT SO ON
BEHALF OF INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY IN CUCAMONGA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION HAVE ALSO BEEN ASKED
TO REG DOT POSITION FOR IRVINE
RANCH WATER DISTRICT WHO
COULDN'T BE HERE TODAY.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER REPRESENTING THE SENATE
CLEVERLY WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION BANKIA.
VALERIE NARROW FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION.
SARS DIVERSE MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY IN
OPPOSITION.
CHRIS* REPRESENT THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
IN OPPOSITION.
CANDIDATES ARE GONE BEHALF OF
THE KERN COUNTY WATER AGENCY IN
THE SAN BERNARDINO VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
OPPOSITION.
STEVE BAKER WITH THEIR REDUCES
HITS FOR THE UPPER SAN GABRIEL
VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT
IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON.
.
OKAY SEEN NONE I WILL LOVE BRING
BACK TO THE DYESS AND.
COLLEAGUES.
MEMBERS AND QUESTIONS.
DR.
YEAH.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASK GO WHY IN
THE A MIDDLE OFF A BIG PROJECTS
ARE GOING ON SUCH AS A.
YOU KNOW WHAT IT'S IN THE
PROJECT WATER FAKES A PROJECT
COME.
DO.
OR THE SUR ARE TRYING TO CHANGE
THE GOVERNING STRUCTURE OF WHAT
THE TRUE MOTIVATION OF THIS HIS
HAS SUCH AS THE MAKEUP. OF THE
F. COUNSELOR WHO EMEKA.
MORE FAVORABLE POSITION
REGIONALLY FIGHT THE.
HOPE.
MISTER CHOICE THE THE WHOLE
REASON IS IS THAT THERE IS A
STATE GOVERNMENTS REPRESENTATION
ON THE DELTA PROTECTION
COMMISSION ALSO APPOINTEES BY
THE GOVERNOR FROM DIFFERENT
AGENCIES THAT ARE REPRESENTED.
.
NO THERE'S BEEN SEVERAL
DIFFERENT PLANS THAT HAVE BEEN
PUT FORWARD OF WITH THE BDC P..
THEN THE DOUBLE TUNNELS ANOTHER
TIME A SINGLE TITLES.
SO THAT PROCESS HAS ALWAYS BEEN
A TUNNEL VISION.
FOR THIS COUNCIL TO HIT THIS
PROJECT GOING FOR YOU SEE THE
OPPOSITION IS CLEARLY THE
BENEFACTORS OF THIS PROJECT.
AND SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO SAY
IS LET'S KITTY.
A REGIONAL AND A STATEWIDE
PERSPECTIVE GOING FORWARD YOU
LOOK AT TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS FUNDING. THE THE.
DELTA STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL AND A
LOT OF MY RESIDENTS HAVE BEEN
JUST ALIENATED BITE TIMING ON
MEETINGS AND WHAT NOT WHERE THEY
CAN'T MAKE MAKING A MAKE IT TO
THE MEETINGS. FOR THEIR
VIEWPOINT ON THIS PROJECT.
.
DON'T PROTECTION COMMISSIONS ONE
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS I I
WAS SERVED ON THERE FOR PROBABLY
ABOUT EIGHT YEARS I SERVE ON THE
DELTA CONSERVANCY.
NOW HAS AN APPOINTMENT BY OUR
SPEAKER. A. SUPERVISOR TOLLEY A
SENSE IT'S ALMOST ITS INCEPTION
HAS BEEN ON THAT THE.
PR TO DELTA PROTECTION
COMMISSION SO YOU LOOK AT. THE
DIFFERENT KIND OF
OF OF OF VALUES THAT THIS THIS
AGENCY BRINGS. AND WE WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT IT'S IT'S SEGREGATED
AND THAT THE STATEWIDE APPROACH
OF THE OPPONENTS OF THIS BILL
ARE CONCERNED ABOUT. WE ARE TO.
AND WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THEY
ACTUALLY HAVE THE AGENCIES IN
PLACE.
THAT ARE REPRESENTING THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GO FORWARD WITH
THIS PROJECT.
OR NOT BASED ON A FAIR AND AND
BALANCED APPROACH WITH THE COURT
WEEK WILL GOAL. OF MAKING SURE
THE DELTA IS PROTECTED
BUT THE WATER SUPPLY.
FOR SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CAN BE
DONE IN A REASONABLE APPROACH.
THAT'S ALL WE'RE LOOKING FOR.
THEN I GET THE IMPRESSION THAT
THE AS A MEMBER COMING FROM THAT
MAKE THESE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
IS YOU KNOW.
WATERS.
.
VERY ABUNDANT IN THE THEM
CALIFORNIAN THAT DOES TO REGION
BUT I'M NOT IN A SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND THE.
ORIGIN ON A ACTIVITIES ARE BY
DISA. YA KNOW DOES DOES JOSEPH
BEAU COUNCIL A WHAT WAS TO
REPRESENTING MORE NASA ENTIRE.
CALIFORNIA RATHER THAN FOCUSING
UPON THE REGION ON INTEREST
OFTEN BECAUSE PACKED AREA. SO
THIS A GOVERNING BODY
RESTRUCTURING IS SIR TO ME
APPEARS TO BE OUT ATTEMPTED. TO.
TOWN. OFFSET THAT THAT.
.
IN A BALANCED OF CORAL CURRENTLY
MEMBERSHIP MAKEUP OF DHEA OF
DOES DOES TOO STOOD STILL SHIP
COMES.
SIR THIS IS NOT ABOUT ABUNDANCE
OF WATER THIS ISN'T ABOUT THE
DECIMATION OF AN ECOSYSTEM. THAT
COULD BE COMPLETELY RUINED BY
THE APPROACH OF A FEW TO TO
BENEFIT.
TWO THIRDS OF THE POPULATION
STATE BUT DAMAGE THE ECONOMY OF
A THIRD WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
ALSO. IS THAT THIS ISN'T ABOUT
WATER. SPECIFIC THIS IS ABOUT
ENDANGERED SPECIES ALSO.
THERE'S THERE'S FISH AND FAUNA
THAT ARE AFFECTED BY THIS
DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
YOU KNOW WE DIDN'T BUILD THIS
PROJECT IN IN.
IN THE.
.
A COURT OF.
AREA OF WHERE IT'S BUILT ARE IN
NEAR TRACY CALIFORNIA. A TO
PROVIDE A COLD THE SACK OF
PULLING WATER IN FROM THE DELTA
REVERSING THE FLOW OF THE DELTA
TO PROVIDE WATER TO. OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA OF SO WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS THAT THERE MAY BE MORE
REASONABLE APPROACHES BUT WE
NEED A NON BIASED LOOK.
AGAIN ALL OF THE OPPONENTS ARE
BENEFACTORS.
TO THIS PROJECT
AND SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING FOR IS
A MORE FAIR BALANCED.
UNBIASED APPROACH THAT TAKING
OTHER FACTORS INTO CONSIDERATION
THIS ONCE WAS THE BT CP
WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF ACRES HUNDREDS
OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND MAKERS
OF MITIGATION FOR CONSERVATION.
TO ENHANCE IN IN THE.
DELTA
THAT'S BEEN THROWN BY THE
WAYSIDE FIRST IT WAS ABOUT A
MAKING THE DELTA BETTER.
NOT JUST BECOME ABOUT WATER
WHO AND.
WE ARE SAYING THAT SPECIES ARE
INVOLVED IN AN ECONOMY IS
INVOLVED.
DRINKING WATER IN OUR AREAS
INVOLVED A LOT OF THOSE FACTORS
NEED TO BE ADDRESSED IN A FAIR
AND REASONABLE FASHION.
OKAY I THINK OF THOSE A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION NOW FROM.
MY OPINION.
IT IS A VERY.
AND UNBALANCED.
MAKE UP AND DOWN A TRYING TO
CREATE. A DELAY SIGN THE
IDEA PROPOSED A DATA PROTECTION
THE OF COMMISSION AND WHEN YOU
SPEAK ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES AND OFFICIIS YOU
ATTENDING JETTA. รณ AND ONE
ISSUES.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT TELL ABOUT
THE HUMAN RIGHTS.
WITH A NO WATER INSTANT A SEVEN
CALIFORNIA. A WE WISH TO HUMAN.
OUR LIFE SO OR FOR.
A ENDANGERED SPECIES. รณ AND DO
YOU KNOW IF OUR WATER FLOWS TOWN
VIA IS SEE ENDANGERED SPECIES OF
FISH USE THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THOUGH. IN ORDER WOULD BE
VIRTUALLY YA COME HOME FREELY
AFFECTED I THINK THAT HAS BEEN
ALL CONSIDER AT THE END UP AND
MOST OF PROPOSED AND HAS BEEN. A
SUBMITTED AND THAT WORKED OUT
THE WIKIPEDIA OR REGIONAL
CONTESTS TO SHIP COMES OF THAT'S
MY OPINION.
AND YOU SERVE VERY MUCH ENTITLED
TO THAT I'VE LIVED IN THE DELTA
REGION FOR TWENTY THREE YEARS.
AND UNDERSTAND THE IMPACTS THAT
WE DO HAVE DROUGHT AND WATER
CANNOT FLOW IN ANY PROJECT
BECAUSE OF LOW FLOWS.
AND I THINK THERE'S A PROTECTION
THAT WE NEED TO TAKE ABOUT YOUR
CONSTITUENTS ALSO THAT IF WATER
IS NOT FLOWING THROUGH THIS
PROJECT. THAT THAT THAT THAT WE
FEEL THAT THIS.
.
S. COUNCILS TRYING TO PROMOTE.
THAT YOUR RATES ARE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE THROUGH THE SKY AND
THE TAXPAYERS ARE GOING TO BE
AFFECTED DRAMATICALLY. IF WE
HAVE A DECADE LOUD RHODEN A.
DECADE LONG DROUGHT A.
THAT PROJECT IS IS NOT
NONEXISTENT OR THEY'LL BE
EFFORTS TO A. TAKE.
A SPECIES INSTEAD OF BANQUET
SPEECH OF FEET PEOPLE AND
PROFITS BEFORE SPECIES AND
THAT'S WHAT I'M AFRAID OF ALSO.
A THIS THIS PROJECT DOES IT.
ALLOW FOR ONE ADDITIONAL DROP OF
WATER IT CIRCUMVENTS THE
PLUMBING ON THE DELTA INCREASES
THE SALINITY LEVELS COMING UP
FORWARD. AND SO I I I BEG TO
DIFFER AND AGAIN I APPRECIATE
YOUR OPINION.
AND WE WILL HAVE THAT NORTH
SOUTH KIND OF A.
LOOK AT THINGS BUT THE.
AGAIN.
I AM AFRAID OF WHAT THIS PROJECT
IN THIS COUNCIL HAS OF THE
APPROACH TO DUE. TO DAMAGE MY
FARMERS MY RECREATION MY
DRINKING WATER YOU'RE WORRIED
ABOUT YOUR DRINKING WATER. SO
MY.
SO MY AND WE HAVE MANY PEOPLE
THAT ARE RELIANT ON THAT. TOOK
TO LIVE AND SO.
WE KNOW THE INITIAL PROJECT WAS
BUILT.
IT DIDN'T WORK.
IT IS A IT'S AN AFFECT ON THE
SPECIES OF THE OF THE DELTA.
AND WE THINK THERE MIGHT BE SOME
MORE REASONABLE APPROACHES THAT
COULD BE TAKEN.
A BEFORE WE ARE HAVE A PROJECT
THAT WILL SIPHON OFF.
THOUSANDS OF CUBIC FEET PER
MINUTE OF WATER.
I THAT WOULD NORMALLY GIVE A
FLUSH TO THE CALIFORNIA DELTA.
AND KEEP THE SALINITY LEVELS
DOWN. OF WHERE THEY REMAIN NOW
AND NO CONSIDERATION OF OF OF
SEA LEVEL RISES BEEN IN IN MY
OPINION HAS BEEN FACTORED IN
ALSO ON HOW THIS CAN AFFECT THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES IN MY
AREA SO AGAIN. MARK TWAIN SAID.
IT WHISKEYS FOR DRINKING WATERS
HER FIGHT.
QUESTION FROM A SUMMER MATHIS.
I'M.
QUIT QUITE FRANKLY I THINK WE
NEEDED.
STAR LOOKING OUTSIDE OF THE BOX
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN SO FOCUSED ON
THE DELTA. BEING THE ONLY SOURCE
TO GET WATER SOUTH.
THEY I REALLY WISH WE DON'T
TAKE A STEP BACK AND LOOK AT
OTHER OPTIONS ON.
DO YOU CELLS A HUGE OPTION.
.
QUITE FRANKLY THAT THE LAST FOUR
YEARS SINCE WE'VE ALL BEEN UP
HERE.
.
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE PUSHING FOR
RENEWABLE ENERGY GOALS WERE
PUSHING FOR WATER GOALS.
ON THE OTHER STATE IN IN THIS IS
NOTHING ON YOU MISTER FREIGHTER.
THAT THE STATE'S LOOKING AT
SHUTTING DOWN DIABLO GRANDET.
OUR LAST NUCLEAR REACTOR
THEY'VE STATED OVER AND OVER
AGAIN THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DO DE SALLE.
JUST BY DOING AN INCREASE IN
THEIR INTAKE PIE.
AND WE ALL KNOW THE DELTA WATER.
ITS NEXT STOP WHERE GETS HELD IN
THE STATE WATER PROJECTS IS THE
SOUND THOSE THREADS WAR.
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO POP
DESALINATED WATER INTO THE ST
LOUIS RESERVOIR AND REFILL IT ON
A CONTINUAL BASIS.
STATING THIS TODAY BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THERE'S ENOUGH
PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT REAL LIFE
THIS.
AND QUITE FRANKLY THIS IS A
VIABLE OPTION AND.
AND IT LEAVES THE DELTA
COMPLETELY INTACT OR NOT MESSING
WITH THAT NAM MESSING WITH THE
SPECIES ON MESSING WITH ANY OF
THAT. AND SIMPLY TAKING
DESALINATED WATER.
FEELING THAT.
REST OF WAR WHERE WE MOVE ALL
THE DOUBTS WATER ANYWAY.
ON A REGULAR BASIS WHICH IS A
LOT MORE WATER THAN IT'S GETTING
FROM THE DELTA ANYWAY.
SO I'M MAKING THAT COMMENT TODAY
BECAUSE QUITE FRANKLY I'M SICK
OF HEARING THAT OUR ONLY OPTION
IS THE DELTA. AND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT SEVENTEEN BILLION DOLLAR
PRICE TAX.
THAT STRAIGHT ACTUAR DOLLARS
WHEN YOU HAVE THE ABILITY FOR A
PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP.
THAT HAS A BETTER RELIABLE
SOURCE THAT'S NOT GOING BE
DEPENDENT UPON CLIMB IT.
I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK AT OTHER
OPTIONS.
ON I'M NOT GONNA BE VOTING ON
YOUR BILL TODAY.
BUT I THINK WE AS A STATE NEED
TO WALK AT OTHER WAYS AND OTHER
OPTIONS THAT ARE MUCH MUCH MORE
VIABLE. ON AND ARE GONNA COSTS
ARE TAXPAYERS LESS MONEY.
ON IT AND GET OUT OF THIS BOX
THAT WE SEEM TRAPPED.
MR MATHESON I'D I APPRECIATE
YOUR CANDOR OF. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT.
TROUBLES ME AS THE CHAIRMAN THE
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AND
WE'VE SEEN MEGA PROJECTS IN
CALIFORNIA LIKE THE BAY BRIDGE.
AND NOW HIGH SPEED RAY RAIL.
THE PUBLIC HAS BEEN TOLD ONE
THING.
AND ANOTHER THING OCCURS THEY
GET INVOLVED IN THE PROJECT AND
THEN IT BECOMES A LARGER THAN
LIFE.
ISSUE THAT.
.
NOW WE HAVE TO TELL YOU ABOUT
THIS.
THIS IS WHAT I'M AFRAID OF ALSO
IN THIS PROJECT THE RATEPAYERS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AGAIN
WILL BE. OF SOLD A BILL OF GOODS
NO PUN INTENDED. AND IN THE
PROJECT BE DRAMATICALLY MORE
EXPENSIVE.
BECAUSE THAT'S JUST WHAT
HAPPENS.
AND SO A AS YOU'VE MENTIONED
ALSO IN.
MY AREA IT PITTSBURG IN ANTIOCH
WE HAVE DECOMMISSIONED POWER
PLANTS THAT HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DISTILL WATER. IN THIS BRACKISH
WATER.
AREAS.
NEVER BEEN FACTORED IN AS AN
ALTERNATIVE AND AND AND AS FAR
AS I KNOW BUT AGAIN WITH IF IT'S
A SEVENTEEN BILLION DOLLAR
PROJECTED PROJECT.
THAT'S ABOUT SIXTEEN D. SELL
PLANTS.
THAT COULD PRODUCE ABOUT A
BILLION GALLONS OF WATER A DAY.
NEW WATER.
THIS PROJECT DOES NOT.
BUILD ONE DROP OF ADDITIONAL
WATER COMING THROUGH THOSE
TUNNELS.
AND SO I'M LOOKING FOR A FAIR
AND UNBIASED OPINION ABOUT HOW
WE CAN FROM MOVE FURTHER AND
PROTECT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BUT ALSO PROVIDE A NOT SO
NECESSARY.
WATER OF PRODUCTS FOR THEM AYE
NEWMAN BAREST WHAT THE NEW
SCORING'S OF THE WATER BOARD
THEY CAME OUT RECENTLY IN THAT
ARE STORAGES. BEEN OF SCORED SO
LOW THAT THERE ARE WATER BOND
WILL BE INEFFECTIVE.
BASED ON A WHAT I VOTED ON.
AND SO YOU KNOW I'M. I'M
DISAPPOINTED THAT CALIFORNIA'S
NOT TAKING A LEAD IN SERVICING
THE NEEDS AN APPROPRIATE
FASHION.
AWAY TOO TO ACCOMMODATE FUTURE
GROWTH.
BUT ALSO.
A RESPONSIBLE STEWARD OF THE OF
THE OF THE ENVIRONMENT TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE GET THERE. HELP MET
MISTER FRAZIER LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU.
ON OTHER VIABLE OPTIONS ON THE
AS YOU STATED THAT THE POWER
PLANT DE CELL OPTION IS IS AN
EXTREMELY VIABLE OPTION
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU GET INTO
LOOKING AT.
CONVERSIONS THE BIOMASS AS WELL
WHICH ON THE ARENA LOCAL SO I'D
I'D LOVE TO WORK WITH YOU.
MOVING FORWARD ON SOME. IDEAS
AROUND THAT I LOOK FOR TO THAT
SIR THANK YOU. AND SEE ANYONE
ELSE. QUESTIONS.
COMMENTS.
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM IT THE
BUT DEPUTY LIKE THAT WILL ALLOW
YOU TO.
.
MAKE YOUR CLOTHES STATEMENTS
AND.
I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THE COMMISSION DO.
THINK LONG AND HARD ABOUT HOW.
THE PROCESS IF YOU LOOK HOW IT'S
MOVE FORWARD AND IF YOU LOOK HOW
THE PROCESS.
GOES.
THAT IT IS A TUNNEL VISION PLAN
AND NO PUN INTENDED IT'S NEEDS
TO BE MORE.
FAIRLY APPROACHED.
AND WE THINK THAT.
THIS APPROACH BY PUTTING IN THE
DELTA PROTECTION COMMISSION%
WHICH WE BOTH SERVED I DON'T
SERVE ON THERE ANYMORE IT'S NOT.
FOR ME TO HAVE THIS HAPPEN.
BUT BEING IN THIS REGION SEEING
THAT THE DIFFERENT AGENCIES THAT
WORK TOGETHER.
THIS WE FEEL CAN ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISH THE CO EQUAL GOAL OF
OF OF PRODUCING WATER BUT ALSO
PROTECTING THE ENVIRONMENT IS SO
VALUABLE TO CALIFORNIA. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR.
THANK YOU.
BUT HAVE ANOTHER AUTHOR.
I AM TO A BE TWENTY ONE NINETY
ONE.
O'DONNELL
.
YOU I YOU MAYBE GET A THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AGAIN
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY ONE WHICH WILL
DIRECT THE OCEAN PROTECTION
COUNCIL TO CREATE THE WHITE
SHARK
THE POPULATION MONITORING AND
BEACH SAFETY PROGRAM.
OZ.
TO KEEP IT SIMPLE S. HUMANS
INTERACT MORE WITH SHARKS WE
NEED TO UNDERSTAND SHARK
BEHAVIOR THAT'S THAT'S THE
EFFORT HERE.
DURING THE LAST TEN YEARS
THERE'S BEEN A SUBSTANTIAL
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF SHARK
SIGHTINGS OFF THE CALIFORNIA
COAST.
OF COURSE I COME FROM LONG
BEACH.
AND OTHERS MORE THE LONG BEACH
AREA MY KIDS ARE IN THE WATER
OUT THERE ON THE WATER OUT THERE
MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES OUT
THERE WE'VE GOT YOU YOUR GUARDS
OUT THERE. AND THERE BEEN MORE
SHARK SIGHTINGS THEY'VE HAD BEEN
PULLED PULLED THEY'VE HAD TO BE
IN A BAND BE PULLED OUT OF THE
WATER.
MANY TIMES DURING THE SUMMER
MONTHS BECAUSE THAT THE THE
INTERACTIONS WITH SHARKS OR THAT
THE.
THE PROXIMITY TO TO THE SHARKS
WE NEED TO GET IT CAN BETTER
UNDERSTAND THAT.
WELL THIS INCREASE IS A GREAT
SIGN FOR THE MARINE ECOSYSTEM
THIS INCREASED ACTIVITY MAKES
HUMAN SHARK INTERACTIONS MORE
LIGHTLY LIKELY FOR SURE.
WHEN THESE INTERACTIONS GO WRONG
THEY STOKE FEARS AND
CALIFORNIA'S BEACH GOERS AND CAN
EVEN END IN TRAGEDY THERE'S
ECONOMIC CONSEQUENCES AS WELL
BECAUSE.
BUT THERE'S A SHARK SIGHTINGS
THAT WE IN THE NEWSPAPER AND
PEOPLE WILL NOT GO TO VISIT
CERTAIN AREAS OF OUR STATE.
BECAUSE THEY'VE HEARD YOU KNOW
THAT'S BEEN SHARK ACTIVITY.
THANK THANKFULLY COOPERATIVE
EFFORTS EFFORTS BY RESEARCHERS
LIKE THOSE WITH THE SHARK LAB.
AT CSU LONG BEACH HAVE PARTNER
WITH LOCAL AGENCIES AND NON
PROFITS TO MONITOR SHARKS STUDY
THEIR BEHAVIORS AND EDUCATE. THE
PUBLIC.
THESE EFFORTS HELP PREVENT
INCIDENTS QUELL UNJUSTIFIED
FEARS AND PROVIDE THE DATA
NEEDED TO UNDERSTAND AND
PRESERVE OUR MARINE ECOSYSTEM.
HOWEVER THESE EFFORTS CAN ONLY
BE SUCCESSFUL WHEN THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES NEEDED TO COMPLETE
THEIR WORK.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE NUMBER
OF SHARKS AT OUR BEACHES WAS SO
HIGH.
RESEARCHERS AT THAT CSU AT THAT
CSU LONG BEACH SHARK LAB RAT OUT
OF TRACKING TAGS TO PUT ON
SHARKS PART WAY THROUGH THE
SEASON.
IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT ARE
EFFORTS TO UNDERSTAND THESE
CREATURES PROTECT BEACH GOERS
ENSURE TOURISTS AREN'T SCARED
OFF FROM CALIFORNIA BEACHES WE
MUST BE WILLING TO INVEST IN
THOSE. WHO ARE IN OUR WATERS
DOING THE WORK?
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY ONE MAKES
THIS INVESTMENT BY CREATING A
GRANT PROGRAM FOR ACADEMIC
INSTITUTIONS PUBLIC AGENCIES AND
NON PROFITS EXPERIENCE CAN
ENGAGE IN SHARK RESEARCH.
A AND B. AND OUR BEACH SAFETY
EFFORTS.
THIS IS A HUMAN ISSUE THE ZEN
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE BUT AGAIN I
I AS I SAID STATE EARLY IT'S
ALSO AN ECONOMIC ISSUE
BECAUSE WHAT WE WANT PEOPLE TO
COME TO OUR CALIFORNIA.
A WITH ME HERE TODAY A TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY AS DOCTOR
CHRIS LOW HE'S DIRECTOR OF THE
SHARK LAB AT CSU LONG BEACH AND
ALICE KESSLER FROM THE YEAR. THE
CITY OF LONG BEACH AND YOU MAY
KNOW DOCTOR LOW IF YOU WATCH
SHARK WEEK YOU'VE SEEN HIM HE'S
THE SHARK WEEK GUY. HE IS
CERTAINLY ONE OF THE FOREMOST
WORLD EXPERTS ON SHARK BEHAVIOR
AND US I TURN IT OVER TO THEM.
THANK YOU SO.
WE'VE KNOWN THAT PRIVATE LAST
TEN TO FIFTEEN YEARS FLETCHER
POPULATION SEEMS TO BE
INCREASING AND THE REASON FOR
THAT IS REALLY SIMPLE WE
PROTECTED WHITE SHARKS HERE
INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA BACK IN
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR.
IT'S VERY LIKELY THAT THE WHICH
OUR POPULATIONS BEEN AFFECTED
FOR OVER A HUNDRED YEARS BECAUSE
A LOSS OF MARINE MAMMALS.
IF YOU DO IT HER AND ALSO
PROTECTION.
SO THE GOOD NEWS IS WHAT CHURCH
COMING BACK BECAUSE OF THE
EFFORTS THAT WE PUT IN PLACE TO
PROTECT THEM.
THE TRICKY PART IS WE'VE LACK
THE TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY STUDY WHITE CHURCH
AND NOW THAT THERE POPULATIONS
COMING BACK WITH ONE'S REALLY
IMPORTANT THINGS LIKE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS THE NURSERY FOR
WHITE SHARKS.
IN.
IN THAT NORTHEAST PACIFIC SIR
WHAT THAT MEANS IS CHARTER
COMING IN AND THEY'RE USING
THEIR BEACH HABITATS
SAME HABITATS AT SURFERS AND
SWIMMERS HE'S.
THAT HABITAT APPEARS TO BE VERY
IMPORTANT FOR THE SHARKS AND OF
COURSE ONCE THEY MATURE THEY
MOVED EITHER FURTHER NORTH TO
THAT CHANNEL ISLANDS OR THEY
MOVED TO THE FAIR LINES. WHERE
THEY'RE FEEDING PRIMARILY ON
MARINE MAMMALS IN THAT
POPULATIONS OF THOSE POPULATIONS
HAVE RECOVERED FAIRLY WELL SUSIE
COULD FEATURES?
BUT IT'S THE ONLY THE YEAR IN
THE JUVENILES HERRING VERY CLOSE
TO WHERE PEOPLE ARE AND THAT'S
SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN STUDYING
FOR LAST.
TEN YEARS NOW WITH FUNDING FOR A
LITTLE BIT OF FUNDING FROM
MONTEREY BAY AQUARIUM.
WE NOW HAVE ALL THIS NEW
TECHNOLOGY THAT'S LITERALLY
DEVELOP LAST FIVE YEARS THAT
WILL ENABLE US TO ANSWER ALL THE
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS.
THAT MANY THE THE WATER SAFETY
PERSONNEL NEED TO DO IN ORDER TO
KEEP PEOPLE SAFE.
MORE IMPORTANTLY IT'S THAT
SCIENCE THAT CAN BE USED TO
EDUCATE THE PUBLIC AND ALSO
WATER SAFETY PERSONNEL. SO THEY
CAN EFFECTIVELY DO THEIR JOB IN
THE PUBLIC OF SAFER BUT USING
SOME CALIFORNIA WATERS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ALICE KESSLER HERE
REPRESENTING THE CITY OF LONG
BEACH UP WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS LEGISLATION. THE POPULATION
GROWTH OF GREAT WHITE SHARKS HAS
IMPACTED LONG BEACH IN MULTIPLE
WAYS.
THREE THINGS I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT FIRST OF.
THE CITY AS OUR AUTHOR MENTION
DOES PROVIDE MULTIPLE MARINE
RECREATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES.
AND.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN ALONE THERE
WERE TEN GREAT WHITE SIGHTINGS
AND IT IT DOES AS WAS MENTIONED.
STRIKE FEAR AND.
THOSE THAT ARE SEEKING TO WRECK
RATE ON OUR BEACHES SO IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO PURSUE THE
POLICY SOLUTIONS THAT WILL MAKE
PEOPLE FEEL SAFE.
SECOND. LONG BEACH DOZEN JOY A
UNIQUE PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
SHARK LAB.
NOT ONLY IS IT SITUATED AND IN
LONG BEACH BUT.
IT COLLABORATES CLOSELY WITH
OUR LOCAL PUBLIC SAFETY
OFFICIALS TO ADDRESS THE IMPACT
OF THE POPULATION GROWTH.
IN THE SHARK LAB WOULD BE ABLE
TO TO APPLY FOR GRANTS UNDER
THIS PROGRAM.
TO SUPPORT ITS WORK TO REDUCE
SHARK ATTACKS ON BY USING THESE
MORE CUTTING EDGE TECHNOLOGIES.
.
AND THEN LASTLY THE CITY ITSELF
COULD APPLY FOR GRANTS UNDER THE
PROGRAM.
THROW FIRE DEPARTMENT AND OUR
DEPARTMENT PARKS RECREATION AND
MARINE.
TO SUPPORT OUR EFFORTS TO KEEP
PEOPLE SAFE ON OUR BEACHES SO
FOR THOSE REASONS WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY URGE AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU OF THOSE I WISH TO
SPEAK IN FAVOR OF AB. TWENTY ONE
NINETY ONE A GOOD MORNING CAO ON
THE SECOND CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
A MULE FROM FROM THE MONTEREY
BAY AQUARIUM IN SUPPORT.
KIM DELFINO DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT THANKS TO
ANYONE ELSE.
SHOULD WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM.
AB BUT THANK YOU ED ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL.
OKAY SCENE NO ONE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE BY YES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR NUYS WILL HIGHLIGHT THAT
THIS IS NOT JUST A LONG BEACH
ISSUE IS A CALIFORNIA ISSUE. A
MY DAUGHTER WAS SERVING IN THE
WATERS IN YOUR DISTRICT THIS
MORNING AND WE SEE SOME PICTURES
OF HER SURROUNDED BY. DOLPHINS
THANKFULLY LA BUT I ATE IT IT'S
SOMETHING WE NEED IT WE NEED TO
EDUCATE OURSELVES ON AND THAT
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL
THAT'S THE EFFORT BEFORE US
TODAY. I ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU
WE WILL LOVE.
TAKE ACTION ON THE ITEM ONCE WE
ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE. ZEN.
THANK YOU LEFT.
THE CALL GETS A MORE AUTHORS
THANK YOU
.
DOCTOR WELCOME.
BUT THE OF TWO BILLS AB TWENTY
SIX FORTY NINE. AND A. B..
THIRTY TWO EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I CAME
RUNNING FROM COMMITTEE AND.
APPRECIATE YOU FOR.
SQUEEZING ME IN.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
TODAY I I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE.
LET ME START BY SAYING THAT I
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
AND WOULD LIKE TO THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN YOUR STAFF.
CATHERINE FREEMAN FOR ALL THE
HARD WORK THEY'VE DONE ON THIS
BILL.
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE HAS TWO
PARTS THE FIRST PART IT CODIFIES
INTO LAW WITH GOVERNOR BROWN
INCLUDED. IN HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER
DURING THE WORST OF THE DROUGHT.
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER CREATED A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAY.
TEMPORARY WATER PERMITS.
IT DIRECTS THE STATE WATER BOARD
TO PRIORITIZE TEMPORARY WATER
RIGHT PERMITS FOR PROJECTS THAT
ENHANCE THE ABILITY OF A LOCAL
OR STATE. AGENCY TO CAPTURE HIGH
RUNOFF EVENTS
FOR LOCAL STORAGE OR RECHARGE.
THE EXECUTIVE ORDER ALSO
SUSPENDS THE PROVISIONS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY
ACT FOR STATE WATER BOARD
ACTIONS ON THESE TYPES OF
TEMPORARY PERMITS.
THE GOAL OF THESE PERMITS IS TO
CAPTURE HIGH PRECIPITATION
EVENTS.
AND STORE WATER THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE FLOW OUT TO THE OCEAN.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ONCE IN A
DECADE TYPE RAIN EVENTS LIKE THE
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WATER
YEAR.
TO OBTAIN AND MAINTAIN THESE
TYPES OF PERMITS YOU MUST
DEMONSTRATE THE BENEFICIAL USE
OF WATER DIVERTED.
THIS IS THE SECOND PART OF THE
BILL.
UNDER AB TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE WOULD BE
CONSIDERED A BENEFICIAL USE
CONSISTENT WITH GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLANS.
A PP I SEE REPORT TITLED
REPLENISHING GROUND WATER IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY WHICH WAS
RELEASED LAST WEEK STATED. THAT
SOME MANAGERS RECOMMENDED THE
STATE WATER BOARD TO FIND
RECHARGE AS A BENEFICIAL USE TO
REINTERPRET DEUCE UNCERTAINTIES
ABOUT THE LEGALITY OF IT TO USE.
WITH THE UPCOMING SUSTAINABLE
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT ACT
IMPLEMENTATION.
EVERY TOOL IS NEEDED IN ORDER
FOR CRITICALLY OVER DRAFTED
BASINS.
TO BECOME COMPLIANT.
AS WE KNOW MANY COMMUNITIES
ACROSS THE STATE ARE FACING
CHALLENGES OF IMPLEMENTATION OF
SIGNAL.
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE WILL
HELP COMMUNITIES AND USERS IN MY
DISTRICT AND ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
TO IMPLEMENT SIGMA BY USING
RECHARGE TO ITS FULLEST
POTENTIAL.
BY NO MEANS DO I THINK THAT THIS
IS THE ULTIMATE ANSWER TO SOLVE
OUR WATER PROBLEMS. AND HELP
PREPARE FOR SIGMA
IMPLEMENTATION.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT THIS. WILL
HELP MOVE OUR CONVERSATIONS
FORWARD.
HERE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS DON CAMERON FROM
TERRANOVA RANCH.
AND IF HE MAKES IT IN TIME
STACEY SULLIVAN. THE DIRECT THE
POLICY DIRECTOR AT SUSTAINABLE
CONSERVATION BEAT BEFORE YOU
PROCEED I'M GOING TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM SO THAT WERE ABLE TO TAKE
ACTION. THINK ARE ON THIS BILL
MEMSIC TRIPS BELOW.
EDUARDO GARCIA.
GALLAGHER HERE BIGELOW AS A.
CARILLO.
CHOI HERE.
CHIU THEIR.
FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA HERE.
HARPER PRESENT.
KALRA.
LEVINE. MATHIS.
RUBIO.
SOLIS WOULD.
THANK YOU WE MAY PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DON
CAMERON LIKE TO THANK THE
CHAIRMAN CHAIRMAN GARCIA MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
BY ALL ACCOUNTS THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY.
MAY LOSE.
ANYWHERE BETWEEN HALF A MILLION
AND A MILLION ACRES OF FARMLAND
BY TWENTY FORTY TWO THE SECOND
IMPLEMENTATION.
I FARMING FRESNO COUNTY WHICH IS
WITHIN THE KING SUBBASIN.
THAT ENCOMPASSES ABOUT A MILLION
ACRES OF FARMLAND.
THIS IS A CRITICALLY OVERDRAFT
BASIN BY SICKNESS DEFINITIONS
REQUIRING A PLAN TO BE IN PLACE
BY TWENTY TWENTY.
THE BASIN IS OVER CRAFTED.
BY PROBABLY TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
ACRE FEET PER YEAR.
IN TWENTY ELEVEN TWENTY ELEVEN
WAS THE FLOOD YEAR SENATE
TURNOVER RANCH WE BEGAN. A FLOOD
WATER CAPTURE PROGRAM THAT
INTENTIONALLY BEGAN FLOODING
WINE GRAPES
FOR UP TO FIVE MONTHS DURING THE
GROWING SEASON.
WE WERE CALLED CRAZY BY A LOT OF
OUR NEIGHBORS.
BUT WE WERE ABLE THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO THAT RECHARGE UP TO
FORTY FIVE HUNDRED ACRE FEET OF
FLOODWATER THAT YEAR.
AND WE DIDN'T KILLER VINEYARD.
TWENTY ELEVEN.
KIND OF.
I EARNED THE NICKNAME OF THE
FATHER OF GROUNDWATER RECHARGE
OR PROBABLY MORE APTLY.
APPROPRIATE GRANDFATHER GRANTHA
FOR. SOME GROUNDWATER RECHARGE.
BUT WE ALSO CAPTURED THE WE
FLIPPED IT FEEL PART OF PLANNING
A CROP PROVING THAT WE COULD
TERM FARMLAND INTO US LARGE
RECHARGE AREAS.
TO CAPTURE THE FLOODWATER WHILE
IMPROVING GROUNDWATER CONDITIONS
AT THE SAME TIME.
LAST YEAR IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE FEET
LEFT THE BASE AND DID FLOOD
RELEASE THAT WERE LOST TO THE
OCEAN.
WEEKS FLAT AS WE EXPAND OUR
PROJECT TO IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
WE BEGAN FLOODING WALLETS.
ALMONDS
SPECIALS AN OLIVE WITH.
PUSHING IT TO THE LIMIT.
FOR THE PURPOSE OF GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE.
WE DID THIS DURING THE PERIOD
FROM NOW FEBRUARY THROUGH JULY.
IT'S THE BIT WITH PRETTY
UNPRECEDENTED.
WE HAVE A VINEYARD ONE VINEYARD
THAT LAST YEAR WE PUT THIRTEEN
ACRE FEET OF WATER ON FOR
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE.
WE EXPANDED OUR PROJECT DEATH
CLICK SAY TO TO OVER.
FIVE THOUSAND ACRES.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
NOT ONLY DOES THIS WATER
REPLENISH OUR AQUIFER BUT IT
PROVIDES HABITAT FOR WILDLIFE.
PRIMARILY SHOREBIRDS AND
WATERFOWL WE HAD ALL TYPES OF
BIRDS COMING INTO OUR REGION
JUST BECAUSE WE HAVE APPLIED THE
WATER TO OUR FIELDS.
WE EVEN HAD SENATOR FEINSTEIN
VISITOR PROJECT TO AND OFFER HER
SUPPORT AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL.
THE FLOODWATER BECAUSE LEVY
BREAKS AND FLOODING DOWNSTREAM
TO THE DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND OTHER FARM LAND ON ITS WAY
TO THE OCEAN.
THE TERRANOVA WERE EXPANDING OUR
RECHARGE EFFORTS WERE BUILDING
MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL
ENABLE US TO CAPTURE. UP TO
THIRTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET PER
MONTH WHEN FLOODWATERS AVAILABLE
TO SPREAD ON UP TO EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND ACRES OF. OUR FARM AND
OUR NEIGHBORS FARMS.
BY RECHARGING IN OUR AREA WERE
STARTING TO. REBUILD THE
AQUIFER.
TO CORRECT NOT ONLY OUR BASIN.
SURROUNDING BASINS TO THE WEST
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT WATER
DOESN'T REMAIN IN ONE PLACE IT
DEFTLY MOVES FROM ONE AREA TO
ANOTHER.
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY NINE IS
NEEDED EVEN MORE WITH CLIMATE
CHANGE.
WE EXPECT A THREE.
INCREASING WATER FLOWS FOR
INFLOWS HIGHER. HIGHER SNOW
LEVELS TO WHERE NORMALLY WE READ
WE CAN HOLD OUR WATER IN THE.
STERN ABOUT A.
THIS A GOOD OR A REAL GAME
CHANGER FOR US THEN.
IT CAN ALLOW GROWERS THEMSELVES
TO REBUILD THE UNDERGROUND WATER
SUPPLY FOR FARMING AND FOR
COMMUNITIES. BY CAPTURING FLOOD
WATER AND STORING THEM
UNDERGROUND. A REALLY SIMPLE
CONT A CONCEPT SUCH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THINK KICKS HIS THEA
HASTY ARRIVAL.
STACEY SOLOMON ON THE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR STABLE
CONSERVATION.
LAW AND I'M HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. A WE
REQUEST THAT. THIS BILL RECEIVE
AN AYE VOTE IN ORDER TO ALLOW IT
TO CONTINUE TO SERVE. AS A
VEHICLE FOR DISCUSSION
NEGOTIATION RESOLUTION OF
IMPORTANT ISSUES CONCERNING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF SIGMA.
AND THE REPLENISHMENT STATES
VITAL GROUNDWATER SUPPLIES.
SUSTAIN CONSERVATION HAS BEEN
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN ADVANCING
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE SINCE
TWENTY ELEVEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH DON CAMERON.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING PRIMARILY
THE NOT EXCLUSIVELY ON ON FARM.
Y. RECHARGE.
WE UNDERSTOOD OBVIOUSLY WE
UNDERSTOOD THE IMPORTANCE OF
RECHARGE BEFORE SIGMA BUT THE
PASSAGE OF THAT ACT MADE OUR
AWARENESS AND A RECOGNITION OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS OF
RECHARGE THAT MUCH HIGHER.
WE ARE.
WE BELIEVE THAT RECHARGE WILL BE
VITAL TO IMPLEMENTING SIGMA IN A
WAY THAT MITIGATES ITS IMPACT BY
ENHANCING SUPPLY.
I AND THE BERRIES IN EMPLOYING
RECHARGE.
TO THE FULLEST EXTENT NEAT BE
REDUCED TO REMOVED WHILE
PROTECTING EXISTING WATER RIGHTS
AND ENVIRONMENTAL USES.
ALL WE KNOW THAT THE BENEFICIAL
USE ISSUE IS HIGHLY CONTENTIOUS.
ARE WE BELIEVE THAT WATER
MANAGERS DEEP UNCERTAINTY ABOUT
HOW TO PROCEED WITH RECHARGE
PRAGUE PROJECTS WITHOUT. RISKING
REGULATORY ACTION HAS BEEN BOTH
THE CAUSE AND RESULT OF A GREAT
DEAL OF THAT CONTENTION.
THAT UNCERTAINTY NEEDS TO BE
REMOVED SO THAT GSA'S AND OTHERS
CAN UTILIZE RECHARGE TO THE
MAXIMUM EXTENT POSSIBLE.
A WE BELIEVE THAT THE AMENDMENTS
PROPOSED BY THE COMMITTEE AND
THE ANALYSIS OR A VERY POSITIVE
STEP IN THAT DIRECTION WE
SUPPORT THEM WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT IT'S
NECESSARY TO MAKE PROGRESS TO OF
MAKE THE PROCESS FOR OBTAINING
TEMPORARY WATER RIGHTS.
ARE CURRENTLY FOUND IN EMERGENCY
DECLARATIONS PERMANENT IT'S
VITAL THAT GSA'S AND OTHER
MANAGERS BE ABLE TO OBTAIN THESE
TEMPORARY RIGHTS QUICKLY.
ENOUGH TO BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THESE VERY
TRANSITORY HIGH FLOWS THAT SAID
WE ALSO SUPPORT EITHER FURTHER
DEFINING IN LIMITING THE TERMS
UNDER WHICH THE SEQUEL
EXEMPTION.
INCLUDED THAT PROCESS CAN BE
EMPLOYED OR FINDING OTHER
MECHANISMS THAT PROVIDE BOTH
QUICK RESPONSE AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION.
WE RECOGNIZE AGAIN THAT THE
ISSUES HERE KILEY CONTROVERSIAL.
WE.
ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE TIME TO
RESOLVE THEM SO THAT RECHARGE
CAN BE INCORPORATED TO GS PEAS
IS NOW.
WE REQUEST VOTE AYE ON AB TWENTY
SIX FORTY NINE SO THAT IT MAY
CONTINUE TO SERVE AS A CATALYST
IN VEHICLE. FOR THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION THANK YOU ALL ASK
OF THOSE WHO WANT TO. ADD ON AS
A SUPPORT TO THE MEASURE PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN
FIRST CAROLING ABOUT THE TULARE
COUNTY BORDER SUPERVISORS IN
STRONG SUPPORT PICKING.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS CHAIR.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS
MARYANN WARMER DAM OF THE REAL
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE I WOULD ALSO NOTE.
THAT THIS APPROACH WILL HELP
ADDRESS THE INTEGRITY OF THE
AQUIFER ITSELF FOR LONG TERM
ACCESS AS A RESOURCE FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PACMAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
OKAY THE TWO WITNESSES SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES.
OKAY.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
AT MANNING ON BEHALF OF THE.
WATSON'S WATER DISTRICT MOJAVE
WATER AGENCY. FIRST LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE WORKING WITH
YOUR STAFF ON THE AMENDMENTS TO
THE BILL WE THINK THEY GO A LONG
WAY TO ADDRESSING SOME OF THE
CONCERNS WE RAISED.
UNFORTUNATELY NOT ALL THE WAY
AND WE THINK THE BILL STILL
NEEDS ARE SIGNIFICANT WORK.
.
WE.
OF COURSE
SUPPORT THE IDEA OF TAKING FLOOD
FLOWS.
ACCESS FLOWS ONE OF SURPLUS
WATER AVAILABLE AND RECHARGING
GROUND WATER BASINS.
WETLANDS FOR EXAMPLE HAS AN
OVERDRAFT GROUNDWATER BASIN
BECAUSE OF LACK OF. AVAILABILITY
OF IMPORTED WATER.
.
HAVING SAID THAT WE'VE WORKED ON
THIS ISSUE FOR OVER THREE YEARS
THERE WAS.
TO BILL TWO BILLS BY MISS
EGGMAN.
OUR INCLUDING ONE THAT WE WERE
ABLE TO FIX.
AND THEN SHE DROPPED THE BILL.
A SECOND BILL THAT WE WORKED ON
A WORK GROUP.
WITH AQUA AND OTHERS UP FOR
OVER A YEAR.
AND I AND AND NOW THIS BILL AND.
THERE ARE TWO.
BRILL UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
FROM THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT WE THINK NEEDS FURTHER WORK
AND THEIR SIGNIFICANT FOR
EVERYONE IN THE STATE.
FIRST THEIR TISSUES FOR IN
DELTA ISSUES AND.
BASICALLY. YOU NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE DELTAS OF
CIRCUMSTANCES OR. IN A SURPLUS
CONDITION.
AND THAT THERE CONSISTENT WITH
WHAT WE CALL TERM NINETY ONE
WHICH IS TO MAKE SURE THAT.
ALL THE WATER SYSTEMS THAT FEED
INTO THE DELTA HAVE ENOUGH WATER
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL PURPOSES.
AND THAT YOU'RE NOT TAKING
WATER OUT OF THE SYSTEM. THAT IS
INTENDED TO THE FOR THE
ENVIRONMENT OR DOWNSTREAM WATER
USAGE THE SECOND ISSUE IS FOR.
RIVERS THAT WATER SYSTEM OUTSIDE
THE DELTA.
AND IN THAT RESPECT
ON THIS BILL AS CURRENTLY
WRITTEN COULD AFFECT SENIOR
WATER RIGHT HOLDERS NAM AND
JUNIOR WATER RIGHT HOLDERS
ADVERSELY.
AND SO WE HAVE MET WITH THE THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU ON MISTER
ARAMBULA FOR MEETING WITH.
ONE OF MY CLIENTS YESTERDAY TO
OFFER SOME IDEAS AND SOME
LANGUAGE.
WE WOULD LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH HIM TO TRY TO WORK
THIS OUT BUT.
WE WOULD BE.
LESS THAN CANDID IF WE DIDN'T
TELL THE COMMITTEE AND THE
MEMBERS THAT THERE'S SO WE THINK
THERE'S STILL A FAIR AMOUNT OF
WORK TO BE DONE HERE THANK YOU.
MR CARE MEMBERS AYE IF YOU
INDULGE ME I'M WHITNEY WILEY
WITHIN ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES AND WE DON'T
ACTUALLY HAVE LOTS A POSITION. I
WANTED TO SQUEEZE THEM HAVE A
TWEENER.
BUT DIDN'T MOVE FAST ENOUGH.
AND I JUST WANT TO TALK MORE
ABOUT A PROCESS SO ED MENTIONED.
.
THERE BILLS FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN SIXTEEN SIX AB SIX FORTY
SEVEN AM THEM. LAST YEAR'S
FOURTEEN TWENTY SEVEN. OCT WAS
BEEN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE FOR
THE PAST SEVEN YEARS.
IN TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THAN OF
A DOCUMENT WAS ISSUED CALLED THE
GROUND WATER FRAMEWORK OUT WHICH
CALLED FOR AS ONE OF THE ITS
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS BENEFICIAL
USE UP I HAVE RECHARGE FOR
BENEFICIAL USE.
WE STARTED AT THAT TIME WORKING
WITH OUR MEMBERS TRYING TO FIND
A PATH FORWARD AND UNFORTUNATELY
WE HAVE MEMBERS ON BOTH SIDES OF
THIS ISSUE.
AND OUT WE SPENT A ONE YEAR AT
INITIALLY LOOKING FOR A WAY TO
COME UP WITH LEGISLATION THAT
WOULD SOLVE THIS ISSUE.
AND BEFORE WE HAD A CHANCE TO.
GET.
TOO FAR DOWN THE ROAD OUT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN THEN
INTRODUCED SIX FORTY SEVEN OUT
WE. HAD.
.
MEMBERS THAT OPPOSE THE BILL.
IN IN ENDED UP WITH SOME OF THE
SITUATION THAT AB MENTION AND
THEY END UP FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN SO OVER THE COURSE OF THIS
LAST YEAR WE HAVE SPENT.
I'M.
ACCOUNTABLE HOURS
TRYING TO BRING OUR MEMBERS
TOGETHER TO FIND A SOLUTION AND
WE'VE ACTUALLY DONE THAT. OUT
IT'S NOT A LEGISLATIVE APPROACH
IS AN ADMINISTRATIVE APPROACH
I'M I'VE SHARED IT WITH THE
COMMITTEE CONSULTANT AND WE
SHARED IT WITH THE AUTHORS.
OUT BOTH ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN
AND AND DOCTOR ARAMBULA IT'S
OFFICE WE ARE MEETING WITH THE
BOARD AND BOARD STAFF NEXT WEEK
ON MAY FIRST TO TALK ABOUT THE
PROPOSAL THAT WE'VE PUT TOGETHER
TO TRY TO MOVE THIS.
ISSUE FORWARD I'M NOT HERE TO
ASK YOU TO VOTE NOW OR OR AYE
AYE ON THE BILL BUT JUST TO LAY
OUT THAT THERE IS A PROCESS IN
PLACE THAT WE'RE TRYING TO FIND
A WAY TO BRING OUR MEMBERS IN
PARTICULAR.
AND THEN BRING OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ONTO THE ISSUE TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING HOW JUST A SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA UNFORTUNATELY
OPPOSED TO THIS TIME AND I WHEN
I THINK THE AUTHOR FOR THE WORK
HE'S DOING ON RECOGNIZING THIS
ISSUE WE DO SUPPORT FROM A
RECHARGE ESPECIALLY THE WORK
THAT SUSTAINABLE CONSERVATION IS
DOING. IS REALLY HELPFUL AND IN
THE VALLEY.
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE.
THAT THAT JOB. BENEFICIAL USES
NOT BEEN SHOWN THAT THERE IT HAS
THE BEEN THE THE BARRIER TO TO
GETTING GROUND WATER RECHARGE
PROJECTS IN PLACE ARM. AND THAT
WE'RE CONCERNED WITH OPENING UP
THE BENEFICIAL USE DESIGNATION
AT ALL BECAUSE IT DOES HAVE SUCH
SERIOUS IMPLICATIONS AND I'M I
DO THINK THE COMMITTEE STAFF
DID.
GREAT WORK TRYING TO FIND
LANGUAGE THAT THAT IS MORE
WORKABLE.
BUT I THINK WE STILL HAVE
CONCERNS WITH THIS APPROACH AND
OUR. PARTICULAR BEEN SAYING THAT
SOMEONE HAS A BENEFICIAL USE TO
A PORTION OF A GROUND WATER BASE
AND.
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR PRIVATIZATION OF
GROUNDWATER BASIN SAYING THAT
PEOPLE HAVE SPECIFIC ACCESS TO
SPECIFIC PARTS OF THAT AQUIFER
WHEN IN REALITY THESE ARE PUBLIC
RESOURCES.
.
ADDITIONALLY WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE USE OF SEQUEL
EXEMPTIONS.
.
OUT NGUYEN CHANGING A WATER
RIGHT THE WATER BOARD TESTIFYING
TO DETERMINATIONS THAT NO LEGAL
USER OF WATERS INJURED OR
THERE'S NO UNREASONABLE FACTS
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE AND WHILE MOST
OF THESE PROJECTS. WON'T HAVE
THOSE ISSUES SOME CODE AND THE
SEQUEL PROCESS IS HELPFUL FOR
DETERMINING IMPACTS THAT CAN
AFFECT THESE PEOPLE'S PROPERTY
RIGHTS WAR. UP IMPACTS TO TO
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
AND SO WE THINK THAT THERE'S
THERE COULD BE ANOTHER APPROACH
FORWARD ON THIS ISSUE I AM AND
WOULD BE MORE SUPPORTIVE OF
LOOKING AT WAYS OF CAN WE DO
THIS PERMITTING IN ADVANCE.
CAN WE DETERMINE AT WHAT
CONDITIONS IS IT OKAY TO PULL
THIS WATER RECHARGE THIS AND SAY
YOU'RE GOOD TO GO RATHER THAN
SAYING. IT'S POURING WE HAVE TO
HURRY RIGHT NOW.
WE THINK THAT MORE WORK TO BE
DONE OUT FRONT TO GET A BETTER
APPROACH OVER ALL AND REALLY
HELP MAKE THESE RECHARGE AREAS.
HOW SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS
ISSUE?
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BIRD THOSE WILL POINT
TO ADD ON IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION.
KATHY CHO THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ADOPT BY REFERENCE MY
COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS MISTER
MANNING AND MISS WYLIE THINKING.
GOOD MORNING PUBLIC GARZA WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND ALSO
IN OPPOSITION WE SUPPORT THE
GOAL BUT SHARE THE CONCERNS
ABOUT THE BENEFICIAL EXCHANGE.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MONICA
MILLER REPRESENTING THE SANTA
CLARA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT AND
WE ARE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
THANK YOU.
WELL THAT WE DON'T KNOW WITHOUT
ABOUT CALIFORNIA AND FORTUNE IN
SUPPORT.
CHRISTY FOR WITH THREE DOLLARS
MISCIBLE WATER DISTRICT AND WE
ARE OPPOSED FOR THE SAME REASONS
OUTLINED BY THE WESTLANDS WATER.
KIM DELFINO WITH DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND WE SUPPORT THAT THE
THANK YOU.
IF YOU CREDIT WITH AN ARCHERY
SOURCES DEFENSE COUNSEL
REGRETFULLY STILL OPPOSE BUT
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHORED A RESULTS IN
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THINKING.
CHRIS SCOTT REPRESENT THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT
WE SHARE THE OPPOSE A LOS
AMENDED THAT POSITION CHAIRED BY
WESTLANDS.
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO.
DICE QUESTIONS SIMILAR.
DOCTOR ARAMBULA. YOU KNOW I
DEFINITELY WITH THE CONCEPT AND
YOU KNOW I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD. TRY
AND FIND A WAY ON TO BE ABLE TO
USE THIS WATER FOR RECHARGE.
.
MAYBE YOU CAN ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONCERNS BECAUSE I KNOW.
AND THIS BILL IS BEFORE US LAST.
THAT LAST YEAR I THINK AS WELL.
AND AND THE THE CONCERN HERE IS
NOT THAT WE DON'T THINK THAT
WOULD BE.
YA BENEFICIAL USE TO TO
RECHARGE JOB OFFERS AND HAVE
THAT WATER BUT RATHER.
WHAT'S THE IMPACT TO DEATH IN A
POTENTIALLY OTHER WATER USERS
AND IS THAT WATER THAT'S BEING
TAKEN THAT. MIGHT OTHERWISE GO
TO OTHERS AND THEN THERE'S ALSO.
YOUR POTENTIAL ECOLOGICAL
CONCERNS AS WELL.
SO.
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE THERE HAS
BEEN A STAKEHOLDER GROUP WORKING
ON THIS ISSUE THAT THEY'RE
GETTING PRETTY CLOSE TO
SOMETHING THAT TO A CONCEPT THAT
COULD WORK THAT WOULD ALLOW
THIS.
SO I GUESS MAYBE TWO PARTS IS
YOU KNOW HOW.
IT DOESN'T SEEM THAT YOU'RE
LEGISLATURE RIGHT NOW ADDRESS
ADDRESSES THAT MAYBE I'M MISSING
SOMETHING AND THEN.
SECONDLY. WHY NOT ALLOW THAT
STAKEHOLDER PROCESS TO KIND OF
PHOENICIAN AND MAYBE GET TO A
PLACE WHERE WE BUT WE WILL BE
ABLE TO USE WATER IN A WAY
THAT'S FOR?
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE
THANK YOU AND.
I APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS AND
FRANKLY THE CONVERSATION THAT
WE'RE HAVING HERE TODAY.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT FOR OUR
STATES TO HAVE THE SUBSTANTIVE.
DISCUSSIONS BUT ALL ADDRESSED
YOUR QUESTION DIRECTLY IF I
CAN'T.
THERE'S AN URGENCY TO THIS
MATTER WHICH IS THIS GOVERNOR IS
LEAVING AT THE END OF THE YEAR.
AND IF WE DON'T CODIFY HIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER BEFORE HE
LEAVES.
WE'RE STARTING ON THE FIRST DAY
OF THE NEW ADMINISTRATION TO
CONVINCE THEM OF WHAT WE HAVE
ALREADY ACCOMPLISHED SO FAR.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION ABOUT
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS
THAT'S GOING ON.
I'VE HAD SOME PRELIMINARY
DISCUSSIONS WITH DOCTOR EGGMAN
AND WOULD BE WILLING TO
COLLABORATE AND WORK WITH HER.
TO JOIN OUR PROCESS CITIES SO
THAT WE CAN DO THIS FOR THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT IT IS A
DIFFICULT NEEDLE TO THREAD AND
ONE THAT WILL REQUIRE A LOT OF
US TO COLLABORATE AND WORK
TOGETHER. I DON'T PRETEND TO
HAVE THE ANSWERS AND REALLY HAVE
BEEN PLEASED TO WORK WITH THIS
COMMITTEE AND AND THE STAFF AS
WELL AS WANTING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION. TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT WE CAN
ACCOMPLISH.
YOU KNOW I WAS MOVED A BIT BY
WHAT A SIERRA SAID THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S POURING AND NOW
WE'RE TRYING TO CREATE A PLANNED
WELL I'M TRYING TO HAVE THOSE
DISCUSSIONS NOW.
SO THAT THE NEXT TIME IT'S
RAINING INSTEAD OF THIS EXCESS
UNUSED WATER GOING OUT TO THE
OCEAN. WE HAVE THE ABILITY WE
HAVE A PLAN FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO DO THE DESIGN
GROUNDWATER RECHARGE AS WE SEE
FIT AS A LEGISLATIVE BODY. BUT I
DON'T PRETEND TO HAVE ALL THE
ANSWERS AND REALLY AM LOOKING
FOR THIS.
SUBSTANTIVE DISCUSSION TO
CONTINUE TO IMPROVE UPON. THIS
BILL AND REALLY ASK THIS POLICY
COMMITTEE IF I CAN TO GIVE US
THAT TIME TO GIVE US.
THE ENERGY TO CONTINUE THIS
MOVEMENT SO THAT WE CAN GET A
BILL SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR THIS
YEAR.
S..
THE TRAIL. IN CARE.
THANK YOU DOCTOR ARAMBULA FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL TO OUR
ATTENTION AND APOLOGIES THAT I
MISSED SOME OF YOUR PRESENTATION
AS I'M RUNNING AROUND BETWEEN
COMMITTEES.
I WAS WONDERING IF YOU COULD
ADDRESS HOW YOUR BILL WOULD BE
WORKED ON DURING THE DRYER YEARS
FOR OUR STATE AND I ABSOLUTELY
HERE. THAT THE CONCERNS AND
QUESTIONS ON FIRE MENTAL ISSUES
BUT. TOTALLY IN IN.
AND REALLY AND ON THE WAY THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT AN ISSUE
THAT WE. HAVE TO ADDRESS AN
ADDRESS CRITICALLY SO IF YOU CAN
TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT. ON THE
BILL IMPLEMENTATION AND HOW TO
WORK DURING DRIER TIMES.
REVEALED THAT CAN I GET A.
MORE SPECIFICALLY HOW CAN I
ANSWER THE QUESTION DIRECTLY
LEFT I FEEL I'M HEARING YOU BUT
I'M TRYING TO MAKE SURE I'M
ADDRESSING.
WELL IN TERMS OF YOUR.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PLANNING
FOR THE FUTURE AND HOW WE'RE
COLLECTING GROUND WATER AND THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF THAT.
WELL WE DON'T HAVE THE RAIN SO
WE'VE BEEN HAVING NOW. WHAT DO
YOU FORESEE WOULD BE AWAY THAT
THIS BILL WOULD BE IMPLEMENTED
OR CAN BE HELPFUL TO THE STATE
IN THE DRY YEARS I ANTICIPATE
THIS BILL HAS NO EFFECT THAT?
IF A SENIOR RIGHT STIFF JUNIOR
RIGHTS IF ENVIRONMENTAL RIGHTS
HAVE NOT BEEN MET THIS BILL HAS
NO. USE AT ALL.
IT'S ONLY IN THOSE ONCE IN A
DECADE.
TYPES OF SITUATIONS LIKE WE HAD
LAST YEAR. WHERE THERE'S ACCESS
ON USED WATER THAT'S ACTUALLY
PRESENTING A HARM TO OUR STATE?
THE RISK TOO DOWNSTREAM IS THE
POTENTIAL FLOODING THAT CAN
OCCUR WITH THAT MUCH WATER. IT'S
IN THOSE OPPORTUNITIES THAT I
REALLY WANT OUR STATE TOOK CRAFT
A PLAN. TO HELP US TO DEAL WITH
AN OVER DRAFTING PROBLEM AS WELL
AS SICK.
AND.
IF I CAN SOAPBOX JUST FOR HALF
A SECOND.
WORKING IN THE ER I SAW THE
EFFECT OF OUR DROUGHT ON MY
COMMUNITY ON MY PEOPLE AND
REALLY DO BELIEVE IT WILL TAKE%
LAWS LIKE THIS DOING GROUNDWATER
RECHARGE. TO HELP MY COMMUNITY
TO HAVE SUSTAINABILITY AND
BELIEVES THAT.
HAVING SOMETHING IN PLACE FOR
THOSE FUTURE WHAT YEARS WILL
ALLOW OUR COMMUNITIES TO THRIVE.
MY OF MISTER SALAS FOLLOWED BY
THE SUPREME.
THANK YOU THAT THANK YOU DOCTOR
EVELYN FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FORWARD.
TO STICK.
YOU KNOW THE WAY I SEE THIS BILL
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG IS
YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO USE EXCESS
WATER LIKE WE HAD.
PREVIOUSLY AND ACTUALLY PUT
THAT TO GOOD USE WHICH IS.
I GROUND BANKING OR HELPING.
HELPING MUNICIPALITY OUR WATER
DISTRICTS WITH THEIR RECHARGE.
AND THAT'S NOT JUST ONLY IN THE
VALLEY BUT THAT'S EVEN THE
CENTRAL COAST WHERE THEY HAVE
THESE ISSUES.
ALONG THE BORDER AND EVEN THAT.
TOWARDS THE NEVADA BORDER AS
WELL.
.
SO.
MY FIRST OFF IS THAT.
IS THAT WHAT YOU'RE AIMED AT
DOING.
WITH THIS LEGISLATION BECAUSE
ANOTHER WAS AMENDMENTS AND.
OUR UNDERSTANDING IS ANY MEDIUM
OR HIGH.
A OVER DRAFTED. THAT GSA WILL
HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO BENEFIT
FROM THIS IN THOSE.
SITUATIONS OF HIGH
PRECIPITATION.
BUT IT'S ANY OVER DRAFTED OR
MEDIUM OVER DRAFTED THAT.
GSA THAT WOULD HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO BE ABLE TO APPLY
FOR THE SENATE AND THAT'LL HELP
THEM MEET THEIR SINGLES THAT'S
GREAT.
OKAY.
I SEE THIS IS A GOOD MEASURE
I'LL HOME OF THE BILL.
IF WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WE DO HAVE. COLLEAGUE.
HI.
.
DEFINITELY I APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND IT MAKES
SENSE.
BUT UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITIES
AND I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH EVERYONE BECAUSE THE WATER
IS FLOWING SOMEWHERE ELSE AND
SOMETIMES THOSE SOMEWHERE ELSE
PEOPLE. WANT ACCESS.
AND MY BIGGEST CONCERN IS THE
SEQUEL EXCEPTION.
GIVEN THAT THIS COULD.
DEPENDING ON WHERE THE WATER IS
FLOWING AND WHERE IT'S BEING
USED CONCERN ONLY IMPACT.
SOME OF OUR NATURAL AREAS AND
THEIR ABILITY TO HAVE WATER.
IN ECO SYSTEMS THAT ARE
DESIGNED FOR OCCASIONAL
FLOODING.
AND YOU KNOW OF COURSE WE
RESTRICT THAT.
THEN THAT CAN DISTURB THOSE ECO
SYSTEMS AND I'M WONDERING IF HOW
A AND ONE OF THE ARM. A.
GENTLEMAN WHO SPOKE ARM ALLUDED
TO THIS IF THERE ARE WAYS OF
DOING SECRET EXEMPTIONS IN
ADVANCE FOR SOME OF THE MORE
SENSITIVE AREAS AND AREAS THAT
WE KNOW ARE SUBJECT TO PERIODIC
FLOODING. SO THAT YOU HAVE THOSE
SEQUEL OUT DOCUMENTS ARE KIND OF
AT THE READY WHEN THAT TIME
COMES OR EVEN THE APPROVAL STEIN
IS THAT SOMETHING THAT YOU'VE
CONSIDERED WITH YOUR AMENDMENTS.
I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
CONSIDER THINGS AS WORK GOING
FORWARD BUT MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT THE TEMPORARY PERMITS GIVEN
BY THAT STATE WATER.
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD CAN BE
THAT MECHANISM TO ENSURE THAT
WERE SENDING WATERS TO AREAS
THAT ARE MORE. ENVIRONMENTALLY
READY TO RECEIVE THEM
MY STRUGGLE THUS FAR GOING
FORWARD HAS BEEN THAT SEQUEL BY
ITS NATURE MAY PRO. THE PERIOD
BEFORE WE CAN APPLY THESE WATERS
AND WE MAY MISS OUR WINDOW OF
HAVING ACCESS ON USED WATER
RIGHT THAT'S WHY I'M WONDERING
WHETHER THOSE THOSE AREN'T
EVALUATIONS CAN BE DONE IN
ADVANCE OF THE. FLOOD EVENT SO
THAT.
WHEN CERTAIN FLOODING HAPPENS
IN CERTAIN AREAS YOU PRETTY MUCH
KNOW I WOULD THINK BY NOW WHERE
MOST OF THE WHERE A LOT OF THE
WATER'S GOING WOULD HAVE GONE.
AND WHERE THE FLOODING IS MORE
LIKELY TO HAPPEN BECAUSE YOU'VE
HAD SO MANY PAST EVENTS OF DOING
THE SEQUENT ALICE'S IN ADVANCE
AND LOOKING AT WHAT DIFFERENT.
KIND OF TAKES OF THAT WATER ON
WHAT KIND OF AN IMPACT THEY
WOULD HAVE RATHER THAN TRY TO DO
THEM IN THE MIDDLE OF THE FLOOD
EVENT I AGREE.
THOSE TEMPORARY ORDERS
DID THEY HAVE SOME SORT OF
SEQUEL ANALYSIS IN THEM OR WHERE
THAT WAS PART OF THE ORDER TO
SAY WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO A
SEQUEL ANALYSIS BECAUSE WE'RE.
ARE IN THIS EXTRAORDINARY.
CIRCUMSTANCE.
THE ONLY EVIDENCE THAT.
OUR OUR PROJECT.
WHAT WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON A
LARGE PROJECT ANY?
?
WE WE RECEIVED A FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR GRANT FROM IDW AND WHEN I
SAY WE.
THE KINGS RIVER CONSERVATION
DISTRICT.
WE HAVE WE HAVE SPENT AND
I'M GODLY AMOUNT OF TIME.
DOING AGREEMENTS DOING SEEK
WERE.
FOR OUR PROJECT OUR PROJECT IT
WAS A FLOOD WATER CORDER PROJECT
THAT WE TURNED INTO A GROUND
WATER RECHARGE PROJECT.
IT'S BEING FUNDED TO PREVENT
FLOODING DOWNSTREAM.
.
I KNOW THAT I'VE TALKED TO OTHER
GSA'S.
I'M THE CHAIRMAN FOR THE GSA IN
THE REGION I FARM.
AND POPULAR TALK OF POSSIBLY
DOING A. PAPER EITHER BASIN Y.
GSA PARA SEQUEL DOCUMENT ORI
GSA.
SECRET DOCUMENT.
SO WE DON'T HAVE THESE ISSUES
BUT.
I'M NOT SURE IF THE IN THE
EMERGENCY OF PERMITTING IF THERE
WAS IF THE QUOTE WAS PART OF
THAT ITEM. THAT'S NOT IT TO.
FIGHT THE IN THE GOVERNOR'S
EMERGENCY DECLARATIONS SEEK
THERE WAS AN EXEMPTION FROM
SEQUEL SO WHERE DID THOSE THOSE
TWO. PA TEMPORARY RIGHTS PERMITS
THAT WERE GRANTED SO FAR AT
LEAST UNDER THAT PROVISION BOTH
WERE. EXEMPTED FROM SEQUEL.
US SO THAT'S BUT THAT'S THE WAY
THAT IT CURRENTLY STANDS IN THE
LANGUAGE.
BUT LIKE I SAID BEFORE HIGH I
MEAN OUR ORGANIZATION AT LEAST
BELIEVES THAT THAT.
.
WE OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATION I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S OUR CONCERNS SO WE
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO SEE
THESE PROJECTS GO FORWARD DE PUT
TO THE DETRIMENT OF THE
ENVIRONMENT BUT. SOME KIND OF A
PROGRAMMATIC DOCUMENT OR SOME
OTHER APPROACH TO SEEK WITH THAT
MIGHT BE ABLE TO DO WHAT YOU'RE
YOU'RE SUGGESTING. TERMS OF
CREATE ADVANCE ANALYSIS SO THAT.
WHEN THE ACTUAL OF EVENTS OCCUR
YOU CAN JUST MOVE ON THE THAT
WOULD BE MY STRONG SUGGESTION
BECAUSE I'M NOT COMFORTABLE.
A VOTING ON DOING.
SEQUEL EXEMPTION SORT OF A QUID
UNIFORMLY ACROSS THE BOARD IN
MANY DIFFERENT LOCATIONS WHERE
PEOPLE MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE DONE
THIS KIND OF ANALYSIS IN THE
PAST.
AND IT SEEMS REASONABLE.
GIVEN THE HIGH PROPENSITY FOR
FLOODING IN CERTAIN AREAS WHICH
MANY WILL BE KNOWN. SO YOU COULD
DO THOSE SORTS OF PROGRAMMATIC
HERE OURS IN THE DIFFERENT AREAS
THAT I INTEND TO. MAKE
THEMSELVES.
YOU KNOW.
.
THEY'LL THEMSELVES OF THE
LEGISLATION SO THAT WOULD BE MY
SUGGESTION AND I'M HAPPY TO
CONSIDER. ANY POTENTIAL THINGS
AS WE GO FORWARD. OUR ATTEMPT
WAS REALLY TO PROVIDE AN URGENCY
TO THE GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE
ORDER AND TO TRY TO CODIFY. AND
SO WE STARTED WITH WHAT HE HAD
DONE RIGHT TO MOVE THIS
CONVERSATION BUT I'M HAPPY TO
ENGAGE AS I WAS PROCESS
CONTINUES RIGHT I UNDERSTAND I
MEAN HE WAS IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
EMERGENCY AND HE WAS RESPONDING
BUT WE'RE NOT THE MIDDLE OF
EMERGENCY NOW SO WE. HAVE TIME
TO ASK THE AGENCIES TO START
DOING SOME OF THIS WORK GOING
FORWARD I WOULD THINK.
SO I THINK THAT YOU WOULD GET A
LOT MORE SUPPORT FROM THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY IF THAT
IF AT LEAST THAT SAFETY MEASURE.
WAS ANTICIPATED AND HAVE PUT
INTO PLACE.
IN ADVANCE
SO. I WILL SUPPORT THIS TODAY
BUT I RESERVE THE RIGHT YOU KNOW
IS I SEE I I'M VERY GLAD TO SEE
THAT YOU ARE WORKING WITH ALL
THE DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS AND
CERTAINLY THE DOWN HOLD. WATER
WATER RATES YOU KNOW AND THEIR
CONCERNS AND I.
JUST WANTED TO PUT IT IN YOUR
BRAIN THAT THIS WAS MY
PARTICULAR CONCERN AND SO WHEN
IT COMES TO A VOTE ON THE FLOOR
I'LL CERTAINLY BE LOOKING TO SEE
WHAT WORK WAS DONE IN THIS AREA.
THINK IT THANK YOU THINKING WE
HAVE A QUESTION FROM MISTER
BIGELOW FOLLOWED BY MISTER
AGAINST YOU.
THANK YOU.
TO THE AUTHOR.
WHEN WE LOOK BACK AT LAST YEAR
NGUYEN NON.
IT'S FORTY SEVEN BILL WENT
FORWARD.
.
I ACTUALLY TOOK A POSITION OF OF
A NOT VOTING ON THAT. TO GIVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE ON
WITHOUT WEIGHING AND WITH YASSER
NOW.
ONE OF THAT.
GOOD PARTS OF HER BILL WHICH IS
THE PART THAT
I HAVEN'T SEEN IN YOUR BILL AT
THIS.
TIME WAS THE ABILITY TO PROTECT.
THE DOWNSTREAM USERS AND THE
WATER RIGHTS.
OF FOLKS WHO WERE. ESSENTIALLY
PROTECTED.
ARE YOU HAVING HEARD A LITTLE
BIT OF YOUR DISCUSSION TODAY YOU
SPOKE DIRECTLY ABOUT.
THE FLOOD FLOWS.
AND SO THERE'S A DISTINGUISHING
COMPONENT BETWEEN PROTECTING THE
SENIOR WATER RIGHTS IN THE
JUNIOR WATER RIGHTS AND THE
FOLKS.
WHO WERE BASICALLY TRYING TO
UTILIZE?
NOT APPROPRIATE NOT.
RECEIVE OUR ADJUDICATE ANYWAY
BUT TO UTILIZE FLOOD FLOOD
WATERS.
IS YOUR BILL SINGULAR.
IN THAT IS ONLY TALKING TO.
THE.
FLOOD FLOWS.
AND WOULD YOUR BILL AND AS IT
MOVES FORWARD WOULD YOU BE
AGREEABLE TO OUTLINING
PROTECTION.
SPECIFIC FOR THOSE SENIOR AND
JUNIOR WATER RIGHT HOLDERS.
YES.
SO I'M MORE THAN HAPPY TO
COLLABORATE AND WORK FORWARD
BOTH TO INSURE THAT SENIOR AND
JUNIOR WATER RIGHTS.
ARE PROTECTED AS WELL AS
ENVIRONMENTAL RIGHTS.
I'M WILLING TO WORK WITH
DOWNSTREAM USERS TO GIVE THEM
CONFIDENCE AND WHAT ARE BILL IS
TRYING TO ASPIRE TO.
BUT I JUST.
I FEEL LIKE I GOT TO KEEP
PUSHING I DON'T WANT TO MISS
THIS WINDOW WITH THIS GOVERNOR
ON HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER. AND AM
HAPPY TO COLLABORATE WITH DR
EGGMAN TO FIGURE OUT WHAT WE
NEED TO DO TOGETHER MOVING.
FORWARD AND MAY BE INCORPORATING
THE PORT PARTS OF HER BILL I'M
AND WOULD ENCOURAGE THOSE WHO
ARE ON THIS COMMITTEE TO
CONTINUE TO GIVE INPUT BECAUSE.
THIS IS.
THAT SOMETHING THAT I BELIEVE WE
NEED TO DO FOR STATE.
GIVEN THAT SAID I'M I'M
ENCOURAGED ARE ALSO. WOULD MISS
EGGMAN SPELL.
IT AFFORDED AN OPPORTUNITY FOR A
NUMBER OF COLLABORATIVE EFFORTS
BY DIFFERENT STAKEHOLDERS TO
COME TOGETHER OVER THE. THE
SPIRITED TIME TO PUT TOGETHER
AND WE HEARD THIS EARLIER.
TO HAVE DISCUSSIONS
TO TRY TO BRING.
.
BILL FORD.
UNFORTUNATELY IT HASN'T
MATERIALIZED AS YET.
BUT THERE ARE SOME KEY POINTS
THAT THEY HAVE.
THAT MAYBE YOU WOULD WANT TO
ENTERTAIN IF THEY COULD RAPIDLY
PUT THOSE COMPONENTS TOGETHER.
IN THIS BILL AND MAKE IT A
LITTLE MORE COMPREHENSIVE.
TO ADDRESS.
THE OVERALL BROADNESS IN SCOPE.
OF YOUR BILL WOULD YOU BE
ENCOURAGED TO MAYBE LOOK AT THAT
I'D BE HAPPY TO LOOK AT ANY
POTENTIAL BUT IF I CAN I'D LIKE
TO WORK THROUGH MISTER CHAIR AND
THAT COMMITTEE. ABSOLUTELY AND
SUCH THAT. CHANGING ONE WORD MAY
HAVE DETRIMENTAL AFFECT WE ALL
UNDERSTAND PHILLIP SO WOULD LIKE
IF POSSIBLE TO WORK THROUGH YOU
TO. ENSURE THAT THE VISION ON
THE STILL BEING A.
AN UNDERSTANDING THAT. THIS BILL
IS REALLY ONLY DEALING WITH
AREAS OF THE STATE.
WHERE YOU HAVE THE ABILITY?
FOR CONVEYANCE SYSTEMS
TO DIRECT AND CHANNEL THE
WATERS.
IT ISN'T GOING TO FACILITATE.
THE OVERALL NEED FOR ALL OF THE.
OVERDRAFT THAT'S OCCURRING.
AREAS THAT.
DON'T HAVE SURFACE WATER
COMPONENTS AND WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF. AREAS THAT ARE BEING FARM
TODAY OR UTILIZED. AND THEY'RE
BEING OVER DRAFTED
WITH NO ABILITY TO RECHARGE.
WITH THIS OPPORTUNITY STILL
AFFORD THEM WHEN THERE ARE FLOOD
WATERS.
FROM FLOOD.
.
CHANNELS THAT MAY EXIST
NATURALLY.
TO BE UTILIZED.
DO YOU SEE THAT IN YOUR BILL.
A MY UNDERSTANDING IS IN THOSE
HIGH PRECIPITATION YEARS WILL
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO ON A
FARM RECHARGE TO DO RECHARGE
BASINS OR TO DO.
INJECTION WELLS THAT WILL ALLOW
US TO USE THESE FLOOD FLOWS TO.
A FILL ARE DEPLETED AQUIFER'S
RIGHT.
AND I'M NOT STE
CERTAINLY OH ALWAYS INCREASE BY
INJECTION WAS BECAUSE I DON'T
KNOW. WHAT THAT REALLY MEANS TO
ME ON THE FILTRATION?
OF THE WATER GOING DOWN I KIND
OF FIND MYSELF MORE ENCOURAGED
BY THE NATURAL.
OF FLOW OF WATER TO.
PERCOLATE THROUGH THE GROUND AND
THE FILTRATION SYSTEM IN A MORE
NATURAL BALLISTIC Y..
BECAUSE OBJECTION TIME TO GET
SHOULD.
FARTHER DOWN QUICKER.
WITH ALL THE SAME CONTAMINANTS
THAT MAY EXIST OR MAY NOT EXIST.
BUT I'M COURAGE BY YOUR WORDS
AND THOUGHTS HERE TODAY I SEE
ABA PERSON WANTS TO RESPOND.
RIGHT MISTER BIGELOW.
HAVE CHAIR OF THE GFA THAT THE
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND ACRES
WITH ABSOLUTELY NO SURFACE WATER
DELIVERIES. WE ARE IN IT AT
EXTREME LEE BAD SITUATION. OF
WITH SIGMA.
UP THE AREAS THAT ARE IN OUR
THAT ARE SIMILAR TO OURS HAVE NO
INFRASTRUCTURE BECAUSE THEY'VE
NEVER HAD THE WATER. TO CONVEY.
WE'VE WE PUT IN FOR SEVERAL
DIFFERENT GRANTS.
AND WE GET REJECTED BECAUSE.
GRETA RECHARGE IS NOT BENEFICIAL
USE.
.
SO THAT THE REAL PROBLEM AND.
AS WE AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
NO THE PUT OUT WITHOUT TELEGRAM
WATER RECHARGE BEING BENEFICIAL
USE. WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO GET
REJECTIONS.
FOR THAT CONVEYANCE THAT WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED TO BE TO COME
AND COMPLIANCE WITH SIGMA.
SO.
THAT THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FACED
WITH.
THANK YOU FOR THE.
ION.
UNDERSTANDING OF YOUR DISTRICT
BUT LET ME BEG THE QUESTION.
HOW DO YOU RECHARGE WHERE YOU
HAVE NO ABILITY TO CAPTURE A
CHANNELER MOVE OTHER THAN
RAINFALL AND THAT'S A NATURAL
OCCURRENCE KNOW IF IF YOU HAVE
NO? SOURCE OF WATER IF YOU'RE
NOT NEAR RIVER.
YOU'RE RIGHT YEAH YOU'RE ONLY.
THE ONLY WAY YOU'RE GONNA BE
COMPLYING IS TO HAVE SOMEONE
ELSE RECHARGE FOR YOU IN AN
ADJACENT GSA.
OR GONNA HAVE TO IDLE GROUND CUT
OKAY AND AND THAT DILUTES JOBS
YOU LOSE A COMMUNITY ABSOLUTELY
UNDERSTAND THAT AND THAT
HAPPENS.
A GREAT DEAL THROUGHOUT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY RIGHT WE HAVE A
NUMBER OF POCKETS THAT OUR
NEIGHBORS TO BUT THERE COMES A
DEPRESSIONS.
ARE LINKED TOGETHER.
BUT YOU HAVE TO HAVE ONE FILLED
BEFORE YOU CAN FILL THE OTHER.
AND THAT BECOMES THE SCENARIO OF
EITHER SUCCESS OR FAILURE.
SO I APPLAUD WHAT YOU'RE DOING
AND I AM ENCOURAGED BY WHAT
MISTER ARAMBULA IS. TRYING TO DO
HERE.
.
TODAY THERE'S JUST A NUMBER OF
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS BEFORE.
SUPPORTED AND AND.
BUT I WANT TO HELP IT AND I
WANT THE ENCOURAGE I AM COURAGE
BY HIS WILLINGNESS TO TAKE.
AND WORK WITH SOME AMENDMENTS TO
OUTLINE THOSE PROTECTIONS OF THE
WATER RIGHT HOLDERS.
AND AND WORK WITH SOME OF THE
OTHER COMPONENTS AS I'VE
DISCUSSED.
SO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU.
SOME MEMBER CHIU.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU ARE DOCTOR
RAMBLER.
VERY QUICKLY I I'M VERY.
ENCOURAGED BY YOUR COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH HER
OPPOSITION ON THE WATER RIGHT
ISSUE AS WELL. AS THE.
OF AN ADVANCE PERMITTING THE
USE OF THEM IDEA SO I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL TODAY AND
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MATHIS.
I WANT TO START BY SAYING YOU
AND I'VE HAD SEVERAL SEVERAL
CONVERSATIONS OVER THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND I REALLY TRULY
DO APPRECIATE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN YOU AND I AND WITH OUR
OFFICES.
I DO LIKE THE DIRECTION THIS IS
HEADING.
I SHARE A LOT OF THE SAME
CONCERNS AS MISTER BIGELOW.
WITH OUR.
SENIOR WATER RIGHTS FIRST JUNIOR
WATER RIGHTS AND EVERYTHING
GOING ON BUT WE MUST MOVE
FORWARD AND FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
GET THE CONVEYANCE.
TO GET THE RECHARGE.
ARE.
I I KNOW A LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT
OBJECTION WHILE SO I DO
APPRECIATE THE THE ABILITIES
THEIR.
QUITE FRANKLY IT'S BEYOND ME
WHY WE ARE LOOKING AT DOING
WETLANDS
WITH INJECTION WELLS WITH THEN.
SO WE HAVE HABITAT AS WELL AS
GROUND WATER RECHARGE AS A
PRIORITY.
ON AND LOOK AT IT AS A HOLISTIC
VIEW SO BOTH ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERNS ARE MAD AS WELL AS.
ON THE BACK END OF SIGMA WHICH
WE ALL KNOW IS GETTING WATER.
BACK INTO THE AQUIFER.
THAT THE NATURAL WAY IS GREAT
BUT IT DOESN'T BREAK THROUGH THE
CLAY LAYERS IN OUR STRADDLE.
ON THE INJECTION IS THE ONLY WAY
TO DO THAT.
.
I'M ENCOURAGED.
I WILL BE WORKING WITH YOU ON
THIS I KNOW WE HARDLY HAD THE
DISCUSSIONS AND DISCUSSIONS
ABOUT AMENDMENTS IN THE FUTURE
SO ON. FOR FOR OTHER MEMBERS ON
THE DIETS THAT ARE ON THE FENCE
I SUGGEST THE INWARD REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU GUYS JOIN IN THE
DISCUSSION MOVING THIS FORWARD.
HE WAS MATHIS.
.
DR NUMBER LED THE MEASURE DOES.
I HAVE A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
WITH COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT
YOU'VE ACCEPTED. DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND BY MISTER
SALAS AND MISS CARILLO CHUCK
CLOSE.
YEAH.
ONE AND A HIGHLIGHTER A SPECIAL
NIGHT WE HAD A FEW MONTHS AGO
WHERE.
MIGHT. HAVE
COMPATRIOT HERE TO OUR LEFT GOT
RECOGNIZED BY OUR GOVERNOR FOR A
GILA THE GOVERNOR'S
ENVIRONMENTALLY EXCELLENCE IN
LEADERSHIP AWARD. FOR THE WORK
THAT HE DID ON ON FARM RECHARGE
EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE TODAY.
AND I'M TRYING TO. REALLY MAKE
SURE THAT WE MOVE THIS
CONVERSATION FORWARD SO THAT
THIS GOVERNOR HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO CODIFY HIS EXECUTIVE ORDER
AND REALLY WOULD HOPE THAT THOSE
ON THE COMMITTEE WILL ALLOW US
THE TIME. TO CONTINUE TO HAVE
THESE IMPORTANT DISCUSSIONS AND
WITH THAT I HUMBLY ASK FOR AN I
POD. ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
BECAUSE OF THE A MOTIONS SECOND
IS TO PASS.
TO ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE RECOMMENDATION.
EXCEPTION NOKIA.
AMENDMENTS.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER.
THAT THE GALLAGHER NOT VOTING.
BIGELOW.
NOT PUTTING BIGELOW NOT VOTING
CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CHOI.
WITH A CHANGE IN MY HOUSE. I'M
GONNA SAY YES.
CHOI AYE.
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GLORIA.
HARPER.
HARPER NO.
KALRA.
LEVINE. MATHIS ARE MATHIS AYE
RUBIO.
WE'VE YOUR AYE SOLIS. SOLIS I
WOULD. WOULD I.
ONLY THAT OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS
TO ADD ON. SECOND BILL.
THAT DAY.
THIRTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I'M HERE TO PRESENT ON AB THIRTY
TWO EIGHTEEN AND LET ME START BY
SAYING THAT ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND WOULD LIKE TO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
BILL.
IN NINETEEN NINETY TWO THE
LEGISLATURE CREATED THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY.
TO DEVELOP AND MANAGE THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER PARKWAY.
THE VISION OF THE CONSERVANCY
AND THEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM
COSTA WAS TO CREATE A TWENTY TWO
MILE NATURAL AND RECREATIONAL
AREA. IN THE FLOOD PLAIN
EXTENDING FROM THE FRAMES DAM TO
HIGHWAY NINETY NINE.
FOR THE LAST TWENTY SIX YEARS
THE CONSERVANCY IN CONJUNCTION
WITH THE CITIES AND COUNTIES A
FRESNO MADERA. AND MANY OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS INCLUDING THE STATE
HAVE WORKED HARD TO ACQUIRE AN
INTERN TO PARTNERSHIPS TO MAKE
THE PARKWAY A REALITY.
HOWEVER MUCH WORK NEEDS YET
REMAINS IN ORDER TO FULLY
OPERATE AND MANAGE THE PARKWAY.
IT IS NO SECRET THIS THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY IS SEVERELY
UNDERSERVED AND FALLS FAR BEHIND
THE IN THE RATE OF PARKS PER
CAPITA.
THIS LACK OF GREEN SPACE AFFECTS
MEMBERS OF OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES THE
MOST.
AS A PHYSICIAN I KNOW THE
IMPORTANCE OF SPENDING TIME
OUTDOORS. DIABETES HYPERTENSION
OBESITY THESE COULD ALL BE
ALLEVIATED BY SIMPLY SPENDING
MORE TIME OUTDOORS IF ONLY WE
COULD PROVIDE A SAFE AND
AVAILABLE RECREATIONAL AREA FOR
ALL TO ENJOY. THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD ACCOMPLISH.
AB THIRTY TWO EIGHTEEN WOULD
ALLOW THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
CONSERVANCY THE ABILITY TO ENTER
INTO A MANAGEMENT AGREEMET WITH
THE STATE PARKS THAT WOULD
PROVIDE FOR OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE.
OF THE TRAILS AND SPACE THAT THE
PARKWAY HAS ACQUIRED. I AM
PLEASED TO PRESENT TO YOU THIS
BILL THAT IS ONE SUPPORT OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER TRUST THE
COUNTY OF FRESNO THE COUNTY OF
MADERA THE CITY OF FRESNO. THE
OFFICIALS FROM THE CITY OF
MADERA AND MANY OTHER COMMUNITY
GROUPS AND LEADERS. HERE WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS SHARON
WEAVER THEEXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER. TRUST.
GOOD MORNING.
I'D LIKE TO START BY READING A
SHORT QUOTE FROM A NEWSPAPER
ARTICLE THAT WAS AUTHORED BY A
JOURNALISM PROFESSOR AND
REPORTER NAMED ROGER TO TERRY
AND BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN BEFORE THE PARKWAY EFFORT
WAS REALLY UNDER WAY.
AND THERE'S A PARAGRAPH HERE
WHERE HE WRITES.
IT IS A MUCH EXPLOITED STREAM
THIS RIVER OF OURS IT IS
HARNESSED AND RE HARNESS FOR
HYDROELECTRIC DEVELOPMENT AS IT
COURSES THROUGH THE SIERRA.
AND AT FREIEN THIS DAMNED FOR
THE BENEFIT OF AGRICULTURE.
IF THOSE PROJECTS HAVE PROVIDED
RECREATIONAL FACILITIES FOR THE
PUBLIC AT LARGE
THEY HAVE DONE SO ONLY A SIDE
EFFECTS.
THIS TIME LET THE PUBLIC'S RIGHT
TO SHARED DIRECTLY IN A GREAT
NATURAL RESOURCE
BE THE PRIMARY MOTIVE.
I AM SO PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO
SIT HERE WITH DOCTOR ARAMBULA TO
URGE YOUR SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
I'VE SPENT ALMOST TWENTY YEARS
WORKING FOR THE SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER PARKWAY AND CONSERVATION
TRUST.
AND WE HAVE MULTIPLE GOALS IN
OUR CREATION OF THE PARKWAY
THOSE GOALS ARE LAND
CONSERVATION. EDUCATION ABOUT
THE IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES AND ALSO
OFFERING RECREATIONAL ACCESS TO
THE COMMUNITY. NOW OVER THE
YEARS WE HAVE WORKED
COOPERATIVELY WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE SAN JOAQUIN
RIVER CONSERVANCY OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE PARKS
AND OTHER OTHER PUBLIC AGENCIES
TO ACQUIRE ALMOST FOUR THOUSAND
ACRES.
FOR PUBLIC ACCESS AND ENJOYMENT
ALONG THE SAN JOAQUIN RIVER.
BUT DURING THAT SAME TIME FRAME
I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE
LOTS OF PEOPLE ON GUIDED WALKS
AND GUIDED TOURS OF THE RIVER.
BUT THE QUESTION THAT I ALWAYS
RECEIVE IS CAN I COME BACK HERE
ON MY OWN. IS THIS PROPERTY OPEN
TO THE PUBLIC AND IT'S BECOMING
HARDER AND HARDER AFTER ALMOST
THIRTY YEARS OF EFFORT ON THE
PARKWAY. TO EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE
THAT KNOW TECHNICALLY THIS LAND
IS NOT CURRENTLY AVAILABLE FOR
YOUR PUBLIC USE AND LESS YOU ARE
ON A GUIDED TOUR. OR ON A FIELD
TRIP LED BY MY ORGANIZATION OR
ONE OF OUR PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS
IN THE COMMUNITY. THIS BILL WILL
SOLVE THAT PROBLEM IT'S THE
RIGHT MEASURE AT THE RIGHT TIME
AND I AM PLEASED TO URGE YOUR
SUPPORT OF IT.
THANK YOU THAT ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN.
SUPPORT MAYBE THIRTY TWO
EIGHTEEN.
KAREN LANG ON GOV OF THE FRESNO
AND MADERA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS WITH THE AMENDMENTS
IDENTIFIED IN THE ANALYSES IN
THE DISCUSSION WITH THE AUTHOR.
THEY'RE VERY HAPPY TO MOVE TO
SUPPORT POSITION TODAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
BUT AFRICAN VOLATILE BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
SEEN ANYONE ELSE.
TO HAVE ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
YOU KNOW ONE.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
DOES ENJOY A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THE AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD LIKE
TO CLOSE OR THE ANY QUESTIONS
FOR THE OP.
XENON.
LESS TIME.
JUST.
I APPRECIATE THE OFFER EFFORTS
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION ON
THE S. AND I KNOW THINGS AND
FRESNO CAN GET QUITE
CONTROVERSIAL AT TIMES.
.
AND AND BEING SOMEBODY WHO YOU
WHAT COLLEGE AT FRESNO STATE AND
GOT TO ENJOY THIS AREA FOR SOME
TIME.
I AM IT'S NICE TO SEE THIS
MOVING FORWARD AND YOU WORKING
WITH THE LOCALS TO.
GET EVERYTHING WORKED OUT SO I
WILL BE SUPPORTING TODAY THANK
YOU FOR WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON THIS.
THANK YOU APPROACH BIGELOW.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR.
AND I'M GLAD THAT YOU'RE TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE OUTLINED
A NUMBER OF FOLKS HAVE WORKED ON
IT. IN THE LAST.
.
COUPLE OF DAYS.
LATE OUR WORK AND AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS.
I DO WANNA.
TRITA DEEP CLEAR.
.
THIS ISN'T CREATING A NEW STATE
PARK.
IS JUST CREATING A MANAGEMENT
TOOL.
BY WHICH THE THE LOCAL AGENCY
THAT'S BEEN CREATED THE SAN
JOAQUIN.
A RIVER CONSERVANCY WILL. WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH STE.
STATE PARKS TO MANAGE
AND FACILITATE THE CONSTRUCTION
ANNA ON HIM IS THAT YOUR
UNDERSTANDING.
OUR INTENT WAS TO WORK THROUGH
THE COMMITTEE AND FIGURE OUT HOW
WE CAN RETURN A PARK IN ANY.
FASHION WE COULDN'T HONESTLY I
WAS QUITE PLEASED WITH THE
AMENDMENTS AND HOW IT HAS BEEN
ABLE TO.
BRING EVERYONE INTO A SUPPORT
POSITION AND WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK.
IN THAT WAY AND AND AS THIS
MOVES FORWARD THE REQUEST OF THE
BILL REALLY. IT KIND OF.
IT IT GETS US TO THE POINT WHERE
PEOPLE CAN TALK.
BUT THE REAL TALK REALLY
REVOLVES AROUND MONEY.
AND THIS IS HOLLOW AT THIS
MOMENT IT HAS NO MONEY.
AND IT HAS NO. OUR ABILITY TO
PUT THE TOOLS TOGETHER UNTIL WE
GET FUNDING.
AND SO THAT'S GONNA BE THE ART
OF THIS BILL AS IT MOVES
FORWARD.
WHERE'S THE FUNDING GONNA COME
FROM.
WHILE I SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
AND WHEN ENCOURAGE EVERY MEMBER
AROUND THIS TABLE.
DISAPPOINTED.
I WOULD ALSO ASK EVERY MEMBER TO
STAND IN OPPOSITION IF IT'S
GONNA TAKE A DIME. OUT OF OUR
EXISTING STATE PARKS BUDGET.
ANDERSON BECAUSE THAT'S NOT A
GOOD PLACE FOR US TO BE. WE NEED
TO FIND NEW FUNDING.
AND I THINK THAT'S FUNDING
THAT'S CLEAN FUNDING THAT
DOESN'T GET TAKEN FROM ANY OTHER
SOURCES.
TO HELP FACILITATE MAKING THIS
HAPPEN.
WITH THAT SAID.
SURE I WOULD ENCOURAGE THE
COMMITTEE STAFF. TO WORK WITH
THE AUTHOR ON TRYING TO FIND THE
TOOLS HE NEEDS TO TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
AND FOR THE PEOPLE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL.
THIS IS GOING TO BE ANOTHER
CHALLENGE.
THE CHALLENGE BETWEEN TWO
COUNTIES.
AND AND A CITY WHO HAS
GOVERNANCE CONTROLS.
OVER THE LAND
WITHIN THE PARKWAY.
THERE ARE CERTAIN TOOLS THAT
PRECLUDE THEM.
IN PARTICULAR IN NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR AGREEMENT THAT DOESN'T
ALLOW THEM TO DEVELOP.
THE PARKWAY FULLY UNTIL EVERY
ACRE.
ENVISIONED IS PURCHASED.
IT'S THE FIFTY NINE HUNDRED ACRE
TOTAL.
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO SEE THAT
THAT.
COMPONENT IS REMOVED AS A
BARRIER.
AND ALLOW THE PEOPLE.
IN THESE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THE
ABILITY TO NOW CONSTRUCT.
AN OPEN.
THE DOOR FOR PEOPLE TO GO OUT
NEUTRALIZE IT.
I KNOW MISS WEAVER.
A NO IS IT'S DIFFICULT BECAUSE
IT'S BEEN A CHALLENGE FOR.
SINCE.
THE EARLY DAYS IN INTO. EARLY
EARLY NINETIES.
THAT THIS WHOLE PROCESS BEGAN.
SO I WOULD STRONGLY ENCOURAGE
THOSE LOCALS TO GO BACK AND
REVIEW THOSE POLICIES.
AND WORK FORWARD.
IN DEVELOPING A MEANINGFUL TRAIL
EXPERIENCE.
BECAUSE QUITE HONESTLY STANDING
FROM ONE TO THREE MILES AWAY.
TAKING YOUR LITTLE CHILD AND
SAYING A LOOK OVER THERE IS THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER.
ISN'T A NIGHT MEANINGFUL
EXPERIENCE.
WILLIAM GO DOWN HERE THE WATER.
TOUCH THE WATER.
AND LOOK AT THE WONDERS THAT
EXIST ALONG THIS PARKWAY.
WOULD BE A MEANINGFUL
EXPERIENCE.
AND I COMPLIMENT BOTH THE
PARKWAY TRUST AND THE
CONSERVANCY BUT EFFORTS THAT
THEY'VE DONE TO THIS POINT.
BUT I ALSO WANT TO CHALLENGE HIM
TO SUCCEED EVEN MORE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THEY GIVE US BIGELOW FOR THAT
DATA VISUALIZATION OF THAT WALK
IN. THIS PART OF.
TO ME.
IT'S GOOD.
WOULD LIKE CLOSE.
IT WAS IN NINETEEN NINETY TOO
AND NOT TO DATE MYSELF BUT
ACTION WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL BACK
THEN AND.
DOT BEFORE MY KIDS ARE IN HIGH
SCHOOL I HOPE WE CAN COMPLETE
THIS PROJECT.
AND IT IS IMPERATIVE FOR THOSE
IN MY COMMUNITY WHO DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO. NATURAL HABITATS AS
ARE AS BEAUTIFUL AS THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER.
FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO REALIZE
WHAT'S IN OUR BACKYARD SO WITH
THAT I HUMBLY ASK FOR YOUR HOME
I WILL CALL THE QUESTION TO THE
MOTION MADE BY MS PREMIUMS
RUBIO.
TO PASS WITH COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO APPROPRIATIONS
WELCOME.
THE MOTION ASTUTE PASSES AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA GARCIA AYE.
GALLAGHER BY GALLAGHER AYE
BIGELOW.
HELLO I CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE CHOI AYE CHOI AYE
CHU. FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN HIGH
GLORIA.
HARPER AYE HARPER AYE KALRA.
LEVINE MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE SOLACE.
SOLACE I WOULD.
WE WILL KEEP HERE CALL OPEN ON
THAT ITEM AS WELL AS THE
PREVIOUS ONE FOR THE MEMBERS AT
OCT THANK YOU MAKE YOU. WILL
MOVE ON TO ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY
THREE FORTY EIGHT WAS
AGUIAR-CURRY.
VIA. AB TWENTY FORTY EIGHT AS
THE. DO PASS RECOMMENDATION.
PROJECTS SURE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY EIGHT WILL
HELP OFFSET THE COST OF WINTER
FLOODING RICE FIELDS AN
AGRICULTURAL PRACTICE THE
PROVIDES CRITICAL WETLAND
HABITAT. AND FOOD FOR ROUGHLY
SIX MILLION BIRDS IN CALIFORNIA.
UNFORTUNATELY AS WATER RATES
HAVE INCREASED IN THE AN
ALTERNATE LAND MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES IN WE MERGED. RICE
GROWERS ARE LESS ABLE TO
CONTINUE WINTER FLOODING THEIR
FIELDS.
THIS SHIFT IN AGRICULTURAL
PRACTICES THREATENING WETLAND
HABITAT AVAILABILITY AND THE
WILDLIFE THEY RELY ON THIS
HABITAT FOR FOOD.
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY ESTIMATES
THAT PURCHASING PROTECTING AND
ENHANCING JUST A HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES OF WETLAND
HABITAT ACROSS THE STATE UP TO
ONE BILLION DOLLARS.
ON THE AND OTHER HAND HELPING
FARMERS PAY TO MAINTAIN THE
AGRICULTURAL WETLANDS THEY
PROVIDE IS A COST EFFECTIVE WAY
TO ADDRESS THIS IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUE.
WELL THIS BILL PER IMPROVES
WETLAND HABITAT FOR BIRDS. IT
ALSO IMPROVES HABITAT FOR OTHER
SPECIES LIKE SAMMONS AND SALMON
AND SNAKES.
FOR THIS REASON I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT A
REPRESENT US FOR THE CALIFORNIA
RIGHTS COMMISSION AND THE ART OF
ON CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CHARACTERIZED MY MAY
CONSERVATION PROJECT MANAGER AT
ALL OF ON CALIFORNIA WHERE I
WORK TO PROVIDE HABITAT FOR.
MIGRATORY BIRDS ON THE FARM
FIELDS OF THE CENTRAL VALLEY. I
THINK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME THIS
TIME TO SPEAK TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY THREE FORTY EIGHT I
WANT TO THANK THE MEMBER OF THE
SPONSORS OF THE BILL FOR
INTRODUCING THIS INNOVATIVE. AND
FORWARD THINKING PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
FOR MANY YEARS ON CALIFORNIA HAS
WORKED IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
INDUSTRY GROUPS CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATIONS FARMERS AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS TO PROTECT AND
ENHANCE.
HABITAT FOR MIGRATORY BIRDS ON
THE WORKING LANDS AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
THE NATURAL WETLAND HABITAT IS A
FRACTION OF WHAT IT USED TO BE
HISTORICALLY.
AND IN THE CURRENT LANDSCAPE OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY THE RICE
PRODUCTION PROVIDES UP TO EIGHTY
PERCENT OF ALL OF THE AVAILABLE
FLOODED HABITAT DURING THE
COURSE OF THE YEAR.
CONSEQUENTLY RICE PRODUCTION
PLAYS A CRITICAL ROLE IN
PROVIDING HABITAT FOR WATER
BIRDS AND OTHER SPECIES THAT ARE
RELYING UPON WHAT HABITATS.
IN CALIFORNIA RICE PRODUCTION
SUPPORTS TWO HUNDRED AND THIRTY
DIFFERENT WILDLIFE SPECIES
INCLUDING OVER FIFTY DIFFERENT
SPECIES OF WATER BIRDS.
AND IN WINTER RICE FIELDS
FLOODED IN THE SACRAMENTO VALLEY
HOST NEARLY THIRTY PERCENT OF
THE REASON SHOREBIRDS. AND TWO
THIRDS OF THE WATERFALL
MIGRATING AND THE PACIFIC FLYWAY
WHICH ACCOUNTS FOR NEARLY TWENTY
PERCENT OF NORTH AMERICA'S
DUCKS.
THE RACE COMMISSION AND RICE
FARMERS HAVE BEEN DEDICATED TO
THE CONSERVATION OF WATER BIRDS
AND HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY WITH
AUDUBON AND OTHER CONSERVATION
PARTNERS.
TO DEVELOP INNOVATIVE WAYS OF
ENHANCING THEIR FIELDS FOR
BIRDS.
AND THERE ARE A FEW OTHER
EXAMPLES OF SUCH A RICH AND
PRODUCTIVE PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN
AGRICULTURAL AND CONSERVATION
GROUPS.
AB TWENTY THREE FORTY EIGHT IS
AN IMPORTANT TOOL TO ADD TO OUR
CONSERVATION TOOLBOX FOR
SUSTAINING WATER POPULATIONS AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY OF
CALIFORNIA.
WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT RICE
FLOODING IS NOT A COMPLETE
SUBSTITUTE FOR WETLAND HABITAT
HOWEVER IT IS CRITICAL TO
PROVIDING PLACES TO REST AND
FEED. FOR THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF WATER BIRDS IN
CALIFORNIA.
FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR IN A VOTES
ON AB TWENTY THREE FORTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU.
YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA RICE COMMISSION
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. HOW ARE A CONSERVATION
PARTNERS CAN SAY IT ANY BETTER
HOW WE HAVE ENJOYED A GREAT
PARTNERSHIP?
IN THE RICE INDUSTRY OF
CREATING THESE
WETLANDS ARE IN THE WINTER.
THE TRUTH MATTER IS A IT'S NOT
AN INEXPENSIVE PRACTICE.
AND DEPENDING ON A WATER RATES
ON ANY GIVEN YEAR WATER
AVAILABILITY ETCETERA AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW TECHNOLOGIES.
THAT ALLOW FOR THE SAME END
FARMING PRACTICE TO OCCUR
WITHOUT WINNER FLOODING WERE.
CONCERNED.
AND THAT IN THE FUTURE RICE
FARMERS MAY NOT BE AS OPEN TO
THE ABILITY OF OF WINTER
FLOODING WITHOUT SOME
INCENTIVES.
AND SO THIS BILL COMES FORWARD
IT AT A VERY OPPORTUNE TIME. I
IN HELPING TO CREATE THIS TYPE
OF PROGRAM HOW WITH THE OF
AVAILABILITY AND POTENTIAL FOR
FUTURE BOND MONIES THAT ARE OUT
THERE AND ALSO WORK THAT THE
RICE COMMISSION IN OUR.
CONSERVATION PARTNERS ARE DOING
IN WASHINGTON DC HOW ON THE
FEDERAL FARM BILL AYE WE BELIEVE
THAT A PROGRAM OF THIS NATURE
THAT COULD HOUSE SOME OF THAT
MONEY WOULD HELP THEN PROVIDE
THE INCENTIVES NECESSARY TO
KEEP.
OUR THOSE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF ACRES AVAILABLE FOR BIRDS FOR
OTHER A MIGRATORY WATERFOWL.
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU THAT
THOSE WISHING TO ADD ON. IN
SUPPORT.
SEC.
Q. MOTION THE SECOND.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARIAN
WARMER DOWN WITH RURAL COUNTIES
WE ARE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE WOULD ALSO NOTE THIS IS
A. VERY CREATIVE WAY OF
RETAINING AND GROWING THE
ECOLOGICAL BENEFITS OF THE
SACRAMENTO VALLEY WHILE STILL
KEEPING THOSE PROPERTIES ON THE
PRIVATE TAX RULES WHICH IS
IMPORTANT AS A LOCAL REVENUE
STREAM FOR COUNTIES THANK YOU.
ARGUMENT WITH DUCKS UNLIMITED
WE'VE LEARNED THROUGH OUR
SCIENCE THAT. WHAT'S GOOD FOR
DUCKS GOOD FOR RICE WHAT'S GOOD
FOR RICE GOOD FOR DUCKS
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELENA ORTIZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS LUCAS FRERICHS AB HAVE
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANKS VERY MUCH.
LAUGHTER AIR GOOD MORNING PUBLIC
OURS WITH ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND IN SUPPORT.
OKAY ZERO ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE
MEASURE.
WELL I.
JOE FULBERT WITH CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION WE DO NOT
ACTUALLY OPPOSED THE BILL.
WE SUPPORT THE CONCEPT.
AT WINTER FLOODED RICE IS VERY
VERY IMPORTANT.
TO OUR WATER FILE.
AND THAT WE IN TWOS YES STICKLEY
SUPPORTED.
AB EIGHT THIRTY TWO LAST YEAR.
.
OUR REAL CONCERN THOUGH IS WITH
USE OF THE.
.
THE FUNDING OR THE ACCOUNT.
THAT IS BEING USED TO
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL HABITAT
PROGRAM ALSO KNOWN AS PROSYD
PROGRAM.
A CALIFORNIA WATER FILES.
SPONSORED THAT BILL THIRTY
YEARS AGO. AND IT HAS.
EIGHT A GREAT DEAL OF EFFORT
OVER THE YEARS TO TRY TO KEEP IT
FUNDED.
A WE HAVE A COUPLE OF PROBLEMS
ONE IS THAT.
THE.
PURPOSE OF THE PRESLEY PROGRAM
IS TO.
UP PROMOTE NATURAL.
ENVIRONMENTS FOR THE DUCKS.
AND.
TO PROMOTE JUDGE SPRINGTIME.
NESTING HABITAT AND SUMMERTIME
OF FOOD GROWTH FOR THAT THE
DOCKS OUTSIDE IT EXPRESSLY
PROHIBITS.
THE USE OF AGRICULTURE OR THAT
PLANNING THAT CULTURAL CROPS ON
THE PROPERTIES.
OF THE OTHER PROBLEM WERE
CONCERNED ABOUT IS THE
POSSIBILITY OF WINDING UP
COMPETING FOR FUNDS.
WITH THE RICE INDUSTRY.
I WE WOULD LIKE VERY MUCH TO SEE
AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM FOR WINTER
FLOODED RICE.
.
IF THERE WAS A WAY IS A WAY TO
PUT A VERY STRONG FIRE WALL IN
THIS ACCOUNT.
THAT WOULD SEPARATE THE.
.
THE CURRENT PROGRAM FROM A
WINNER RISE.
THAT MIGHT BE A POSSIBLE
SOLUTION. OF THE OTHER WOULD BE
TO SEEK ANOTHER.
.
ACCOUNT CREATE A NEW ACCOUNT
AND.
.
FUNDED SEPARATELY.
AGAIN THE YOU KNOW IT IN THOSE
TYPES OF THINGS WE COULD.
STRONGLY SUPPORT AND WE VERY
RELUCTANTLY.
EXPRESS OUR CONCERNS HERE.
WE HOPE TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR
TO. ACHIEVE A.
SUCCESS FOR EVERYBODY ON THIS
BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
KIM DELFINO WITH DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE AND WE DO NOT HAVE A
POSITION OF OPPOSING THE BELT
BUT YOU'RE A COMEDIAN NOW
ASSISTED RATES OF AND AND JUST
LET ME JUST SAY FIRST FOR THE
RECORD WE THINK THIS IS A GREAT
PROGRAM AND. ARE VERY SUPPORTIVE
THE CONCEPT.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS FLAG ONE
ISSUE WHICH IS.
CURRENTLY THE WELL THE WAY THE
BILL'S DRAFTED IS THAT IT WOULD
ALLOW FOR LANCE TACTIC
CHARACTERIZES LANDS THAT IT
WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR THIS
FUNDING WOULD BE LAND THAT
INFALLIBLE. THAT'S MEANING NOT
PLANTED THAT YEAR WHEN IT'S THAN
BEING FLOODED UP THE CONCERN
THAT WE HAVE IS THAT.
THESE DOLLARS ARE VERY SCARCE
WE WANT TO MAXIMIZE THE USE OF
THE DOLLARS LANDS THAT HAVE NOT
BEEN PLANTED IN THAT HAVE BEEN
FOLLOWED AND THEN FLOODED.
REALLY PROVIDE VERY LITTLE
HABITAT VALUE IT IS THE VALUE OF
THE RICE THAT HAD BEEN PLANTED
THERE.
THAT REALLY PROVIDES AND THEN
THAT WHATEVER'S LEFT OVER THEN
FLOODED OUT THAT PROVIDES THE
REAL FOOD VALUE. AND SO WE WOULD
JUST URGE THAT IN THE PROCESS OF
MOVING THROUGH AND MASSAGING
THIS BILL THAT THE AUTHOR
CONSIDER MAKING.
THIS AMENDMENT.
IN THE PROCESS OF THINK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
XENA AND NO ONE ELSE'S.
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION WOULD YOU
LIKE TO AYE. WE ADDRESS ANY OF
THOSE QUESTIONS ARE FOR.
CHAIRMAN LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
CALIFORNIA RICE COMMISSION HAD
TO ADDRESS JUST A COUPLE OF THE
ISSUES OUT FIRST
I IN. IN REGARDS TO THE PRESLEY
PROGRAM WE FIND THAT TO BE A
VERY IMPORTANT PROGRAM.
AND EVER AGREED WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION
AND WANTING TO DIVIDE DIVINE.
DRAFTING
LANGUAGE THAT CREATES THAT SOUND
FOR FIREWALL.
BETWEEN.
THAT THE FUNDING FOR NATURAL
WETLANDS IN ANN RICE WETLANDS.
BUT OUTSIDE OF THAT THOUGH WE
BELIEVE THAT I'M WITH THE RICE
INDUSTRY AND OTHERS IN IN
CONSERVATION THAT SUPPORT WINNER
FLOODED RICE. THAT THE MORE OF
US ASKING FOR MONIES FOR THESE
PROGRAMS PROBABLY THE BETTER FOR
THE PROGRAM IN THE LONG RUN. AND
UTILIZING THE THE PARTNERSHIPS
THAT WE HAVE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL HIGH AS WELL AS IN IN
OTHER AIR AREAS TO GET FUNDING
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT ULTIMATELY
WE CAN ENHANCE THE PRESLEY
PROGRAM OVERALL WITH
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE FUNDING.
ON THE ISSUE OF THE FALLOW
GROUNDS
THE REASON WE'VE ADDED THIS IN
HERE IS FOR BOMB OUR FARMERS IN
THE INDUSTRY THAT GROW ORGANIC
RICE.
I THEY HAVE A CROP ROTATION IN
ABOUT EVERY THIRD YEAR THEY
LEAVE THEIR PROPERTY FALLOW FOR
THE PER THAT FOR THOSE PURPOSES
OF GROWING ORGANIC RICE TO
REGENERATE THE SOIL. AND SO WE
DID NOT WANT TO ELIMINATE THEM
FROM THE OPPORTUNITY WE KNOW
THAT THAT. THAT'S THOSE FIELDS
THAT DON'T HAVE A CURRENT
OUTCROP OF RICE ON IT ARE NOT AS
BENEFICIAL TO THE WATERFOWL. BUT
AGAIN WE DID NOT WANT TO LEAVE
OUR.
FARMERS OUT THERE THAT ARE
GROWING ORGANIC RICE OUT OF THIS
PROGRAM SO THAT'S THE ONLY
REASON THAT WE'VE ALLOWED FOR
THAT OPPORTUNITY.
IF YOU.
THE QUESTIONS FROM ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THERE'S A MOTION A
SECOND BY MEANS FRIEDMAN.
AND MAY HAVE MISSED GALLAGHER.
LIKE CLOSE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THREE AYE
VOTE RIGHT THIS IS A DO PASSED
TO SIMPLY APPROPRIATIONS.
IS KALRA.
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA. GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER BY GALLAGHER AYE
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO. CHOI YEAH I
CHOI AYE CHU.
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE GLORIA
YOU.
HARPER THOUGHT HARPER AYE KALRA.
LEVINE MATHIS FIVE MATHIS AYE
RUBIO.
SOLACE.
SOLIS I WOULD.
SIX LEAVES.
THE P. THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS HAD ON THINK YOU'D
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AUSTIN
COMMITTEE AT THIS TIME TO TAKE
ACTION ON THE PROPOSED THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
LIKE MOTION AND A SECOND.
THAT IS THE AB TWENTY TWO FORTY
ONE AB TWENTY FOUR SEVEN NEED BE
TWENTY SIX FIFTEEN AND. EIGHTY
ART THIRTY EIGHT.
PLEASE COLOR.
MOTIONS FOR A BEAST TWENTY TO
FORTY ONE TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
AND TWENTY SIX FIFTEEN. IS TO
PASS TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. AG OUR THIRTY
EIGHT IS TO PASS.
EDUARDO GARCIA BY.
YEAH I GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI HIGH CHOI AYE CHU.
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE GLORIA.
HARPER.
I AYE HARPER AYE KALRA.
LEVINE. MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE RUBIO.
SOLACE. SOLACE I WOULD.
THINGS YOU.
WHO ARE IN NEED OF?
AUTHORS WE DO HAVE A COUPLE OF
MEMBERS HERE ON THE COMMITTEE
THAT COULD PRESENT.
SHE GALLAGHER MR MATHIS.
HE LIKED TO.
ANOTHER MORE. STABLE.
THERE ARE YOU READY YEAH BILL.
.
MAINLY BY LIKE. ONE OF MY.
MOVE THE BILL.
THIS GALLERY OF TWO BILLS THAT.
OR THREE THREE.
I I THINK IT UP A HEAD OF TEN AB
TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE.
AB TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN.
HE BEAT THIRTY FORTY FIVE.
OF START WITH THE TWENTY FIVE
FORTY FIVE.
IT THAT YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY FIVE HELPS
ENSURE THAT THERE'S CLARITY AND
CONSISTENCY IN THE APPLICATION
ENFORCEMENT.
OF THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE LAKE AND
STREAM BED ALTERATION PROGRAM.
AND I DO ONE OF STATE TO BEGIN I
AM TAKING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
WHICH I THINK HELPS CLARIFY
THAT THIS WOULD INCLUDE WILDLIFE
AND NOT JUST AQUATIC.
.
THAT NOT JUST AQUATIC SPECIES.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES
NOTIFICATION TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE BEFORE
BEGINNING ANY ACTIVITY THAT WILL
SUBSTANTIALLY MODIFY A RIVER
STREAM OR LAKE IF THIS ACTIVITY
HAS A SUBSTANTIAL IMPACT. ON
FISH AND WILDLIFE RESOURCES THAT
CDF CD OF W. MAY REQUIRE A LAKE
AND STREAM THAT ALTERATION
AGREEMENT THAT INCLUDES
MITIGATION MEASURES TO PROTECT
THESE RESOURCES.
HOWEVER TO ENSURE THIS PROGRAM
FUNCTIONS AS INTENDED AND
CONTINUES TO EFFECTIVELY PROTECT
OUR FISHERY RESOURCES IT'S
IMPORTANT TO PEOPLE. THAT PEOPLE
KNOW WHEN THIS LAW ACTUALLY
APPLIES THAT MEANS BEING ABLE TO
KNOW WHAT ARE THE BOUNDARIES.
IN WHICH IF YOU DO WORK.
IT REQUIRES NOTIFICATION.
A TO THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE TWENTY FIVE FORTY FIVE
DEFINES THE TERMS RIVER AND
STREAM. AND CONFIRMS THAT FOR
THE PURPOSE OF THE PROGRAM THE
DEFINITIONS OF BANK BAD IN
CHANNEL ARE CONSISTENT. WITH
EXISTING CASE LAW THAT'S ALREADY
ON THE BOOKS AND THE LONG
STANDING PRACTICAL
UNDERSTANDING.
PEOPLE HAVE OF WHAT CONSTITUTES
A STREAM.
I BELIEVE THIS CLARITY WILL
HELP.
INTO FIRST OF ALL ALLOW RATE THE
THE REGULATED COMMUNITY.
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT'S REQUIRED
OF THEM AND ALSO ENSURE THAT
THIS LA MEETS ITS PURPOSE PAN
INSIDE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY FOUR FORTY
TWO. TWO WITNESSES.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE JACK CRISIS IN
YOUR COUNSEL WITH A CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU FEDERATION
REPRESENTING FARMERS RANCHERS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
SO THE CLARITY IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER POINTED OUT IS
WHAT THE OBJECTIVE IS HERE SO
OUR MEMBERS CAN UNDERSTAND WHAT
THEIR OBLIGATION IS UNDER THE
LAW.
I THIS IS.
EQUALLY IMPORTANT GIVEN HOW THE
LAKE AND STREAM BED ALTERATION
AGREEMENT PROGRAM WORKS IT'S
REALLY ASTUTE TWO STEP PROCESS
THE FIRST STEP IS IF YOU'RE
GOING TO CONDUCT A CERTAIN
ACTIVITY. YOU HAVE TO NOTIFY THE
DEPARTMENT THAT NOTIFICATION
MEANS COMPLETING THE FORM AND
PAYING A FEE THAT IS AT A
MINIMUM FIVE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
SEVEN DOLLARS.
SO THE NOTIFICATION DOESN'T IT
DOES REQUIRE SOME WORK.
AFTER THE SECOND.
STEP IN THE PROCESS IS THE
IMPACT ANALYSIS BY THE
DEPARTMENT IF THE DEPARTMENT
DETERMINES IS THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GALLAGHER POINTED OUT
THAT IT MAY ADVERSELY AFFECT.
FISH AND WILDLIFE RESOURCES THEN
AS LAKE AND STREAM BED
ALTERATION AGREEMENTS REQUIRED
WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS
FOCUS IN ON THAT FIRST STEP IN
THE PROCESS THERE'S A. PROBLEM
EMERGING FOR MANY OF FR MEMBERS
FARMERS RANCHERS IN CALIFORNIA.
ABOUT WHERE. A STREAM BED
ALTERATION AN ACTIVITY REQUIRES
NOTIFICATION.
WE'RE HEARING FROM OUR MEMBERS
INSTANCES WHERE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH WILDLIFE FIELD STAFF ARE
INDICATING ACTIVITIES THAT ARE
NOT WITH AND A STREAM OR RIVER
OR WHAT THEY WOULDN'T UNDERSTAND
TO BE A STREAM OR RIVER. ARE.
REQUIRE NOTIFICATION WE WANT TO
HONE IN AND CLARIFY FOR FOLKS
WHAT THAT IS AND I THINK AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY FIVE HELP WITH
THAT.
THE KEY EXAMPLES FROM THE TEXT
OF THE STATUTE A REALLY YOU KNOW
EITHER AN ARTIFICIAL WATER
CONVEYANCE SO WATER CONVEYANCE
DEBTS THAT'S NOT. A PART OF A
NATURAL RIVER OR ALSO ACTIVITIES
OCCUR OUTSIDE THE CREEK BUT MAY
HAVE BEEN MORE WATER HAD FLOODED
IN THE PAST.
BECAUSE OF THE WAY TO THE
PROGRAM WORKS AND THE FACT THAT
IT'S THE OBLIGATIONS ON THE
PERSON CONDUCTING THE ACTIVITY
IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
HOW THE PROGRAM FUNCTIONS AND
FOR THE FAIRNESS TO THE ACTORS
THAT PEOPLE KNOW WHEN THEY HAVE
TO NOTIFY.
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY FIVE.
SEEKS TO DO THIS TO ME. BANK
ILL BE VERY HELPFUL BOTH FOR.
THE FOLKS WHO ARE MANAGING LAND
AND FOR THE DEPARTMENT'S
ENFORCEMENT OF IT.
THANK YOU WE APPRECIATE TERM
GUIDANCE INSISTED FROM THIS
COMMITTEE PARTICULARLY MISTER
JACQUI AND AND.
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK.
WITHOUT THE COMMITTEE AND
DEPARTMENT ON THIS NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS BABRI WITH THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ON BEHALF
OF THE VALLEY ATWATER COALITION
AND THE CALIFORNIA'S CENTRAL
VALLEY FLOOD CONTROL
ASSOCIATION.
MEMBERS OF THESE TWO
ORGANIZATIONS UP PROVIDE FARM
WATER. DRAINAGE AND FLOOD
CONTROL WORKS FOR THE RANCHERS
AND CATTLEMEN IN CALIFORNIA.
AND AND FOR OUR URBAN AREAS AND
WE OFTEN HAVE A MAN MADE
FACILITIES DRAINAGE CANALS
IRRIGATION CANALS THAT
INTERSECTS AN INTERVAL ACTS WITH
NATURAL WATERCOURSES.
WE THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT IT
TO THE BEST OF OUR ABILITY TO
DRIVE DRAW A BRIGHT LINE BETWEEN
THE NATURAL WATER COURSES IN THE
MAN MADE. A CONVEYANCE IS THAT
ARE SO IMPORTANT FOR IRRIGATION
FLOOD CONTROL WITH US FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
GOT.
CARE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
CATHOLIC COLOR THE METROPOLITAN
WATER DISTRICT SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA YOU WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR THE SPONSORS AND
COMMITTEE STAFF WORKING WITH US
ON THE US SOME AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL. WHICH WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE WE'RE NOT QUITE THERE
YET BUT I DO URGE THE COMMITTEE
TO GIVE THUMBS UP ON THE BILL AS
WE CONTINUE TO WORK FOR THE
AUTHOR THINKING Q..
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARIAN
WARMER DAM OF RAIL COUNTY
ASSOCIATION WHICH JEFFREY
GOLDBERG FOR CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
YOU HAVE ANYONE WISHING TO
OPPOSE THE BILL.
TESTIFYING OPPOSITION.
THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING.
FIRST LET ME JUST POLITICS AT
THE COMBINATION OF A COLD AND.
ALLERGIES AT THE SAME TIME BUT
NOW MY NAME IS KIM DELFINO AND
I'M THE STATE DIRECTOR FOR
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE. AND.
WE ARE CONTINUING TO OPPOSE THE
BILL ALTHOUGH WE DO APPRECIATE
THE EFFORT OF THE AUTHOR TO WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE WITH THE
AMENDMENTS WHICH TO MAKE SOME
IMPROVEMENTS TO THE BILL.
HOWEVER.
.
EVEN WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS WE
STILL ARE VERY CONCERNED WITH
WHAT THE BILL DOES.
FIRST THE BILL I BELIEVE IT'S
REALLY DIRECTED AT KIND OF
ADDRESS UNCERTAINTIES.
UNCERTAINTIES WITH THE PROCESS.
IN TRYING TO DETERMINE WHAT IS
A STREAM OR RIVER.
HYDRO GEO MORPHOLOGY IS A VERY
HE COMPLICATED SCIENCE
AND WHAT THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
DO IS SORT OF PUT IN BLACK AND
WHITE TERMS HOW YOU DEFINE THE
STREET WHEN A RIVER. THAT'S
DIFFICULT TO TO.
IN PARTICULAR.
THERE'S NO DEFINITION THAT'S
BEING PRO PROVIDED BY THE NEW.
.
A DEFINITION ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT THERE'S A DEFINITE CHANNEL
OR QUARTERS
THERE'S NO DEFINITION OF WHAT IS
A NATURALLY OCCURRING BAD BANKER
CHANNEL. THERE'S NO DEFINITION
OF WHAT IS CONSIDERED A PRE
EXISTING RIVER SO I BELIEVE
ACTUALLY THAT THIS BILL WOULD
PROBABLY CREATE EVEN MORE
UNCERTAINTY.
WITH TO APARTMENT EFFICIENT Y.
LIFE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO BE
ADMINISTERING THIS PROGRAM. THE
OTHER ISSUE I RAY I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT IS THAT A MY ORGANIZATION
A PARTICULAR WORKS IN THE DESERT
AND IN THE ARID.
LANDSCAPE OF A LOT OF TIMES
WHAT MAY THINK WHAT WHAT YOU
MIGHT THINK IS A RIVER THAT BY
DEFINITION OF A RIVER MAYBE UP
IN THE NORTH NORTHERN PART OF
THE STATE IS VERY DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT YOU ARE LOOKING AT IN THE
DRY. AIRED SYSTEM WHERE
SOMETIMES IF YOU'RE WALKING
ACROSS THAT AREA YOU DON'T EVEN
REALIZE YOU'RE WALKING THROUGH
WHAT IS A DRY DESERT WASH. UNTIL
YOU KNOW A YEAR OR TWO LATER
WHEN YOU ACTUALLY OF RAIN YOU
HAVE WATER RUNNING THROUGH
THERE.
TO REQUIRE A DEFINITE BANK WOULD
PERHAPS LEAVE OUT HUGE PORTIONS
OF WHAT WOULD BE CONSIDERED A
WHAT WOULD BE NORMALLY COVERED
UNDER THE STREAM THAT ALTERATION
JURISDICTION.
AND I'D I DON'T KNOW IF THAT
WAS AN INTENDED PART OF HOW THIS
DEFINITION WAS PUT TOGETHER BUT
THAT IS VERY MUCH LIKELY WILL BE
THE RESULT. MOVING FORWARD.
AND SO I THINK MY SUGGESTION AS
THIS BILL. MOVES FORWARD IS THAT
FRANKLY THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
SHOULD BE ADDRESSED THROUGH A
STE THE REGULATORY PROCESS BY
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE. BECAUSE WHEN YOU HAVE
SOMETHING AS COMPLICATED AS
TRYING TO DEFINE USING THE
SCIENCE OF HYDROGEN MORPHOLOGY
AND ALL OF THE VARIATIONS WITHIN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA OF WHAT
IS A RIVER STREAM. THAT INS
ISN'T SOMETHING REALLY WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IS SUPPOSED TO BE
CRAFTING THAT'S VERY DIFFICULT
DIFFICULT AND COMPLICATED A
DEFINITIONS IT SHOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT IS CONDUCTED
THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE IN THE REGULATORY
PROCESS. AND PERHAPS BECAUSE
THEY'VE NOT BEEN MOVING FORWARD
WITH REGULATIONS ON THIS ISSUE
AND THAT IS WHY WE FIND
OURSELVES IN HAVING THIS A
DISCUSSION. WITH THAT BEING SAID
I KNOW I WOULD URGE THAT THAT BE
MAYBE THE APPROACH TAKEN WITH
THE SPELL ON BUT AT THE VERY
MINIMUM WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE OFFER
IN TRYING TO ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES. BECAUSE AGAIN THE POINT
OF THE STREAMBED ALTERATION
PROGRAM IS TO PROTECT FISH AND
WILDLIFE THAT IS THE POINT OF
IT.
IF THERE ARE PROJECTS THAT IMP
IN A. DIVERT OR IMPACT FLOW THE
AMOUNT QUALITY QUANTITY TIMING
OF WHEN WATER IS DELIVERED. IN
SYSTEMS THAT IS HAVING A
PROFOUND IMPACT ON THE FISH AND
WILDLIFE AND IT IS NOT A A
PROGRAM THAT IS JUST SIMPLY
THERE TO MAKE UP PROJECTS
COMPLICATED IS THERE TO SERVE A
PURPOSE.
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE SURE
THAT IN MOVING THIS BILL FORWARD
THAT IT ACTUALLY GETS OUT.
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
PROTECTING THE FISH AND WILDLIFE
RESOURCES THIS PROGRAM IS
INTENDED TO PROTECT THANK YOU.
YOU KNOW ALSO WISH TO ADD ON
OPPOSITION PACKAGE OF THIS YEAR
CLIP CALIFORNIA ALSO POST.
ONE OF THEM I DON'T KNOW WITHOUT
A ONE CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION.
MARK FENCED MAKER FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND APART
OPPOSITION.
SEEN KNOWN ELSE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
DOCTOR CHAU ARE I'M ONE DAY ARE
NOT SOMETIME WHEN.
AS YOU CAN RESPOND TO HER
UNCERTAINTIES.
OF THE OPPOSITION.
YEAH I THINK GO A WAS GOING TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE THINGS IN
THE CLOSE IF IT IF YOU WANT ME
TO DO IT NOW I CAN.
.
SO I THINK I CAN APPRECIATE THAT
WERE OPPOSITION IS COMING FROM
WE DID JUST GET NOTICE FROM THEM
ON THURSDAY.
AND THEN THERE WAS A COMMITTEE
AMENDMENT THAT ADDRESSED
WILDLIFE.
WHICH I BELIEVE ADDRESSES A LOT
OF THE CONCERNS FROM OPPOSITION.
.
I I APPRECIATE WHAT'S BEING
BROUGHT UP ABOUT THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN WHAT HAPPENS
ON THE DESERT AND WHAT HAPPENS
UP HERE IN THE NORTH ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS IN THE REASON FOR THIS
BILL. IS THAT A STUDY THAT WAS
CONDUCTED RELIEVED LARGELY
FOCUSED ON THE DESERT COMMUNITY
IS BEING YOU. HAS BEEN USED
UP HERE IN THE NORTH AND SO
THERE IS THIS UNCERTAINTY
BECAUSE WE AREN'T MAKING THAT
DISTINCTION BETWEEN. SOME OF
THESE DIFFERENT AREAS.
AND WE'RE I WOULD VERY
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE IS A AND I
THINK THIS IS SOMETHING FOR US
OF THE LEGISLATURE.
IS NO WE DON'T JUST LEAVE THIS
TO THE REGULATORY PROCESS
IT'S OUR JOB TO PASS LAW IT'S
OUR JOB TO ESTABLISH THE
STATUTE.
AND THEN THE AGENCY WILL
OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO DO SOME
FURTHER DEFINITION IN THEIR IN
THEIR REGULATIONS.
BUT WITHIN THE CONFINES OF WHAT
WE ESTABLISH.
IS THE LAW AND SO WE NEED TO
START DOING THAT AS A
LEGISLATURE AGAIN INSANE WE ARE
THE ONES THAT ESTABLISH THAT.
AND THEN THE AGENCIES THAT YOU
KNOW DOESN'T THAT'S BACKWARD
PROCESS TO ME.
THAT WE SAID NO WE DON'T
LEGISLATE WE DISALLOW THE
REGULATORS TO PASS LAN IN AND
DEFINED THIS NO WE SHOULD.
DEFINE THOSE PARAMETERS BROADLY.
AND THEN THE REGULATORY
COMMUNITY DOES ITS JOB I WILL
SAY WE ARE WORKING WITH
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
HAVE ALREADY BEEN IN MEETINGS.
WITH THE DIRECTOR I WOULD VERY
MUCH OPEN TO SUGGESTIONS A MINT
ON LANGUAGE FROM THEM. I DON'T
THINK THIS IS THE FINAL PRODUCT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO BE
WORKING WITH A OPPOSITION ALL
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED WITH THIS.
BUT IT IS NEEDED AND I THINK WE
NEED TO START HERE'S LEGISLATURE
ESTABLISHING NODE WHAT THE RULES
ARE SO THAT PEOPLE HAVE
CERTAINTY. AND SO I WOULD ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. NOT YOU KNOW
THIS LEGISLATION MOVING FOR.
QUESTION FROM.
OKAY IT PLEASE.
I'M
I A. A DEFINITE APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND I CAN
SEE WHERE FOUND THE LACK OF
DEFINITION IS CAUSING A PROBLEM
FOR PEOPLE IN YOUR AREA. A BUT
TO ME THIS IS A BIT OF A ONE
SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH THAT
REALLY RUNS INTO PROLEMS ACROSS
THE STATE. AND I THINK THAT
WHERE AGENCIES TO DO A GOOD JOB
BUT I THINK THE ROLE IS AND
YOU'RE RIGHT THAT WE CAN'T
DEFAULT TO THEM BUT WE ALSO CAN
GIVE THEM STRONG INSTRUCTION.
AND THE ONE THING THAT A
REGULATORY AGENCY HAS THE
FLEXIBILITY TO. HAVE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF SOLUTIONS
ARE FOR DIFFERENT AREAS AND TO
TREAT DIFFERENT AREAS
DIFFERENTLY SO I CAN'T SUPPORT A
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH THAT
REDEFINES.
THINGS REALLY TO SUIT ONE AREA
WHERE IT CAN BE YOU KNOW I THINK
A REAL REAL PROBLEM IN OTHER
AREAS I HOPE THAT YOU CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS ARE BECAUSE I'D
LOVE TO GET RECONCILED RING
RELIEF TO THE REGULATED
COMMUNITY IN YOUR AREA BECAUSE
I.
I CAN UNDERSTAND THEIR PROBLEM
I'M I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT HOW
THIS PLAYS OUT IN OTHER PARTS OF
THE STATE. THANK YOU.
OKAY TO NONO'S ENQUIST COMES IS
DOES HAVE A. TO PASS AS AMENDED.
IS THERE A MOTION TO MOVE. THE
MOTION.
MOST IN A SECOND.
MEMSIC TRIP TO CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER. AYE GALLAGHER AYE
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI. AYE CHOI AYE CHU.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NO GLORIA.
GLORIA NO HARPER AYE HARPER AYE
KALRA. LEVINE. MATHIS.
RUBIO.
SOLACE.
SO.
SOLIS I WOULD.
WE'LL KEEP THAT THE.
ON CALL.
YOUR NEXT ITEM THAT WAS
GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
PROUD TO PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY SEVEN AND I WHICH WOULD A
STEP WHICH AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM
TO ENCOURAGE LANDOWNERS TO
MAINTAIN COVER CROPS WERE
NATURAL VEGETATION ON IDLED
AGRICULTURAL LANDS. TO ABIDE
HABITAT AND NESTING COVER FOR
WATERFOWL AND OTHER WILDLIFE.
I DO HAVE SOME WITNESSES HERE IN
SUPPORT I THINK THIS WOULD BE. A
GOOD.
THAT PROGRAM TO ESTABLISH.
AND I'D ASK YOUR ABOUT.
MOTION AND SECOND IT DOES HAVE A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION PLEASE
PROCEED.
I MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKEDLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION
ON THE BILL WOULD HELP TO FILL
IMPORTANT NEED A PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL NESTING COVER AND
UPLAND HABITAT. FOR WATERFOWL
ANOTHER GAME BIRDS ON PRIVATE
LANDS THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE CENTRAL VALLEY JOINT VENTURE
IMPLEMENTATION PLAN OF WHICH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES ARE BOTH SIGNATURE
SIGNATORIES TO.
I'M IT WOULD ESSENTIALLY DO TWO
THINGS IT WOULD STRENGTHEN A
POLICY HAS OF MENTIONED BEFORE
IN THE WATER CODE.
THAT WOULD ENCOURAGE LANDOWNERS
TO PROVIDE OUR TO MAINTAIN
NESTING COVER THAT'S NON
IRRIGATED NESTING COVER.
FOR WILDLIFE SO LONG AS ALL THE
WATER TRANSFER REQUIREMENTS HAVE
BEEN MET.
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
NECESSARY BECAUSE THE EXISTING
LAW. HAS NOT WORKED WE HAD A
POLICY IN PLACE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN TO TRAIN
COURAGE THIS HABITAT IN A NUMBER
OF FOLLOWING TRANSFERS AND WE
HAVEN'T HAD ANY NEW HABITAT
CREATED. SORT TRYING TO ADDRESS
THAT.
AS WAS ALSO MENTIONED ALSO
CREATES AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM THE
INCENTIVE PROGRAM IS BASED ON
THE CONSERVATION RESERVE PROGRAM
WHICH IS A FARM BILL PROGRAM
THAT HAS DONE WONDERFUL THINGS
FOR WATERFOWL AND OTHER BIRDS IN
THE UPPER MIDWEST THE DAKOTAS.
AND HAS REALLY BEEN CREDITED
WITH RESTORING WATERFOWL
POPULATIONS IN THOSE AREAS. ARE
BILL WOULD.
CREATE A CALIFORNIA SPECIFIC
PROGRAM.
PACIFIC FLEET TAILORED TO OUR
GROWERS
AND WE BELIEVE THAT'S WHAT'S
GOING TO BE NEEDED TO REALLY.
IMPROVE OUR OUR WATER FOUND
OTHER PER POPULATIONS HERE SO WE
ARE RISK REAP ASPECT FULLY I
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
IT'S GOODNESS YES MY NAME IS DAN
CONNELLY I AM.
WITH PRESENTS FOR EVER.
AND.
.
THIS PROGRAM HAS SOME VERY SOME
REALLY BROAD OF BENEFITS.
OBVIOUSLY OUR PRIMARY INTEREST
IS IN IN AND UPLAND UPLAND GAME
BIRD NESTING.
BUT IT ALSO HAS.
BENEFITS TO AIR QUALITY SOIL
FERTILITY FLOOD CONTROL. OUR
WATER QUALITY CARBON
SEQUESTRATION TALK A LITTLE BIT
EARLIER ABOUT.
BENEFICIAL INSECTS MONARCH
BUTTERFLIES.
VIEW SCAPIN AND AND OBVIOUSLY
WILDLIFE SO IT'S A IT'S A VERY
BROAD.
THE VERY BROAD DATA.
BENEFITS TO THIS IS JUST BASS
HE WIPED Y. STEWARDSHIP OF THE
LAND IF YOU'RE GONNA IT'S PART
OF A TRANSFER. IN HOW WOULD YOU
RATHER HAVE THE LAND IF IT'S IF
IT'S AND IT LOOKED LIKE A
PARKING LOT OR IF YOU HAVE SOME
VEGETATION ON THAT LAND SO.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST US SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE WANTING TO
ADD ON IN SUPPORT.
NAME ORGANIZATION.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARIAN
WARMER DAMMIT THROUGHOUT
COUNTIES RIPLEY'S TO SUPPORT
THIS MEASURE SIMILAR TO EARLIER
MEASURE. A WE WILL LEAVE THIS
HELPS CONTRIBUTE TO THE OF
ECOLOGICAL OUT ATTRIBUTES OF THE
VALLEYS. AS WELL AS KEEPING THE
LANDS ON PRIVATE PROPERTY TAX
ROLLS THANK YOU.
JERRY LINK DUCKS UNLIMITED
SUPPORT.
ONE OF THE BE DONE WITHOUT ABOUT
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
FOR A GROUP AT THE CULPRIT RIFLE
PISSED ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT.
DOMINIQUE OFTEN ON BEHALF OF THE
GRASSLAND WATER DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT.
WE'RE GOING TO MEAN FOR THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
PUBLIC REYES WHO WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN
SUPPORT.
KEN DELFINO DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT.
BILL GAINES ABOUT HALF THE CSU
RESOURCES CONSERVATION DISTRICT
THE CALIFORNIA BOWMAN UNDERSTAND
ARTERY ASSOCIATION WHILE SHE
FOUNDATION THE BLACK PRINT GROUP
IN THE CAL OR WHAT ONCE
WONDERFUL COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
LAURIE JACOBS CALIFORNIANS ONE
FOR CONSERVATION AND SUPPORT.
PAT FITZ MORRISON WITH
CALIFORNIA DEAR ASSOCIATION AND
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KEVIN FELLOW WITH THE NATIONAL
WILD TURKEY FEDERATION STRONG
SUPPORT.
OKAY ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
I'M BACK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE KATHY CALLED
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
I WE SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE
A COALITION LETTER OF ABOUT
ELEVEN SIGNATORIES TO REPRESENT
WATER AGENCIES WHO THEIR DARK
DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY
PARTICIPATE THE WATER TRANSFER
MARKET.
AND OUR LETTER OUTLINES OUR
CONCERNS WITH THE BILL.
UP OVER THE YEARS MANY THE
SIGNATORIES OF TO THE LETTER
HAVE IMPLEMENTED WATER TRANSFERS
IN CLOSE COORDINATION WITH THE
PURE ON GW ARE. AND HISTORICALLY
THOSE TWO AGENCIES HAVE NOT
ALLOWED ANY VEGETATION LANDS
FOLLOW TO PRODUCE WATER FOR
WATER TRANSFERS.
THE REQUIREMENTS NECESSARY IN
STILL IMPORT TODAY IT ACCURATE
ACCURATELY DETERMINE THE AMOUNT
OF WATER THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
CONSUMED BY THE FOREGOING
FOREGONE CROP ABSENT THE WATER
TRANSFER.
LET ME EMPHASIZE HERE WE BELIEVE
THAT MAINTAINING USEFUL WATER
HAVE WILDLIFE HABITAT DOES NOT
HAVE TO BE. A INCOMPATIBLE WITH
WATER TRANSFERS.
HOWEVER THERE'S GOT TO BE AN
APPROPRIATE ADJUSTMENT MADE UP
TO THE AMOUNT OF WATER ELIGIBLE
FOR THE TRANSFER TO ACCOUNT FOR
CONSUMPTIVE USE IS NECESSARY TO
MAIN HABITAT OR IDLE FARMLAND.
THE DETERMINATION OF THE AMOUNT
OF WATER ELIGIBLE FOR THE
TRANSFER MUST BE TRANSPARENT.
AND IT'S GOING TO PROBABLY BE A
COSTS FOR COMPLETING THE WATER
TRANSFER UNLESS OTHER FUNDS ARE
MADE AVAILABLE FOR THAT PURPOSE.
SO SINCE THE PASSAGE OF SB SEVEN
FORTY NINE BY SENATOR A LOS WALK
BACK IN TWENTY THIRTEEN. D. W.
R. HAS ALLOWED NON IRRIGATED
VEGETATION REMAIN ON THE FALLOW
LANDS IF THE LANDOWNER CAN
DEMONSTRATESUCH VEGETATIONS NOT
CONSUMING TRANSFERRED WATER.
THIS APPROACH ALLOWS DWI TO
ENSURE THAT LEGAL WATER USERS
ARE NOT NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY
ANY VEGETATION CONSUMING WATER
ON THAT FELLOW PLAN.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT UNDER
THE BILL OF FARMERS COULD BE
PAID BOTH TO ALLOW VEGETATION
REMAIN ON AYE THE LANDS AS WELL
AS REMOVING VEGETATION FROM AYE
THE LANCE REPLIED WATER TRANSFER
SUPPLIES.
THIS COULD VERY MUCH MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR D. W. ART AND
FORCES WATER TRANSFER RULES
SINCE A FARMER WANNA MAXIMIZE
BOTH FUNDING STREAMS. BY ARGUING
THAT ANY VEGETATION LEFT ON AYE
THE LANCE IS NOT CONSUMING
WATER.
SO WE BELIEVE THE EXISTING LAW
ALREADY STRIKES A BALANCE WHICH
IS IMPORTANT FOR ENCOURAGING
COVER CROPS AS WELL AS
PROTECTING WATER TRANSFERS. AND
THAT WAS THE COMPROMISE THAT WE
STRUCK ALONG WITH OTHER
OPPONENTS AND THE SUPPORTERS AND
PROPONENTS BACK IN TWENTY
THIRTEEN.
SADDAM MINIMUM WE WOULD ASK THAT
THE BILL BE REVISED TO ELIMINATE
ANY NEW REQUIREMENTS TO MAKE IT
MORE DIFFICULT TO FORGET OF YARD
FROM FORCES WATER TRANSFER
RULES.
THINKING.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO. STATE FOR THE RECORD
THEIR OPPOSITION BILL.
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND
MANY WERE KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON
BEHALF OF MOJAVE WATER AGENCY
MUSLIMS WATER DISTRICT.
AND WE ARE EQUALLY CONCERNED
WERE SUPPORTIVE OF THE.
GOAL OF INCREASE UPLAND HABITAT
WE THINK IT'S WORTHWHILE BUT WE
ARE.
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR TO GET
CLARIFICATION ON THE ACCOUNTING
FOR THE WATER TRANSFERRED
ACCURATELY THANKS.
YOU CHAIR MEMBERS CANDIDATE JOB
ON BEHALF OF THE KERN COUNTY
WATER AGENCY IN SAN BENITO
VALLEY MISS WATER DISTRICT.
BOBBY CISSY AT OUR COMMENTS WITH
THOSE IN SCHOOLS.
CHRISTY FOR A WITH THREE
VALLEY'S ADMISSIBLE WATER
DISTRICT WE ARE ALSO OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED FOR THE REASONS
OUTLINED BY. AND MW DEAN
MYTHICAL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE BILL DOES HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
QUESTIONS FROM OUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
I HAVE MISTER GALLAGHER AYE.
I HATE TO COME OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE NOT VOTING FOR AT
LEAST ONE OF YOUR FILMS.
ARE YOU WILLING TO WORK WITH
THE WATER AGENCIES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR CONCERNS.
YES.
AND WE ALREADY HAVE BEEN IN
DISCUSSIONS AND.
SO ONE I'VE ALREADY TAKEN SOME
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THE
MOSQUITO VECTOR CONTROL.
ASSOCIATION OF SOME OF THEIR
CONCERNS AND KNOW. MY I AM
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING THE
WATER TRANSFER ISSUE TOO I MEAN
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO GET OUT AS
FIND THAT. THAT HAPPY MEDIUM YOU
KNOW WHEN WHEN THERE ARE WATER
TRANSFERS RIGHT NOW.
BASICALLYTHE RULES YOU JUST
FOLLOW THOSE COMPLETELY GRAY AND
SO THERE'S NOTHING GROWING THERE
AT ALL.
.
AND ACTUALLY HAS EVEN BEEN SOME
ISSUES TAXI DOWN IN THE DELTA
WHERE THERE WAS A TRANSFER.
AND OR TO KEEP THE VEGETATION
OFF YOU HAVE TO DO AERIAL SPRAYS
IN AN AERIAL SPRAY WAS DONE IN
WHICH ALL THE IT IS ACTUALLY THE
DELTA WINDS PICKED UP AND
CARRIED IT OVER ALL BUNCH OF.
OTHER CROPLAND AND SO THE AND
THERE WAS A HUGE LAWSUIT OVER
AND LIABILITIES SO.
YOU KNOW.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO KEEP THEM
COMPLETELY CLEAN IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND THERE'S SOME LIABILITY
CONCERNS.
BUT ALSO I THINK EVERYBODY
AGREES AND EVEN THE OPPOSITION
SAID WE WANT TO HAVE ACTUALLY IF
WE CAN DO NON IRRIGATED COVER
CROP ON THIS THAT'S ACTUALLY
BETTER FOR WILDLIFE.
THEN OBVIOUSLY THAT'S KIND OF
THE GOAL WE'RE TRYING TO GET AT
IS TO ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN HAVE
AN INCENTIVE PROGRAM IN PLACE.
SO THE LANDOWNERS DO THAT SO
EVEN MORE DROUGHT.
OR WERE HAVING TO DO WATER
TRANSFERS WE'RE STILL GONNA HAVE
THAT HABITAT THAT IS NEEDED BY
MIGRATORY.
WATER FELL AND I THINK THERE'S
A HAPPY BALANCE TO DO THAT I
THINK WHAT THEY'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT IS HOUSE THAT ACCOUNTED
FOR IF THERE'S ANY WATER LOST.
AN ARM AND I THINK I THINK WE
CAN DO THAT AND THAT'S WHAT WE
ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING. TO
THAT ISSUE AGAIN I'M NOT.
TOTALLY TIED TO JUSTICE LANGUAGE
AND I'LL BE WORKING WITH THEM
FEEL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
WATER AGENCY YES AND MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR CONCERNS ARE
ADDRESSED AND. THEN I'LL BE ABLE
TO VOTE ON IT ON THE FLOOR AS
WELL SO.
I ALSO PUT IT TODAY GIVEN YOUR
COMMITMENT DOES NOT LOVE TO HAVE
YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTIONS
YOUR COMMENTS SEEN NONE THERE'S
A MOTION AND SECOND.
MADE BY MISTER BIGELOW SHOULD
GLORIA THAT DOES HAVE A DO PASS.
REGULATION TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WE'LL TAKE THAT AS YOUR CLOTHES.
BROKAW.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA I.
SEE I GALLAGHER AYE GALLAGHER
AYE BIGELOW.
IT LOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI.
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN I.
FRIEDMAN I GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE
HARPER AYE AYE HARPER AYE KALRA.
LEVINE. MATHIS
I MATHIS AYE RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE
SOLACE.
NO SOLACE NO WOULD.
WE WILL LEAVE THE CULT ON THAT
ITEM AS WELL. IN EXCITED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
.
PROUD TO PRESENT A VERY
IMPORTANT BILL.
.
AND FOR ME A BEAST THIRTY FORTY
FIVE.
.
FEEL WHEN I INITIALLY INTRODUCED
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO GET OUT.
A PROBLEM THAT THAT IT REALLY
WAS HIGHLIGHTED IN THE AFTERMATH
OF THE OROVILLE CRISIS.
AND THAT IS ESSENTIALLY THE.
THE SAME AGENCY RIGHT NOW THAT.
OPERATES AND MAINTAINS THE STATE
WATER PROJECT INCLUDING OROVILLE
DAM.
IS ALSO THE SAME AGENCY THAT
PROVIDES THE REGULATORY
OVERSIGHT. OF PROVIDES
INSPECTIONS AND PROVIDES THE
FEEDBACK AND REGULATES.
THE ENTITY THAT'S OPERATING
THAT'S DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES OPERATES.
A THE DAMS A MAINTAINS THEM AND
IN THEIR DIVISION OF DAM SAFETY
IS TASKED WITH THEN REGULATING.
HOW THAT OPERATION TO MAINTAIN
MAINTENANCE IS TAKING PLACE SO?
THE ORIGINAL INTENT HERE WAS TO
ACTUALLY TAKE DIVISION A DAM
SAFETY OUT OF THE W. ARE AND
MAKE IT.
AND PUTIT SEPARATED FROM
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
AND BUT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
WHICH HAVE BEEN PROPOSED I THINK
WOULD DO THE THE SAME THING.
AND I'M I ACTUALLY ACTUALLY IN
AND LOOKING AT THEM.
I THINK IT OPENS UP A
CONVERSATION A REALLY NEED TO
HAVE ESPECIALLY IN THE AFTERMATH
OF WAR BILL WHICH IS. SHOULD WE
HAVE A DIFFERENT. AND MORE
INDEPENDENT OVERSIGHT OF THE
STATE WATER PROJECT ITSELF.
AND.
SO WHAT.
I AM GOING TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
AND THEN WHAT THAT WOULD DO
INSTEAD IS ACTUALLY CREATE AN
INDEPENDENT STATE WATER PROJECT
COMMISSION NINE MEMBER
COMMISSION.
I THAT WOULD OVERSEE THE STATE
WATER PROJECT.
INSISTS IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
BEEN PROPOSED PREVIOUSLY BY THE
LETTER LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION.
AND I'M.
AND I THINK IN THE AFTERMATH OF
OROVILLE.
THAT MANY OF YOU HAVE HAD.
HEARD OF AN OBSCENE THE FORENSIC
REPORT WHICH HIGHLIGHTED.
AND THERE WERE SOME.
MAJOR ISSUES THERE WITHOUT THE
W. ARE OPERATED AND MAINTAINED
OROVILLE DAM. FOR EXAMPLE IT
FOUND ORGANIZATIONAL FACTORS IN
HUMAN FACTORS THAT CONTRIBUTED
TO THAT. THAT THERE WAS A
CULTURAL.
A OVERCONFIDENCE IDW ARE ABOUT
THE INTEGRITY OF THE STATE WATER
PROJECT.
AND.
A REACTIVE VERSUS PROACTIVE
APPROACH TO PROJECT MAY
MANAGEMENT.
THERE WERE BASIC DESIGN AND
MAINTENANCE
FLAWS THAT WERE.
BUT NOT ADDRESS DIMMER
OVERLOOKED.
AND AND THERE WERE COST CONTROL
PRESSURES THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
IN THE.
OF THE REPORT IS WELL THAT THAT
LED TO THE CRISIS.
AND SO WHAT THIS WHAT THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WOULD DO IS
ACTUALLY CREATE A NEW COMMISSION
THAT WOULD PROVIDE THAT
OVERSIGHT TO THE STATE WATER
PROJECT AN INDEPENDENT
COMMISSION.
AS WE HAVE IN MANY OTHER
INSTANCES AND I ACTUALLY AS WE
ACTUALLY HAVE IN MANY OTHER
STATES.
WERE ACTUALLY KIND OF A VERY
DIFFERENT CALIFORNIAN THAT WE
DON'T HAVE.
A AN INDEPENDENT BODY
INDEPENDENT COMMISSION PROVIDING
THAT OVERSIGHT.
AND.
SO I THINK THIS IS VERY MUCH
SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO.
DISCUSS A MOVE FOR OBVIOUS
CAESAR COMMITTEE MEMBERS BEING
PROPOSED A DAY AND THERE NEEDS
TO BE MORE DISCUSSION MOVING
FORWARD.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS VERY
MUCH A DISCUSSION WE NEED TO
HAVE IN A DIRECTION WE NEED TO
MOVE IN.
THE OTHER THINK THAT THE
COMMISSION WOULD DO.
AND I THINK THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT AS PROVIDE
TRANSPARENCY.
THE COMMISSION WOULD BE
GOVERNED BY BAGLEY KEENE.
THAT SOMETHING THAT'S REALLY
NOT QUITE THE CASE WITH
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
RESOURCES RIGHT NOW WHEN IT
COMES TO HOW THE STATE WATER
PROJECT.
IS OF MAINTAINED WE DON'T HAVE
THAT ANSWER HAVE THE SAME
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCESS.
TWO RECORDS THAT WE WOULD HAVE
UNDER BAGLEY KEENE. PASSABLY
THAT'S ANOTHER IMPORTANT MEASURE
SO. THAT I WOULD ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS AND I
WOULD ASK.
FOR THIS COMMITTEE SUPPORT AS
THIS IS A.
AND CONTINUED MUCH NEED REFORM.
AT DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
AND ENSURING THE INTEGRITY AND
THE SAFETY OF OUR STATE WATER
PROJECT FOR THE ENTIRE STATE.
NOW THANK YOU NICE RIBA.
ASK UP FOR THOSE WHO WANT TO
COME FORWARD AND.
I JUST FIND SUPPORT A BILL.
KAREN LANG ON BEHALF OF THE
BUTTE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS THAT THE CENTER OF
THIS EVENT ASKING FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
A BECAUSE OF THE CIRCLE
CALIFORNIA WERE SUPPORTIVE AT
THE INITIAL CONCEPT THE BILL
I'VE JUST HAVEN'T HAD ANY CHANCE
TO WAY AND.
UNFORTUNATELY BUT WE ARE
LOOKING FOR TWO WAYS TO PUT MORE
EMPHASIS ON MAINTENANCE OF
EXISTING DAMS IN THE STATE BAD
DOING SO WHICH COULD INCREASE
WATER SUPPLY.
WHILE STAYING WITHIN THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF
EXISTING STRUCTURES AND MAKE
THOSE OVERALL SAFER.
WE WILL LOOK AT THE MOMENT SAID
AND WEIGH IN ON THOSE IN THE
FUTURE.
THANK YOU YOU ELSE WISHING TO
ADD ON SUPPORT.
SUE NO KNAUS ANYONE WISHING TO.
DESPITE OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
ED MANNING ON BEHALF THE MOJAVE
WATER AGENCIES STATE WATER
PROJECT CONTRACTOR.
WE DID NOT HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL.
UNTIL NOW.
AND THE REASON WE DIDN'T IS
MISTER GALLAGHER'S BILLATTEMPT
TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE. THAT
IMPACTED HIS DISTRICT DIRECTLY
WHICH IS THE ISSUE DAM SAFETY.
AND THE QUESTION OF THE ROLE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES IN
INSPECTING AROUND FACILITIES
WHICH IS A LEGITIMATE.
ISSUE FOR DEBATE AND SO WE HELD
OFF.
BUT THIS IS NOW A RADICAL BILL
THIS BILL REVERSES FIFTY YEARS
OF HISTORY THE BURNS PORTER AT.
AND IN A COMMITTEE AMENDMENT.
SUGGESTS THAT WE SHOULD TAKE.
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES.
AND TAKE AWAY THE STATE WATER
PROJECT AND JUST PUT IT IN
ANOTHER AGENCY.
WHEN YOU GONNA CHANGE FIFTY
YEARS OF CALIFORNIA WATER
STRUCTURE HISTORY GOVERNANCE.
PERHAPS.
SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO AN INTERIM
STUDY.
PERHAPS THE COMMITTEE SHOULD
HAVE NUMEROUS INFORMATIONAL
HEARINGS TO UNDERSTAND HOW THE
WATER BONDS ARE STRUCTURED.
THE ROLE OF THE STATE WATER
PROJECT.
THE FACT THAT THE STATE WATER
PROJECT CONTRACTORS RATE PAYERS
ARE THE ONES WHO PAY AND. IN
MANY OTHER STATES ACTUALLY THE
STRUCTURE IS THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY PAY THE RATES LIKE
MOJAVE WATER AGENCY RATEPAYERS
ARE METROPOLITAN.
HAVE DIRECT GOVERNANCE OVER THE
PROJECT.
SO WE CAME HERE TODAY NOT
ANTICIPATING BEING IN THIS
POSITION. BUT THIS BILL NOW
DRAMATICALLY CHANGES
THE STRUCTURE OF CALIFORNIA
WATER POLICY.
AND WE WOULD ARGUE THAT PERHAPS
IT WOULD BE BETTER DONE NOT IN
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT. BUT IN
A FULL FLEDGED DISCUSSION ON AN
ISSUE THAT REALLY MERITS FAR
MORE.
DISCUSSION AND THOUGHT THAN THIS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN PRISON
THE COMMITTEE CATHY COLE AGAIN
TO THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT ON JUST TO BUILD SOME
OF MY COLLEAGUES SAID ON.
HOLIDAYS FOR THE LATE OPPOSE.
WE HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE BILL
THIS IS A VERY COMPLEX
SITUATION OTHERS FINANCIAL
IMPLICATIONS I DON'T BELIEVE
IT'S READY FOR PRIMETIME YET
LEGISLATIVELY. WE SHOULD DUST
OFF THAT TWENTY TEN LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION ANALYSIS.
MAYBE COME UP WITH SOME
HEARINGS AND DEVELOP A PLAN
THAT'S FULLY DEVELOPED WITH
INPUT FROM STAKE HOLDERS.
NOT ALL OPTIONS OF GOVERNANCE.
AND OVERSIGHT TRANSPARENCY HAVE
BEEN EXPLORED UNDER THE BILL AS
PROPOSED.
WATER RIGHTS DEBT SERVICE
OBLIGATIONS BONDS THIS IS A HUGE
ISSUE.
AND I WOULD JUST URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO CONSIDER THAT IT'S
NOT REALLY PRIME TIME YET FOR
THIS AND MORE ADVANCED WORK IS
NECESSARY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
THANK YOU.
THE CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BOB REBIRTH
REAP GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ON
BEHALF OF DESERT WATER AGENCIES.
WILL HAVE AN OFFICIAL POSITION
ON THE BILL WE ASSOCIATE ARE.
CONCERN WITH ABOUT FIVE
EXCLAMATION POINTS A.
IN ASSOCIATE OURSELVES WITH
PRIOR WITNESSES.
FIVE.
ANYWHERE ELSE.
LORENA BRING IT BACK TO ANY
QUESTIONS COMMENTS REMEMBERS.
THANK YOU. AT.
LET'S WANT TO GIVE US GALLAGHER
CHANCE TO RESPOND TO SOME OF THE
OPPOSITION AND HAVE WE LOOKED AT
DOING ANY INTERIM HEARINGS OR
ANYTHING ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE
SUM WITH THIS WOULD ACTUALLY
INTEL AND THE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OF SUCH ACTION.
SO FIRST THEY WERE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE BROUGHT
FORWARD.
.
BUT IT REALLY GOT THE HEART OF
WHAT I WAS TRYING TO DO AND SO.
YOU KNOW IT'S REALLY THE
INVERSE OF WHAT I WAS TRYING TO
DO RIGHT WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
IS PULL DIVISION A DAM SAFETY.
OUT OF DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES AND MAKE IT
INDEPENDENT.
BUT ACTUALLY THE CONFLICT GOES
AWAY IF YOU JUST TAKE THE STATE
WATER PROJECT OUT OF VW ARE.
AND THEN THE W. ARE WILL SERVE
ITS REGULATORY FUNCTION. OF
INSPECTING DAMS ACROSS THE STATE
ARM.
SO ID IT ACCOMPLISHES THE SAME
PURPOSE.
AND I WOULD AGREE THAT YOU KNOW
THEY'RE IT THIS IS A SIGNIFICANT
CHANGE IT IS.
ARM BUT WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
STOPPING THE CONVERSATION WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT OPEN IT UP.
AND WE NEED TO START HAVING THE
CONVERSATION.
.
YES HAS BEEN FIFTY PLUS YEARS
BUT THAT'S FIFTY PLUS YEARS OF
WHAT THIS FORENSIC REPORTER
SHOWN WAS.
A NOT PAYING ATTENTION TO A
FUNDAMENTAL DESIGN FLAW IN THE
SPILLWAY AT THE AT ORVILLE. AND
THAT'S UNDER THE W. ARE UNDER
THEIR WATCH THIS IS WHAT'S
HAPPENED RIGHT IN THE NOTHING
FELL APART AND PUT HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND OF MY
CONSTITUENTS.
AND AT RISK IT'S NOT NOT PAID
ATTENTION TO VERY CLEAR
FUNDAMENTAL FLAWS CRACKS THAT
WERE FORMING IN THAT SPILLWAY
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN. THAT.
NOT ME THAT THE FORENSIC TEAM.
TOTALLY INDEPENDENT GROUP OF OF
EXPERTS
LOOKED AT AND SAID THAT SHOULD
HAVE BEEN. A SOMETHING THAT THEY
SHOULD HAVE PAID ATTENTION TO
AND UNDERSTOOD THAT THAT WAS A
FUNDAMENTAL FLAW.
AND IT'S YEARS OF OF DEFERRED
MAINTENANCE.
OF ISSUES NOT BEING ADDRESSED OF
ORGANIZATIONAL FLAWS A CULTURE
THAT THE INDEPENDENT.
FORENSIC TEAM.
SAID A CULTURE WHERE THEY
CREATED A MYTHOLOGY.
A MYTHOLOGY QUOTE UNQUOTE OF
WHAT OF THE INTEGRITY OF OF THE
STRUCTURE UP THERE.
THAT CAN'T BE IGNORED THAT
FIFTY PLUS YEARS.
OF WHAT I WOULD CALL.
NOT VERY GOOD ORGANIZATION NOT
GET MAINTENANCE
ANNA AND NOT TAKING CARE OF THE
STATE WATER PROJECT THAT DOESN'T
JUST AFFECT MY DISTRICT RIGHT.
IT AFFECTS THE ENTIRE STATE.
SENSE THAT THAT FIFTY YEARS OF
POOR MANAGEMENT HAS BEEN NOW
REVEALED FOR THE WORLD. I THINK
IT'S ABOUT TIME THAT WE HAVE
THIS DISCUSSION ABOUT HAVING AN
INDEPENDENT COMMISSION AS WE'VE
DONE IN MANY OTHER AREAS.
TAKE OVER CONTROL THE STATE
WATER PROJECT IN ENSURE.
THAT THOSE THINGS ARE DONE
RIGHT.
ANNA AND I WOULD REMIND ACTUALLY
YOU KNOW PEOPLE FROM OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE.
NOW THAT.
YOU CAN'T HOLD AS MUCH WATER IN
OROVILLE DAM.
AFTER THE WETTEST YEAR ON
RECORD.
MANY WATER DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE ARE GOING TO BE FACING
WATER SHORTAGE SHORTAGES AND
WE'RE BASIC GONNA BE POTENTIALLY
BACK IN A DROUGHT.
SITUATION BECAUSE OF THAT SAME
MISMANAGEMENT.
AND SO REGARDLESS OF WHERE
YOU'RE FROM. IN CALIFORNIA. AND
YOU SHOULD WANT.
BETTER OVERSIGHT AND MANAGEMENT
YOU SHOULD WANT BETTER
TRANSPARENCY.
THAT'S THE OTHER THING ABOUT THE
COMMISSION WE SHOULD WANT BETTER
TRANSPARENCY. ABOUT HOW THESE
DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT.
WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO HOW THESE
ISSUES ARE BEING ADDRESSED AND I
THINK WE YOU KNOW WE CAN ARGUE
ABOUT WHAT THAT COMMISSION LOOKS
LIKE? I WANT TO HAVE CONTINUE
DISCUSSION ON THAT I'M GONNA
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS.
AND HAVE OPEN DIALOGUE WITH THE
OPPOSITION I'M NOT GOING AWAY I
TO REMIND PEOPLE I AM A
REPUBLICAN.
THERE'S NOTHING THAT I CAN
STEAMROLL THROUGH THIS PROCESS
BUT.
BE OTHERS KNOW WHERE I CAN
STEAMROLL ANYTHING THROUGH THIS
PROCESS.
AND AND I I THINK THIS IS A
GOOD.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S NEW
THIS WAS BROUGHT UP BY THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION. SNOT
THIS NEW CONCEPT IT'S BEEN BEING
DISCUSSED AND TALKED ABOUT EYES
ONE OPEN UP THE DISCUSSION AND
CONTINUE IT AND SO THAT'S WHY I
WOULD ASK. FOR THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT TODAY A TO MOVE THIS
MEASURE FOR.
SO IN HEAR DISCUSSIONS AND YOUR
RESEARCH ORDER JUST FOLLOW UP
AND YOU'VE MENTIONED THE LITTLE
HOOVER COMMISSION BUT THERE IS
THERE ANYTHING IN THE LITTLE
WHO.
HOOVER COMMISSION REPORT THAT'S
REFLECTED IN THE LEGISLATION OR
IN THE BILL CURRENTLY.
THE YES IT IT BASICALLY TAKES
THE WILL HOOVER COMMISSION'S
IDEA OF CREATING A NINE MEMBER
COMMISSION THAT WOULD OVERSEE.
DE AT THE STATE WATER PROJECT
ANNA. AND.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE. YOU KNOW
THERE ARE SOME DIFFERENCES BUT
LARGELY IT'S THE SAME IDEA AND
CONCEPT THAT WAS PUSHED BY THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION.
OKAY UPSTART BECAUSE I THOUGHT
THE LANGUAGE WAS TO. BASICALLY
JUST HANDED OVER TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY THAT'S WHAT THE
BILL DID ORIGINALLY WAS I WOULD.
ORIGINALLY THE BILL WOULD OF
TAKEN THE DIVISION OF DAM
SAFETY.
OUT OF THE W. R. AND PUT IT
UNDER NATURAL RESOURCES.
NOW WITH THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS IT CREATES A NEW NINE
MEMBER COMMISSION.
THAT WOULD BE TASKED WITH
OVERSEEN THE STATE WATER PROJECT
IN BASE WE WOULD TAKE STATE. THE
STATE WATER PROJECT OUT OF THE
W. ARE AND PUT IT UNDERNEATH
THIS THIS COMMISSION.
GOT IT THINKS.
IN THE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
TEEN.
NO MORE SPECIAL DIETS THIS DOES
HAVE A DO PASS.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENT FOR OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS LOOK I YOU
MENTIONED. AT YOUR REPUBLICAN.
.
MY DEMOCRAT.
I'M WANTING TO ENTERTAIN THIS
CONVERSATION
CONSIDERING THAT THE LA O. AND
D. LITTLE OVER A HAS MADE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS ON THIS
CONVERSATION.
LAST YEAR WE HAD A A. B..
THREE THIRTEEN SPONSORED BY.
ADAM GRAY THAT HAD SOME VERY
SIMILAR COMPONENTS TO THIS THAT
BOTH A PASSED THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR TO GET
ONE IN THE MORNING.
AND SO OUT OF YOU SEE PEOPLE
WANT TO HAVE THE CONVERSATION
AND I'M WILLING TO CONTINUE TO
FURTHER THIS OUT DISCUSSION SO.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
THE DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER AYE CALIBER AYE
BIGELOW.
I TODAY RESERVE ALRIGHT.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO. CHOI.
CHIU.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GLORIA.
HARPER AYE HARPER AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE
SOLIS.
SOLACE I WOULD.
WE KEEP THAT OPEN FOR THE
MEASURES THAT. I THINK IS JIM
WOULDN'T GO BACK TO A FILE ORDER
AND WE DON'T HAVE ANY AUTHORS IT
WITH EXCEPTION OF OUR. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
SO ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
RUBIO AND THEN MR MATHIS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
I'D TODAY I AM PRESENTING AB
TWENTY TO FORTY TWO WHAT RICK
AYE THAT WOULD REQUIRE IN URBAN
WATER SUPPLIER TO INCLUDE IN ITS
URBAN WATER MANAGEMENT PLAN AN
ASSESSMENT OF THE RELIABILITY.
OF ITS WATER SERVICE PROVIDER
PROVIDED TO CUSTOMERS DURING
CERTAIN EYES SPECIFIED
CONDITIONS INCLUDING DRY AND
MULTIPLE DRY YEARS.
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES WATER
SUPPLIERS TO PREPARE URBAN.
WATER MANAGEMENT PLANS EVERY
FIVE YEARS THESE PLANS ARE
REQUIRED TO INCLUDE A
DESCRIPTION OF THE RELIABILITY
OF THE WATER SUPPLY AND
VULNERABILITY OF SHORTAGES.
THE RECENT DROUGHT NEGOTIATED.
THE VALUE OF PLANNING
PREPARATION AND INVESTMENT BY
LOCAL WATER SUPPLIERS AND THE
NEED FOR MORE INFORMATION TO
ALLOW THE STATE TO BETTER ASSESS
WATER SUPPLY CONDITIONS TO
ENSURE STATE. OUT AGENCIES CAN
RESPOND APPROPRIATELY. WHAT
WOULD THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE?
DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WE WILL MOTIONS
SECOND. ANY PEACE ANYONE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
OKAY AND ONE ONE TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
CASEY NONE ALL ASKING FOR
BROKEN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO. CHOI.
TO.
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I GLORIA.
HARPER.
AFTER I KALRA. LEVINE. LEVINE
AYE MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE RUBIO
AYE VIA AYE SOLACE. SOLACE I
WOULD.
LEAVE THAT OPEN FOR OTHER
MEMBERS HAD ON I THINK OF YOU
SUMMER MATHIS
.
HERE.
RIGHT.
I BELIEVE WE'RE STILL ON
MORNING.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
TODAY I AM PRESENT TEAM.
HE BE.
THREE ELEVENTHS SEVEN.
THE BILL WOULD ADDRESS THE
SERIOUS CONCERNS BY ALLOWING
FISH AND GAME COMMISSION TO
TEMPORARY SUSPEND THE
PROHIBITION.
OF THE USE OF LEAD AMMUNITION
FOR THOSE CALIBERS THAT MAY BE
REASONABLY AVAILABLE.
TO THE CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
DURING PEAK TIMES.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE
MISTER BILL GAINES REPRESENTING
THE SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE
BUILDS LAWYERS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS BILL
GAINES SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE CO SPONSORS OF THE BILL
THE ROCKY MOUNTAIN ELK
FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA DEAR
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
THE WHILE SHE FOUNDATION IN THE
CALIFORNIA ANNOUNCEMENT FOR
CONSERVATION.
THIS BILL HAS BEEN PASSED AS
BEING ATTEMPT TO SIMPLY REVERSE
IF YOU WILL. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
RENDON'S AB SEVEN ELEVEN I CAN
ASSURE YOU THAT IS NOT THE CASE.
IN JULY OF TWENTY NINETEEN
LITTLE OVER A YEAR FROM NOW.
NON LEAD AMMUNITION TO BE
REQUIRED FOR THE TAKING OF ALL
WILDLIFE'S. NOT ONLY BY HUNTERS
BUT BY RANCHERS FARMERS AND
OTHERS IT MAY BE TRYING TO
PROTECT THEIR INVESTMENTS FROM
DEPREDATION.
THE ODDEST WIN THRILLED WITH THE
PASSAGE OF AB SEVEN ELEVEN BACK
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN BUT WE DID
TAKE SOME COMFORT IN KNOWING
THAT WE STILL HAD THE ABILITY TO
GO ONLINE MAIL ORDER OR TRAVEL
OUT OF STATE TO PURCHASE
AMMUNITION. THAT WE NEED TO HUNT
AND TO.
CONTROL DEPREDATION IN OUR STATE
BUT THINGS HAVE CHANGED SINCE
PASSAGE OF AB SEVEN ELEVEN.
COUPLE YEARS AGO WE HAD THE
PASSAGE OF TWO PROPOSALS THAT
PUT SERIOUS RESTRICTIONS ON THE
ABILITY OF HUNTERS RANCHERS
FARMERS AND OTHERS. TO PURCHASE
AMMUNITION THE STATE NO LONGER
CAN YOU GO OUT OF STATE VIA
INTERNET MAIL ORDER OTHER WAYS
WITHOUT GOING TO THE VERY
CUMBERSOME AND COSTLY PROCESS OF
BRINGING IT BACK THE WAY
PERMITTED AMMUNITION DEAR.
IN JULY OF TWENTY NINETEEN AB
SEVEN ELEVEN WILL TAKE FULL
EFFECT THAT MEANS IF A RANCHER
OR A FARMER OR A HUNDRED DOES
NOT. OR CANNOT OBTAIN AMMUNITION
THAT DOES NOT LEAD FOR HIS
RIFLE.
HE CANNOT OR THEY CAN'T DO THEIR
DEPREDATION.
DUTIES.
CALIFORNIA'S THE ONLY STATE IN
THE NATION THAT ACTUALLY
REQUIRES THE USE OF NON LEAD
AMMUNITION FOR THE TAKING OF ALL
WILDLIFE.
CALIFORNIA'S A VERY VERY SMALL
MARKET SHARE
WHEN IT COMES TO MANUFACTURERS
OR MANUFACTURING LEAD AMMUNITION
NATIONWIDE THAT SUDDENLY HAVE TO
PUT OUT SOME PRODUCTION OF NON
TOXIC LOAD INTO THE ARE INDEED
TO PUT THEM OUT THERE.
AB SEVEN ELEVEN WOULD SIMPLY
ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA FISH AND
GAME COMMISSION AND THE ABILITY
WHAT REQUIRE BUT WOULD GIVE THEM
THE AUTHORITY TO TEMPORARILY
SUSPEND THE LED BAND FOR
SPECIFIC CALIBER. IF THOSE LOADS
WERE UNAVAILABLE THAT BOARD OF
FIVE APPOINTED BY THE GOVERNOR
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE. A IS A
VERY REASONABLE BOARD THEIR
ACTIONS ARE DONE IN PUBLIC
FORUM.
THEY ALSO HAVE THEIR WILDLIFE
RESOURCES COMMITTEE WHICH IS THE
SECOND.
VENUE IF YOU WILL FOR THEM
VETTING YOU KNOW ISSUES SUCH AS
THIS ALL STAKEHOLDERS ARE ARE
PRESENT IN THOSE DISCUSSIONS.
IF AMMUNITION OF KNOWLEDGE
VARIETY IS AVAILABLE.
A. B. THIRTY ONE SEVENTEEN WILL
DO NOTHING BUT IF IT'S NOT
AVAILABLE IT WILL SIMPLY GIVE
THE FISHING GAME COMMISSION. THE
AUTHORITY IF THEY'D LIKE TO.
TEMPORARILY SUSPEND FOR A SHORT
THREE YEAR PERIOD.
THE.
NON LED PROHIBITION ON
AMMUNITION KEEPING HUNTERS IN
THE FIELD AND KEEPING RANCHERS
AND FARMERS THE ABILITY TO
PROTECT THEIR CROPS AND THEIR
INVESTMENT.
I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS PAT FITZ MORRISON
WITH CALIFORNIA DEAR ASSOCIATION
AND WE I REPRESENT EIGHT
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF DEER HUNTERS
IN THE AND THE.
AND THE STATE ALL OF WHICH ARE
CONCERNED WITH CONSERVATION AND
GIVE BACK THROUGH HABITAT
PROJECTS OUR PRIMARY MISSION. IS
TO HELP WILDLIFE THROUGH
PROJECTS WE WORK ALL OVER THE
STATE AND SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT
OF THE MONIES THAT WE REYES GOES
TO HABITAT PROJECTS THAT HELP
WILDLIFE.
I WE WORK WITH CALIFORNIA
SPORTFISHING WILDLIFE.
US FOR SERVICE US BUREAU OF LAND
MANAGEMENT OTHER AGENCIES AS A
RESTORATION PARTNER.
ARM OVER THE YEARS HUNDREDS OF
MADE ENORMOUS CONTRIBUTIONS.
TO THE CONSERVATION WILDLIFE IN
CALIFORNIA.
.
THEY PROVIDE CRUCIAL FUNDS FOR
REFUGE.
AND WILDLIFE AREA ACQUISITION
AND MANAGEMENT AND RESTORATION
PROJECTS.
A FIFTY PERCENT OF THE.
CALIFORNIA PART OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE'S.
BUDGET COMES FROM THE SALE OF
LICENSES AND TAGS IN STAMPS.
THAT US SPORTSMAN IN THIS GREAT
STATE PROVIDE.
.
WE YEAH IN IN NINETEEN THIRTY
SEVEN CONGRESS PASSED THE
WILDLIFE EIGHT RESTORATION.
ACT OR THE PITTMAN ROBSON ACT.
SOME OF YOU KNOW ABOUT IT IT.
WAS A BILL THAT CREATED ELEVEN
PERCENT TAX AND HUNTING
EQUIPMENT.
SO THAT MEANS ANY TIME A HUNTER
GOES INTO A SPORTS AND WAREHOUSE
OR BASS PRO SHOPS BY THE HUNTING
BACKPACK OR A.
SOME BUT OCULAR ZERO BORROW
LEVIN PERCENT. OF.
IS TAXING GOES BACK TO A A
FEDERAL FUND BATON BACK IN
WASHINGTON. THOSE FOR THOSE
FUNDS ARE DISTRIBUTED BACK TO
THE STATES
IN THE FORM OF GRANTS.
THAT.
GO DIRECTLY TO HABITAT PROJECTS
IN THE STATE'S UP IN THE
STATE'S.
SO BETWEEN FORTY FIVE AND FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS COMES BACK
CALIFORNIA.
AND IT'S ALL GENERATED BY BY
HUNTERS.
SO.
.
HAS BUILT STATED NEXT SUMMER ALL
SPECIES OF GAME IN THE STATE.
.
WILL BE OUT.
HUNTED WITH NON LEAD AMMUNITION
SO THAT'LL BE THE LAW. AND.
THERE IS THE LAW AND IT WILL BE
IN FULL EFFECT NEXT SUMMER.
SO.
.
MOST DEER HUNTERS ONLY HAVE ONE
OR TWO RIFLES.
IF THE IF AMMO IS NOT AVAILABLE
THEY'RE SIMPLY NOT. NOT GOING TO
PARTICIPATE.
AND THE WHICH RESULT IN LOST
REVENUES FOR THE DEPARTMENT FISH
WILDLIFE HABITAT PROJECTS.
AND.
AND WE WOULD.
RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT THIS.
BILLY PASSED THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
AND THEN MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE MARK KELLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATERFOWL WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL PROVIDES MUCH NEEDED
FLEXIBILITY FOR CALIFORNIA
HHONORS INAPPROPRIATELY LEAVES
THE DECISION WITH THE FISHING
GAME COMMISSION SO WE. ASK YOU
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
KEVIN VELLA CALIFORNIA NEVADA
DISTRICT BIOLOGIST THE NATIONAL
WILD TURKEY FEDERATION STRONG
SUPPORT.
EJ'S CEMETERY ROCKY MOUNTAIN ELK
FOUNDATION WE.
LOOK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
LARA JACOBS PRESIDENT OF
CALIFORNIA ANNOUNCEMENT FOR
CONSERVATION AND AS A CO SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ABOUT CREAMERS
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
MORNING JUST AN OLD FIELD WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES ARE TESTIFYING
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
IS COME FORWARD
.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
AND IT'S ONE OF THAT WE DON'T
KNOW.
WITHOUT ABOUT CALIFORNIA. OTHER
AS THE SCHOOLS CO SPONSOR FOR
SPEAKER RENDON'S AB SEVEN ELEVEN
A BILL THAT REQUIRED TO PHASE
OUT.
TOP TOXIC LEAD FROM AMMUNITION
TO SHOOT WILDLIFE IT CALIFORNIA
WHERE HEARINGS IN STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTY ONE
SEVENTEEN. EVERYONE THIRTY ONE
SEVENTEEN.
WE STRONGLY AND SINCERELY
THAT ATTEMPTS TO ADDRESS A
PROBLEM THAT HAS NOT YET BEEN
MATERIALIZED.
IF WE ALLOW THE STATE TO FALTER
AMMUNITION MANUFACTURES WILL NOT
FEEL THE NECESSITY WORRY THE
INCENTIVE TO MAKE THE
INVESTMENTS NECESSARY IN NON
TOXIC.
TOXIC
HUNTING AMMUNITION.
WHEN WE KNOW ALL WE KNOW A FEW
THINGS ABOUT LED.
LEAD IS A TOXIC TOXIN THAT IS
BAD FOR HUMAN HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT AND LEAD AMMUNITION
EXPOSES HUMANS TO OTHER ANIMALS.
AND OTHER ANIMALS TO THIS LIFE
THREATENING POISON.
LIKE MERCURY AND ARSENIC LEAD IS
UNKNOWN TOXIN THAT HAS BEEN
OUTLAWED IN REMOVED FROM PAIN
CASTLE ARE GASOLINE PIPELINES.
OF CHILDREN'S TOYS AND MANY
OTHER PRODUCTS TO PROTECT HUMAN
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT.
THE CENTER FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND LEAD LEADING SCIENTISTS FROM
AROUND THE COUNTRY AGREE THAT
THERE IS NO SAFE LEVEL OF LEAD
EXPOSURE. FOR HUMANS
LET.
BAIT BASE PAY A SEES ME LEAD
BASED AMMUNITION IS ONE OF THE
GREATEST SOURCES OF LEAD
DISCHARGED TO OUR LANDS IN WATER
SCIENTISTS AGREE THAT THIS POSES
A SIGNIFICANT RISK TO HUMAN
HEALTH AND THE ENVIRONMENT
FURTHERMORE. WE KNOW THAT IN
CALIFORNIA PHASING OUT LEAD
AMMUNITION IS WORKING AND RE AT
REDUCING LEAD IN THE ENVIRONMENT
AND PROTECTING WILDLIFE AND
HUMAN HEALTH. THAT ADMONITION IS
KNOWN.
AND WELL DOCUMENTED YA IS A WELL
DOCUMENTED CRITICAL THREAT TO
ENDANGERED SPECIES LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA CONDOR.
ARE WHEN THE LEAD BAD PHASE OUT
BEGAN TO BE IMPLEMENTED.
THE CONDOR FACED NEAR EXTENSION
EXTINCTION.
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN FOR
EXAMPLE THERE WERE ONLY ABOUT
TWENTY SEVEN. CALIFORNIA
CALIFORNIA CONDORS LEFT A AND
THESE WERE HELD IN CAPTIVITY TO
FOSTER THE SPECIES TO RETURN TO
THE TO THE WHILE TODAY. A THERE
ARE MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTY THREE FLYING CONDORS
LIVING IN THE WILD IN ANOTHER
TWO HUNDRED PLUS INTACT
CAPTIVITY.
AND TWO THOUSAND SEVEN NOT LEAD
AMMUNITION WAS REQUIRED IN THE
CALIFORNIA CONDOR TOWARD TO
WORRY. IN AN ATTEMPT TO ABATE
THE CHRONIC LEAD POISONING A
FROM THIS CRITICAL ENDANGERED IN
ICONIC SPECIES.
THE BAND IN THE CONDUCT
TERRITORY WHICH SUCCESSFULLY AND
ARE WAS SUCCESSFUL IN DECREASING
OVERALL BLOOD LEVELS LED BLOOD
LEVELS ARE AND CASES OF TALKS
TALKS.
SO.
CITY. AND WILDLIFE ARE IT IS.
IT IT IT ONLY ARE. IN WE KNOW
THAT IT ONLY TAKES A TINY AMOUNT
OF LEAD ARE DEPLOYED IN ANIMALS
CAUSING IMMENSE SUFFERING BEFORE
KILLING THEM. ARE AND THAT THAT
IS WHY WE NEED TO ELIMINATE LAID
OUT LEAD AMMUNITION WE NEED. TO
LET THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE DO ITS JOB AND PROTECT
OUR WILDLIFE MORE THAN A HUNDRED
THIRTY SPECIES ARE AT RISK OF
POISONING BY.
SPENT LET AYE MUNITION ARE.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY JOB OR JUST
AS IMPORTANT AND WE MUST KEEP
DISCUSS SPEAKER RENDON THEY BE
SEVEN ELEVEN. IN PLACE AND NOT
ROLL BACK ANY PROVISION SIGNED
INTO LAW AND IS FOR THOSE
REASONS THAT WE STRONGLY OPPOSE.
AB THIRTY ONE SEVENTEEN AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NO VOTE.
I AM. I THINK IT'S STILL MORNING
GOOD GOOD MORNING MY NAME'S KIM
DELFINO AND I'M THE DIRECTOR
WITH DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE WE
WERE ALSO A SPONSOR OF THE BILL
AB SEVEN ELEVEN.
VIRGIN ARE A NO VOTE ON THIS
BILL THIS BILL LIKE.
WON SAID IS PREMATURE AND AND
REALLY IT'S FRANKLY UNNECESSARY
UP A COUPLE OF THINGS FIRST OF
ALL WHEN WE.
WHEN WE AGREED TO A FIVE YEAR
PHASE OUT OF AMMUNITION WE'VE
FRANKLY BELOW BELIEVE HAT THAT
WAS ACTUALLY GIVING THEM A LOT
OF TIME BECAUSE THERE WAS A TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN STUDY. THAT
SHOWED. THAT SPECIFICALLY IN
CALIFORNIA SEVENTY SEVEN PERCENT
OF A HUNDRED ELEVEN STORES
ALREADY WERE STOCKING NON LEAD
AMMUNITION AND THAT THE STATE
CONCLUDED THERE WERE NO
REASONABLE VARIES IN CALIFORNIA.
REGULATING THE USE OF NON LEAD
AMMUNITION ON ALL STATE
PREVALENCE BY TWENTY FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN BUT WITH THAT BEING
SAID.
WE BELIEVED THAT IN THE
INTERESTS OF WORKING WITH THE
BRIT THE HONEYED COMMUNITY WE
WOULD GIVE A LONGER PHASE OUT.
ALLOW THE COMMISSION TO WORK
THROUGH IT AND THE COMMISSION
HAS BEEN ENGAGED IN A VERY
DETAILED AND EXTENSIVE PROCESS.
WHERE THEY HAVE ACTUALLY PUSHED
OUT THE MAJORITY OF THE LEAD TO
PHASE OUT TO JULY TWENTY
NINETEEN?
WE NEED TO HAVE A FIXED DATE FOR
PHASE OUT AND IT WAS IMPORTANT
BACK IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE WHEN
THE FISH AND WILDLIFE SERVICE
WAS PHASING OUT THE USE OF SHOT
FOR A WATER MIGRATORY WATERFOWL.
IT IS IMPORTANT NOW BECAUSE YOU
NEED TO DRIVE YOU NEED CERTAINTY
TO DRIVE MARKET DEMAND.
CREATING UNCERTAINTY BY CREATING
A PROCESS THAT THIS BILL CREATES
THAT WOULD ALLOW DIFFERENT
CALIBERS TO TO POTENTIALLYPAID
OUT AT RANDOM TIMES WHEN WE
DON'T EVEN KNOW WHICH CALPERS
THEY MIGHT BE.
CREATE A MOVING TARGET.
AND AND FRANKLY IT'S UNFAIR TO
THOSE WHO'VE ALREADY RESPONSIBLY
ANTICIPATED AND RESPONDED TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION SCHEDULE AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY ALLOWS FOR CONTINUE
TO LEASE OF TOXIC LEAD
AMMUNITION ENVIRONMENT.
FURTHER IF THE AVAILABILITY OF
NON LIVE AMMUNITION WAS TRULY A
PROBLEM FOR HUNTING THEN WHY WAS
IT REPORTED JUST LAST WEEK IN
THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NATIONAL WILD PICKING USDA TASK
FORCE MEETING. THAT USDA
WILDLIFE SERVICES
WHICH IS THE FEDERAL ENTITY IN
CHARGE OF.
KILLING A AT NUISANCE ANIMALS
AND ALL DIFFERENT KINDS.
SO THEY'LL BE USING ALL
DIFFERENT KINDS OF AMMUNITION BY
THE WAY WHY WAS IT REPORTED THAT
THEY ARE GOING TO CONVERT TO ALL
NON LEADING AMMUNITION IN THEIR
FIELD SERVICES. A BECOME THE
NUMBER ONE CONSUMER OF NON LEAD
AMMUNITION.
WHILE IT SERVICES KILLED FOREIGN
HALF MILLION ANIMALS A YEAR.
SO FRANKLY THAT'S A HECK OF A
MARKET MOVER AND I THINK WE'LL
BE PUSHING THE MARKET EVEN
FURTHER. FINALLY WITH RESPECT S.
B. TWELVE THIRTY FIVE.
THE ISSUE ABOUT ACE AB SEVEN
ELEVEN WHAT SPECIFICALLY
CONSIDERED WHEN AT SB TWELVE
THIRTY FIVE WAS GOING FORWARD
AND IN FACT ON IN THE PENAL CODE
SECTION THREE OH THREE FOUR FIVE
P.. THERE'S A NUMBER OF
EXEMPTIONS THAT WERE PUT IN
PLACE FOR COMMERCIAL HUNTING
CLUBS DOMESTIC GAME BIRD HUNTING
CLUBS DOMESTICATED MIGRATORY
BIRD SHOOTING CLUBS AND
NONPROFIT MUTUAL IN PUBLIC
BENEFIT CORPORATIONS ORGANIZE
PURSUIT OF CORPORATION CODES AND
ENGAGES IN RECREATIONAL SHOOTING
UNLAWFUL HUNTING ACTIVITY.
SO.
AND THEN FINALLY YOU KNOW THE.
.
S. B. TWELVE THIRTY FIVES A
REQUIREMENT OF NOW HAVING
FEDERAL OF HAVING CALIFORNIA
LICENSED.
AMMUNITION OF.
SELLERS IS MOVING FORWARD.
WALMART DICK'S SPORTING GOODS
BASS PRO SHOPS THEY'RE ALL
SELLING AT NON LEAD AMMUNITION.
BOB AND THAT WITH RESPECT TO
ONLINE SALES ON YOU CAN BY THE
NON LET AMMUNITION ONLINE.
IT DOES HAVE TO BE DELIVERED TO
A FEDERALLY LICENSED.
OF WHAT IT WHAT'S THE RIGHT
WORD A A FEDERAL FIREARMS
LICENSED OF ENTITY. HOWEVER IN
PERUSING THROUGH WEBSITES ON
ONLINE AMMO SALES ARE UP AND
RUNNING FROM CROSS ARMORY THINK
THEY CITED SOMEONE IN THIS WAS
FROM.
JANUARY TWENTY EIGHTEEN SAYING
THAT AT THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
GLOBAL. GUN OWNERS REPORTS
THERE'S LEAPS ONE OUTFIT RUNNING
A GREAT OPERATION RIFLE SHOT IN
DEFENSE OF HANDGUN AMMUNITION
PURCHASES FROM BULK AMMO. HAVE
SHOWN UP TO BE AN EASY PROCESS
TO ORDER ONLINE THE A LARGE
SELECTION AVAILABLE ONLINE AND
ORDERING IS EASY THE AMMUNITION
SHOWS UP IN ABOUT A WEEK.
SO I ACTUALLY DON'T THINK THAT.
THIS IS REALLY THE THE PROBLEM
THAT THEY'RE OF PUTTING FORWARD
AS AND ALSO I THINK THAT IF YOU
ALLOW THE.
A PROCESS OF.
SETTING UP THIS EXEMPTION YOU
WILL BE CUTTING OUT THE HEART OF
AB SEVEN ELEVEN AND.
FURTHER DELAYING WHAT IS REALLY
WITH THE INTENT WHEN SPEAKER
RENDON PUT THIS BILL TOGETHER
AND THAT IS TWO AND A VERY
TOXIC.
A AND A CONTAMINANT FROM GOING
INTO OUR ENVIRONMENT AND SETTING
UP A VERY REASONABLE PROCESS TO
BE ABLE TO DO THAT PHASE OUT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR THOSE WISHING TO
ADD ON IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
BOB GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS RECALL MUSTERED
ANOTHER WITH THE TRUST FOR
PUBLIC LAND FIVE YEARS SEEMS
LIKE AMPLE TIME TO TRANSITION TO
A NEW AMMUNITION.
AND WE DO NOT NEED MORE POISON
IN THE ENVIRONMENT.
NEW HOUSE.
THEY BRING IT BACK AND QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
KALRA.
THANK YOU SHARON AND I THINK
MISS MATHIS BRING THIS FORWARD.
THE.
.
A LOT OF REFERENCE BOTH IN THE
COMMITTEE REPORT AND THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT AB SEVEN
ELEVEN AND ITS INTENT. OF AND
DID YOU REACH OUT TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE SPEAKER.
ABOUT A. B. SEVERAL OF AND ABOUT
THIS BILL AS A RELEASED AB SEVEN
IT'S A IN KNOW IT IT IT'S THE
SPEAKERS BILL AND OBVIOUSLY YOU
LIKE AND WANT TO DO ANYTHING
THAT'S GOING TO ASCERTAIN OR
CHANGE THAT THAT THAT IS NOT THE
INTENT OF THIS LEGISLATION. ALL
ARE SIMPLY TRYING TO DO IS
ALLOW.
THE FISH AND GAME COMMISSION
THE ABILITY FOR THEM TO ACTUALLY
DO THEIR JOBS.
.
SO I ME AND WITH THAT A I'D LOVE
FURTHER DISCUSSION WITH THE
SPEAKER AND WITH ANYBODY WILLING
TO MOVE FORWARD. UMBER JUST
SIMPLY TRYING TO ALLOW THEM THE
ABILITY.
TO MANAGE THE FISH AND GAME IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND I'M
PRETTY SURE NOT ONE OF THOSE
COMMISSIONERS APPOINTED BY THE
GOVERNOR. I'LL IS OUT THERE
TRIED AT PUT TOXICS INTO THE
ENVIRONMENT
JUST A SIMPLE PRECAUTION. ARMED.
A YOU KNOW QUITE FRANKLY YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THE THE CURRENT
OPPOSITION IS TALK ABOUT YOU
KNOW THE. BALL THERE'S A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD THAT WAS ALSO BEFORE
THE TERRACE.
THAT ARE GOING ON WITH STILL
AND.
ALUMINUM THAT ARE HAPPENING IN
THAT THOSE ARE MARKET MEASURES
THAT WERE NOT ABLE TO ADDRESS
THE IMPACTS OF WHAT THAT'S GONNA
LOOK LIKE OVER THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS AS WELL. ON SO THAT MIGHT
HAVE A HIGH HIGH IMPACT ON OTHER
AMMUNITIONS.
NOTCHED IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA
BUT ACROSS THE NATION. AS WELL
THIS IS JUST SIMPLY A SCHOOL.
FOR.
THE COMMISSION.
AND AND QUITE FRANKLY I THINK
THE COMMISSION WOULD NO BASS ON
WHAT TO DO WITH THE STATE.
I'M THIS IS JUST A SIMPLE TOOL
FOR THEM TO USE JUST IN CASE WE
HIT A POINT.
IT'S NOT MANDATING IS NOT
CHANGING THAT IT IS GIVING THE
GOVERNOR APPOINTED COMMISSION.
THE ABILITY TO DO THEIR JOBS.
UP THANK YOU I I BELIEVE THOSE
WHO IS MENTIONED THAT THE.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
WILDLIFE SERVICES DEPARTMENTS
ALREADY CONVERTED TO ALL NON
LEAD AND I THINK THAT.
I'M.
FOR THAT THEY ARE THE NUMBER ONE
CONSUMER OF NON LET I I'D. I'D
ATTENDED AN EMPRESS ACT YEAH
THAT'S FOR COMMON CALIBERS
GET YOU HAVE MUCH FOR COMING UP
I'LL GIVE AWE. AYE AYE. BUT
WOULD.
A BUT I AM I'M NOT CUT WAS BORN
THIS BILL RIGHT NOW BUT I'D OF
RESPECT WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
EXACTLY UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE IMPACTS. THAT DO OCCUR THAT
SOMETIMES UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES APPEAL MUCH MORE
COMFORTABLE IF THE AUTHOR OF THE
ORIGINAL BILL HAD COME FORWARD
OR WORKED IN COLLABORATION WITH
YOU. AS TO WHAT THE INTENT WAS
BY DIGGING A FIVE YEAR LEAD IN
WAS INTENTIONAL JUST FOR THAT
PURPOSE OF ALLOWING THE MARKET
AND. ALLOWING.
THOSE THAT USE THE PRODUCTS TO
ADJUST BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MANY OF QUESTIONS COMETS.
SHELTER.
HOW JUST GONNA SAY VERY QUICKLY
AND?
NO THE ORIGINAL LEGISLATION DID
ACTUALLY TASK.
A IT WAS A COMMISSIONER THE
DIRECTOR WITH LOOKING INTO THIS
AND IF THERE WEREN'T AVAILABLE
ALTERNATIVES THAT HE WOULD HAVE
A PROCESS. THEY WOULD DO THAT
NOW.
IN THIS BILL DOESN'T CHANGE
THAT IT WHAT IT DOES IS IT PUTS
IT IN THE HANDS OF THE
COMMISSION THE SAY LET THEM
THEIR.
THERE ARE CALIBERS OUT THERE
WHERE THERE AREN'T SUFFICIENT
ALTERNATIVES AVAILABLE YET SO.
AND I THINK ITS IN AND IT IS A.
IN LINE WITH THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION.
AND I JUST PASS THEM TO DO THIS
YOU KNOW PRIOR TO CERTAIN DAY
BECAUSE THERE ARE CONSUMERS OUT
THERE THAT THEY THEY'RE NOT
GONNA HAVE.
NEO NAM LET ALTERNATIVES
AVAILABLE TO THEM AND THEY AND
THEY STILL WANT TO. KNOW HUNTON
AND AND GO ABOUT.
THAT RECREATIONAL ACTIVITY JUST
LIKE ANYBODY ELSE WOULD SO I I I
I WOULD ASK THAT WE CONSIDER
THIS IN AND PUSH IT THROUGH. I'M
IN AND IT WOULDN'T BE. YOU KNOW.
I DON'T THINK THAT IT IS THE IT
DOESN'T INHIBIT THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
YOU DO HAVE A MOTION SECOND.
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE A NO
RECOMMENDATION
AND DOM AND I'LL SHARE WITH YOU
THAT ALTHOUGH.
IT'S BEEN MENTIONED THAT YOU
KNOW MORE WORK.
WITH THE ORIGINAL AUTHOR IS ONE
OF THE. COMPONENTS TO.
AND YOU KNOW A RECOMMENDATION.
IDEA RECENTLY RECEIVED OF THE.
STUDY THAT CAME BACK. THAT
IDENTIFIED THAT THERE WERE ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY THREE
SCHOOLS.
DOT THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THAT.
HEAD OUT A LEVEL ABOVE AND
BEYOND.
ACCEPTABLE WAIT.
OF LEAD AND ALTHOUGH WE MAY BE
TALKING ABOUT APPLES AND ORANGES
THE JUSTICE OF THE FACT THAT.
YOU KNOW WE'VE GOT THE CHILDREN
THAT ARE BEING IMPACTED BY THIS
IS OF GREAT CONCERN TO ME.
I I WOULD ASK THAT THAT YOU KNOW
THEIR BE FURTHER CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE ORIGINAL AUTHOR THE
BILL I CONTINUE TO BE OPEN TO.
SEEN SOME TYPE OF COLLABORATIVE
YOU KNOW APPROACH TO THIS. AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT TIME YOU KNOW WE
CAN HAVE THIS CONVERSATION.
AGAIN BUT AT THIS TIME WE
RECOMMEND YOU KNOW AND THE.
.
THAT'S THE STAFF. RECOMMENDATION
AS WELL SO.
MEG CLOSE PLEASE.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS
TOMORROW THE OPPOSITION.
IN IN RELATION TO THE
CALIFORNIA CONDOR ON THIS BILL
WOULD NOT CHANGE THE BAN ON
THOSE AREAS AT ALL. ARMS OF THIS
COMMENTER.
NOT GERMANE TO THIS LEGISLATION.
THAT AGAIN I'D LIKE TO STRESS
THE UNKNOWN MARKET WITH THE
CURRENT TEAR SITUATION.
.
IT AND ALSO I MEAN.
AB.
THREE ELEVEN SEVEN AS A MEASURE
WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE LAW
ABIDING HUNTERS.
ARE NOT PRECLUDED FROM LEGALLY
TAKING WILDLIFE AND DEPRAVATION.
AND OTHER PURPOSES.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED AB
SEVERAL OF IN MAKING CALIFORNIA
THE ONLY STATE REQUIRED TO USE
NON LEAD AMMUNITION.
FOR TAKING ALL OF WILDLIFE.
WITH A FIRE.
THE ELDER READ THROUGH THE AGES
FOR AYE I THINK SOME OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NEED THE.
TO KNOW THE FULL BACKGROUND.
WITH THE SUBSEQUENT PASSAGE OF
S. B..
TWELVE THIRTY FIVE IN
PROPOSITION SIXTY THREE AND
TWENTY SIXTEEN.
AS OF JANUARY FIRST OF THIS YEAR
HUNTERS ARE NOT ABLE TO PURCHASE
AMMUNITION OUT OF THE STATE. AND
BRING IT BACK INTO.
CALIFORNIA IS IMPORTANT TO KNOW.
NOR WILL THEY BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE AMMUNITION ONLINE OR
BY.
ANY MEANS UNLESS THEY GO THROUGH
AN AUTHORIZED RETAILER.
THE PROCESS IS ALSO VERY COSTLY.
CURRENTLY SOME CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS HAVE LIMITED SUPPLY OF
NON LEAD AMMUNITION.
AND COMMON CALIBERS.
HOWEVER ONCE NOT LEAD AMMUNITION
IS FULLY REQUIRED FOR THE
TAKING.
OF ALL WILDLIFE IN CALIFORNIA ON
JULY.
TWENTY NINETEEN NEXT YEAR DEMAND
WILL FAR EXCEED THE SUPPLY OF
MONEY CALIBERS.
AB
THREE ELEVEN SEVEN.
WHAT ADDRESS THIS SERIOUS
CONCERN BY ALLOWING?
THE FISH AND GAME COMMISSIONER
TO TEMPORARILY SUSPEND THIS IS
ONLY A TEMPORARY SUSPENSION.
BY.
GOVERNOR APPOINTED OR.
TO SUSPEND THE PROHIBITION OF
THE USE OF LEAD AMMUNITION FOR
THOSE CALIBERS THAT MAY BE
REASONABLE A.
UNAVAILABLE TO CALIFORNIA'S
PUBLIC.
AGAIN MEMBERS LET ME BE CLEAR.
WITH THIS MEASURE WE ARE NOT
TRYING TO UNDO.
BAKER RENDON'S A. B. SEVEN
ELEVEN.
RATHER WE WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT.
SOLUTION.
THESE THREE PREVIOUS MEASURES
HAVE PLACED WITHIN THE HUNTING
AND RANCHING AND FARMING
COMMUNITIES.
ACROSS RURAL CALIFORNIA.
JUST RECENTLY WE PASS
LEGISLATION THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE. ADDRESSING WHILE
PICKS.
ANOTHER PROBLEM WHAT DO YOU DO
WHEN YOU RUN OUT OF AMMUNITION
FOR HUNTING.
THIS IS A SEVERE PROBLEM.
THE AN ABILITY TO PURCHASE
PARTICULAR LOADS WILL RESULT IN
DEPRAVATION.
AND WILL HINDER HUNTERS FROM
SEEKING TO APPLY.
AND FILL TAX
THIS IS ANOTHER PROBLEM A LOT OF
THE STATE BUDGET FOR FISHING
GAME COMES FROM THE CELL OF TAX.
IF MONSTER OUT HUNDREDS ARE VERY
SIMPLE GUYS.
THE IF YOU DON'T HAVE THE AMMO
YOU'RE NOT GONNA HUNT.
WHICH MEANS YOU'RE NOT GONNA BY
THE TASK
WHICH WAS THE STATE'S NOT GOING
TO GET THE MONEY THAT I CAN GO
TO ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS. WHICH
THE OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL
REPRESENTS A IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY
SENSE.
AGAIN WE'RE NOT SEEKING TO UNDO
THE BAN.
AS THE THREE YEAR SUNSET ON A.
B..
THREE ELEVEN SEVEN.
WE SIMPLY WANT TO GIVE THE
COMMISSION THE AUTHORITY TO
ENACT A TEMPORARY SUSPENSION
SHOULD PARTICULATE CALIBERS.
BE SEVERELY.
UNAVAILABLE.
AGAIN MEMBERS.
WE'RE NOT TRYING TO DO.
FIGURES DON WE'RE SIMPLY VERY
VERY SIMPLY. TRIED TO MAKE SURE
THE GOVERNOR'S.
FISH AND GAME BOARD HAS THE
ABILITY.
TO ADDRESS ISSUES THAT MAY COME
UP WITH UNKNOWN FUTURE
PROJECTIONS WITH THE TERRACE
WITH EVERYTHING ELSE GOING ON.
I ASK YOU FOR YOUR AYE THOSE.
THANK YOU THE THERE'S A MOTION A
SECOND BY MISTER BIGELOW AND
MISTER GALLAGHER.
KERRIGAN NATION IS NOW.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA. GARCIA NO.
GALLAGHER BY GALLAGHER AYE.
BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI. CHOI AYE CHU.
FRIEDMAN. GLORIA.
HARPER BUT I HARPER AYE KALRA.
KALRA NO. LEVINE.
THE VINO. MATHIS BY.
SIGH RUBIO.
RUBIO NO SOLACE.
WOULD.
WOULD KNOW.
THE ONLY BE YEAH COLOR.
IF IT DOESN'T PASS MASTERY
CONSIDERATIONS OF CAN CONTINUE
THE DISCUSSION WITH THE SPEAKER
SO I I I BELIEVE BECAUSE THIS IS
THE LAST HEARING. THAT WE WE MAY
NOT. BE.
IN A POSITION TO DO THAT BUT LET
ME CHECK WITH.
THE ACTUAL TECHNICAL.
YEAH IT'S I THINK. IT'S THE LAST
HEARING.
LAST POLICY HEARING.
WHO? LET'S KEEP THAT LET'S KEEP
THAT THE ROLE OF AN. IN THEM
THANK YOU MISTER.
WHICH SOME
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
WILL MOVE ON TO A LIGHTER
SUBJECT.
AND THAT'S
MONARCHS IN CALIFORNIA.
AS IT HAD A LONG MORNING I
GUESS.
SO IN THE EIGHTIES WE HAD
PROBABLY TEN MILLION. OR SO
THANK YOU MOTION AND MONARCHS
ACROSS THE THE STATE CURRENT
ESTIMATES AROUND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND IN PART OF THE
PROBLEM.
IS THEY.
THE HABITAT OF THE MONARCHS NEED
TO TO BREED AND A LOT OF IT'S IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IN A LOT OF
IT HAS BEEN SUBJECTED TO
AGRICULTURAL AND OTHER. TYPES OF
USES BUT THERE'S AT THERE'S A
CHANCE TO BE ABLE TO RECOVER A
LOT OF THIS HABITAT. INTO THIS
PROGRAM WOULD DO WOULD BE TO PUT
SOME MONEY TO WORK WITH
LANDOWNERS THROUGHOUT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. TO FACILITATE.
MONARCH HABITAT.
THIS IS CALLED THE.
MONARCH AND POLLINATOR RESCUE
PROGRAM HOW TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT THERE'S BEEN SOME CONFUSION
MONARCHS ARE NOT GREAT
POLLINATORS BUT IT DOES TURN OUT
THAT THE HABITAT THAT THEY USE
DOES.
FACILITATE THEY A NUMBER OF
SPECIES THAT ARE IN FACT
POLLINATORS.
THESE ARE ICONIC SPECIES THE
MONARCHS ALONG THE CENTRAL COAST
WHERE THEY COLLECT IN CYPRUS AND
THEY COLLECTED PINES THEY ALSO
COLLECT IN THE. THE NON NATIVE
EUCALYPTUS TREES THAT ARE
THROUGHOUT MY DISTRICT BUT
BECAUSE WE'RE SEEING SUCH
SUCH DECLINES IN POPULATIONS I
THINK IT'S VERY WORTH CREATING A
PROGRAM PUTTING SOME MONEY
THROUGH THE.
WHAT WILDLIFE CONSERVATION BOARD
TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN WORK WITH
LANDOWNERS IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY
IT'S NOT A MANDATORY PROGRAM BUT
THOSE WHO ARE WILLING? TO TAKE
THE MONEY TO WORK ON. RESTORING
AND MANAGING HABITS AT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WITH THAT I ASK
FOR YOUR EITHER THINK YOU DO
HAVE A MOTION A SECOND THAT
PLEASE PROCEED.
MORE INITIATIVE CHAIRMAN
CARCILLO VICE CHAIRMAN GALLAGHER
MY NAME IS ERIC HOLST.
ON THE BALLOT JUST AN ASSOCIATE
VICE PRESIDENT FOR WORKING LANDS
WITH ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND
BASED IN SACRAMENTO.
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF FOOD
NAG.
I'M HERE DOING TODAY TO
ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
TWENTY FOUR. TWENTY ONE THE A
MONARCH BUTTERFLY IMPONER RESCUE
PROGRAM.
.
IT IT'S IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE
THE TERM RESCUE MARKER ONCE ONE
OF THE MOST RECOGNIZABLE AND
UBIQUITOUS.
WILDLIFE SPECIES IN OUR STATE.
THEY'RE FAMILIAR TO RESIDENTS OF
THE CENTRAL COAST WHERE THEY
SPEND THE WINTER. IN THE SPRING
THEY FAN OUT FROM THE COAST AND
READ IN FEE THROUGHOUT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. FOOTHILLS IN
THIS YEAR NEVADA.
BUT AS OUR BREEDING HABITAT IS
DECLINE THE NUMBERS FOR THE
WESTERN POPULATION HAVE DECLINED
AS WELL.
THE P. PEAK POPULATION WAS
MEASURED IN THE MILLIONS AND AS.
MR STONE MENTION THIS WINTER
THEY.
THEY'RE DOWN TO TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND WHICH IS ACTUALLY
DECLINE OF THIRTY PERCENT FROM
LAST YEAR.
A IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
THE WESTERN POPULATION IS
DISTINCT FROM THE PERHAPS MORE
FAMOUS BUT EQUALLY IMPERILED
EASTERN POPULATION.
THAT OVER WINTERS IN THE
MOUNTAINS OF CENTRAL MEXICO.
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT MARK CAN
RECOVER.
THE CONCERTED EFFORT TO RESTORE
THEIR BREEDING AND FEEDING
HABITAT THE CENTRAL VALLEY
FOOTHILLS CAN MAKE A BIG
DIFFERENCE.
THIS HABITAT CONSISTED OF A PRO
INAPPROPRIATE BLEND OF WILD
FLOWERS FLOWERING SHRUBS.
GRASSES AND MILKWEED.
MILK WEED IS THE KEY FOR MARK
BECAUSE IT LAYS ES ITS EGGS
EXCLUSIVELY ON THIS.
YOU NEED PLAN AND HERE'S THE
KICKER.
ALSO AS A.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER STAR MENTION THIS
HAVE SAME HABITAT IS HOME TO.
CALIFORNIA'S MOST ECONOMICALLY
VALUABLE CLASS OF WILDLIFE
NATIVE BEES AND OTHER
POLLINATORS CRITICAL
CONTRIBUTORS.
TO CALIFORNIA'S NEARLY NEARLY
FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY.
NATIVE BEES AND OTHER PARTNERS
ARE SIMILARLY EXPERIENCING
TROUBLING DECLINES PARTICULARLY
IN AGRICULTURAL LANDSCAPES WHERE
THEY PROVIDE THE MOST BENEFIT.
IN CALIFORNIA SOME OF OUR MOST
IMPORTANT CROPS INCLUDING ALMOND
STRAWBERRIES APPLES AVOCADOS
KIWIS AND OTHERS DEPEND ON BEE
POLLINATION.
AND FINALLY AS WE MENTIONED
BECAUSE OF THEIR DECLINE THE
MONARCH AND A HANDFUL OF OTHER
POLLINATORS ARE CANDIDATES FOR
LISTING ON THE FEDERAL
ENDANGERED SPECIES LIST.
A STRONG EFFORT TO STIMULATE
VOLUNTARY HABITAT ENHANCEMENT.
WHO CONTRIBUTE GREATLY TO
AVOIDING LISTING?
AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS THAT WOULD
GO ALONG WITH OUR THE ECONOMIC
COSTS THAT WOULD GO ALONG WITH
THAT LISTINGS OF THANK YOU AND I
ARE JR. SIMPLE YOU AND THOSE
WISHING TO LIVE ON THE RECORD
SUPPORTING THE MEASURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR A
RECALL MUST WRITTEN ON IT WITH
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT GETTING MY
LETTER OF SUPPORT AND ON TIME
BUT THIS IS A GREAT BILL.
DRIVE OF.
BECAUSE AS A SECOND CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
COULD NOT BE DONE WITHOUT A ONE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
NO KRAMERS CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION WE DON'T HAVE
AN OFFICIAL POSITION BUT I WE
ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THIS CONCEPT
AND REALLY APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR
WORKING WITH US. I'M ON WAYS TO
MAKE SURE THAT THIS BILL WILL BE
WORKABLE FOR OUR MEMBERS WHO
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT CONSERVATION
OF THE MONARCH AND ARE WORKING
TO HELP IMPROVE CONSERVATION
EFFORTS.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELEANOR TEAS ON
BEHALF OF SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS AND BEGS
FOR LAND TRUST AND SUPPORT.
YOUR CHAIR MEMBERS LUCAS
FRERICHS ABOUT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT THANKS.
CAN DEVELOP KIM DELFINO WITH
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
TENNIS ALL A FOR THE ALLMAN
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
SEE NO ONE GOT ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO A CLOSE PASSED
HERE EITHER LOCATE DO PASS A
RECOMMENDATION. TO
APPROPRIATIONS AND THAT WAS
SOROKA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA I
SEE I GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO CHOI AYE
CHOI AYE CU.
FRIEDMAN. GLORIA I'VE GLORIA AYE
HARPER. HARPER NO KALRA.
FLORA AYE LEVINE. LEVINE AYE
MATHIS.
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE SOLACE.
I SOLIS I WOULD.
WOULD I.
THANK YOU SO WILL KEEP IT OPEN
FOR THE MEMBERS AT ON WILL HAVE
THOUGHT IT WOULD REPRESENTS TWO
BILLS AND THEN.
SUMMER KALRA.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
AS YOU KNOW MY DISTRICT IS HOME
TO SOME OF OUR STATES MOST
SPECTACULAR STATE NATIONAL PARKS
AS YOU ARE ALSO PROBABLY AWARE
THERE ARE A FEW CANNABIS PLANTS
GROWING IN THE SECONDS ASSEMBLY
DISTRICT.
JUST A FEW OF MY DISTRICT IS
HOME TO THE EMERALD TRIANGLE THE
HISTORICAL HEART OF THE NATION'S
CANNABIS INDUSTRY.
THE RUGGED REMOTE NATURAL NATURE
OF THIS REGION COMBINED WITH THE
AMPLE WATER SUPPLY MAKES THE
EMERALD TRIANGLE AN IDEAL PLACE
TO GROW CANNABIS UNDETECTED.
IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN WAS
ESTIMATED THE REGION PRODUCED
OVER SIXTY PERCENT OF THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY'S CANNABIS.
WHILE MAJORITY THESE CANVAS
FORMS ARE PRIVATE LANDOWNERS.
TRYING TO DO THE RIGHT THING
THAT IS NOT ALWAYS THE THE CASE.
THAT EVERY EVERY YEAR DOZENS OF
UNSUSPECTING HIKERS WEEKEND
WARRIORS LAWN FORSMAN OFFICERS
PARK PERSONNEL STUMBLE ACROSS A
TETE A TRESPASS GROWS ON PUBLIC
LAND.
THESE CRIMINAL OPERATIONS RAFEAL
ASSOCIATE WITH ORGANIZED CRIME
NOVELS AND AN ALMOST ALWAYS
HEAVILY ARMED.
THE SITUATIONS BECOME SO DIRE
THAT MOST FAMILIES IN MY
DISTRICT WILL NOT VENTURE OUT TO
THE PARKS DURING THE GROWING
SEASON WHICH SPANS FROM LATE
APRIL.
THROUGH SEPTEMBER.
THE SAME TIME PERIOD WHEN MOST
OF US WERE LOOKING TO GET
OUTSIDE AND UP INTO THE
MOUNTAINS.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE THE
TENTS AIMS TO TAKE BACK OUR
STATE PARKS.
THE BILL WOULD WOULD DIRECT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION TO COLLABORATE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO SURVEY THESE PUBLIC
LANDS. IDENTIFY TRESPASSING
GROWS AND COME UP WITH THE PLAN
PUT THESE GUYS OUT OF BUSINESS
AND CLEAN UP THE SITES.
IT IS TRUE THERE ARE MANY
TRESPASS GROWS ON PRIVATE LANDS
AND I AGREED THAT
ENVIRONMENTALLY MANY OF THESE
SITES ARE AS ARE AS IMPORTANT IF
NOT MORE IMPORTANT ECOLOGICALLY.
BILLS BILLS IS NOT STAINED STE
IS NOT AIMED AT STEERING GRANT
MONEY AWAY FROM CLEANUP PROJECTS
ON PRIVATE LANDS.
OVER PRIVATE LANDS HAVE A
LANDOWNER TO HELP IDENTIFY THESE
TRESPASS GROWS AN ADVOCATE FOR
THE CLEANUP.
OUR PRIVATE LANDS OF REQUIRE OUR
PUBLIC AGENCIES ARE PUBLICLY
YOUR PRIVATE.
BLAMES REQUIRE PUBLIC AGENCIES
TO IDENTIFY GROWS IN CREATIVE
PLAN TO GET THEM CLEANED UP
RIGHT AND RIGHT NOW THIS IS NOT
HAPPENING.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
ITS MAIN AS LIZ FORCED BURKE A
PATH FOR THE NATURE CONSERVANCY.
GREAT CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LIZ
FORSBERG I'M HERE AT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WHAT HAS CHAMPION
THE EFFORT TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT FROM ILLEGAL
CANNABIS CULTIVATION WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE HIS LEADERSHIP AND
ATTENTION TO THIS ISSUE.
AND TWO DOZEN FIFTEEN THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY PUBLISHED A STUDY IN
BIOSCIENCE THAT HIGHLIGHTED THE
IMPACTS OF ILLEGAL CANNABIS
CULTIVATION THE ENVIRONMENT.
ILLEGAL GROWERS OFTEN TOP SMALL
HEAD WATER STREAMS IN SUMMER
TAKING WATER EXACTLY ONE FIFTY
THAT THE MOST.
ILLEGAL CANNABIS FARMING IS ALSO
ASSOCIATED WITH I'M PERMITTED
FORCED CLEAR CUTTING AND ROAD
CONSTRUCTION WHICH CAN INCREASE
EROSION DESTROYED HABITAT AND
DAMAGE STREAMS.
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY IS
HELPING MAKE SURE THAT REVENUE
FROM PROP SIXTY FOUR IS
DEDICATED TO THE ENVIRONMENT TO
SPEND IS SPENT ON PREVENTING
IMPACTS AND CLEANING UP FROM
PAST DAMAGES FROM ILLEGAL
CANNABIS CANNABIS PRODUCTION.
WE SUPPORT AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
FIVE EFFORTS TO IDENTIFY AND
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL RESOURCES TO
DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE AND WE URGE
OUR AYE VOTE.
THOSE WISHING TO ADD ON SUPPORT.
MARIAN WARMER DOWN BROKE COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELEANOR TEAS ON
BEHALF OF SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE IN SUPPORT THINK YOU.
ONE OF THEM AGAIN WITHOUT MY
CALIFORNIA WOULDN'T GET A LOT OF
SUPPORT AND BUT WE STRONG
SUPPORT EUROPE EFFORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
OKAY SEE NO ONE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. BIGELOW.
TO THE AUTHOR ON.
SPECIFICALLY CAN YOU ADDRESS
HOW THIS.
BILL WILL IMPACT.
THE PRIVATE USES OF THE FUNDS
THAT HAVE BEEN COMING IN ON
PRIVATE LANDS.
OR THE PUBLIC FUNDS UTILIZED
FOR.
STOPPING THEIR AN AND A RATTY
KILLING THE ILLEGAL USE OF GROWS
ON PRIVATE LANDS.
THE FUNDS THAT YOU'RE GOING TO
USE CURRENTLY ARE OUTLINED AS
THOSE SAME FUND SO THE BE
COMPETING INTERESTS.
DO YOU BELIEVE.
OR WILL YOU.
CLARIFY SO THAT WE CAN MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE NOT HARMING ONE OVER
THE OTHER.
BY TED IS NOT TO HARM ONE OVER
THE OTHER MOM BUT I MY INTENT IS
TO FOCUS THAT ARE THE FOCUS OF
THIS BILL IS ON ON ON PUBLIC
LANDS.
OKAY SO.
MAYBE THROUGH THE CHAIR HOW CAN
WE DETERMINE.
SO THAT WE'RE NOT IMPACTING.
THOSE FUNDS ARE BEING
SUCCESSFULLY USED
FOR THE.
PRIVATE LANDOWNERS TODAY.
OVER THE OVER THE CANE THAT.
THE AUTHOR IS RIGHTFULLY ASKING.
TO BE ADDRESSED ITS A DIFFICULT
ISSUE. AND IT'S ALMOST LIKE AN
AUGMENTATION NEEDS TO OCCUR. IN
ORDER FOR IT TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
WITHOUT HARMING.
ANOTHER.
MAYBE YOU COULD ADDRESS THAT OR
MAYBE THE STAFF SOMEHOW.
SOUNDS LIKE THAT SUB.
APPROPRIATIONS ISSUE.
THAT THAT YOU'LL BE YET WORKING
ON I UNDERSTAND SUSPECT THIS IS
A PROBLEM ORGAN PREPARATIONS
ISSUE YES.
AND AND AND.
THROUGH THE CHAIR OF THESE
ANSWERS BIGELOW I'VE BEEN STRONG
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING AND
ADVOCATE FOR PROPER I'VE IT AND
PUBLIC LAND PROTECTION SO THIS
IS NOT NAY ANYWAY MEANT TO TAKE
FROM WANT TO STEAL FROM ONE. TO
GIVE TO ANOTHER IT'S JUST NOT
IT'S AN OPPORTUNIST EIGHT NO
LOOK WE NEED TO FOCUS HERE AND
AND AND WE'RE LOOKING FOR
SIGNIFICANT RESOURCES TO DO
THAT.
AT AS SOMEONE WHO WRECKED.
RECOGNIZES AND HAS A LOT OF.
LANDOWNERS WHO ARE IMPACTED NOW
WHERE THEY CAN'T SAFELY GO OUT
AND.
I DO THEIR COMMON DAY PRACTICES
FROM RANCHING TO.
TO JUST GOING OUT AND ENJOYING
THE LAND OUT OF FEAR. FROM
ILLEGAL GROVES THAT EXIST ON
THEIR PRIVATE LANDS.
THAT ARE SET UP WITH GROOVY
TRAPS PEOPLE WITH GUNS GUNS THAT
ARE ILLEGAL.
WHILE DEFINITIONS IN THE STATE
TODAY.
ARM.
I JUST WOULD HATE TO SEE THE
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAMS.
FOR THOSE PEOPLE WHO WERE TRYING
TO.
PROTECTING A RADICALLY THESE
ILLEGAL ACTIVITIES ON THE
PRIVATE PLANS BE IMPACTED.
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE WHERE THE
OTHER COMPONENT OF THIS IS THAT.
I'M WITH YOU HAVING ALSO.
ALSO BEING ONE OF THOSE WHO
REPRESENT A LARGE NUMBER OF ACRE
CENTER AND STATE PARKS LIKE
YOURSELF.
AND EMPOWER.
AND PUBLIC LANDS.
IT'S A REAL QUANDARY FOR BOTH OF
US RIGHT BECAUSE THIS DOES EXIST
AND WE'VE GOT A RADICALLY BOTH.
I THINK WHAT WHAT THAT DID
DISTINCTION I'M TRYING TO MAKE
HERE IS THAT.
THE PRIVATE LANDOWNER CAN.
KEEP AN EYE ON THEIR OWN LAND
THEY CAN MONITOR THEIR LAND
LOOKED AT MORE.
THEN.
THE PUBLIC LANDS WE NEED SOMEONE
TO ACTIVELY SURVEYED THE PUBLIC
LANDS TO SEE WHAT'S GOING ON OUT
THERE. BECAUSE THEY'RE PUBLIC
LANDS AND THEY AND THEIR OWN BY
GOVERNMENT. BUT WE DON'T HAVE
YOU KNOW AT LIKE IT'S AT YOUR
PRIVATE LANDOWNER CAN. SURVEY
THEIR OWN PUBLIC THEIR PRIVATE
LAND AND THEY CAN YOU KNOW.
MAKE REPORTS IN THE CAN BEFORE
THAT BUT THERE'S NO ONE
CURRENTLY TO AT THERE'S NO
MECHANISM. TO MAKE SURE WE
SURVEYED THE THE PUBLIC LANDS
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M AFTER. OKAY
SO MAYBE THAT THE COMPROMISE
HERE IS MAYBE THE COMMITTEE
COULD. ARE.
RECOGNIZE THAT THIS CONFLICT
DOES POTENTIALLY EXIST.
I END THAT WE COULD RECOMMEND AS
AGO SO APPROPRIATIONS THAT THERE
BE. ARE A SERIOUS LOOK AT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO MAKE SURE
THAT. THERE ISN'T ANY HARM.
.
THE COMFORTING US OUT OF THE
LAST PERSON TO TURN AWAY AT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING. I UNDERSTAND
THAT BUT THE ONLY WAY TO GET
THERE IS TO CHANNEL IT HERE IN
POLICY TO HELP YOU RIGHT AND
THIS IS HOW IT HAS TO HAPPEN.
AND HAVE AND AND ON THE ODD DUCK
IN HERE TRYING TO MAKE THIS
HAPPEN.
BEING A GOOD CONSERVATIVE BUT
I'M ALSO SOMEBODY WHO'S A
PREGNANT. THAT WANTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE RIGHT THING IS
DONE.
* THAT
HAPPY TO WORK WITH YOU OKAY SO
MISTER CHAIR WOULD WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO WORK AND HELP.
YES SIR THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
PROJECT CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND WE DO HAVE A DO PASS.
RECOMMENDATION TO APPROPRIATIONS
ADDICTS REGULAR REYES AND GOOD.
QUESTION IS IT PARA WE STERN
YOU'RE COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
WITH YOU ON ABSOLUTELY. AS WERE
BROKEN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER.
BIGELOW.
SUPPORTERS
BIGELOW AYE CARILLO.
CHOI. CHOI AYE CHU.
FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA. GLORIA AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO. KALRA. FLORA AYE
LEVINE.
LEVINE I MATHIS.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE SOLACE. SOLIS I WOULD
DIE WOULD I.
I THINK YOU WILL KEEP THAT OPEN
SECOND BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY SIX FORTY GIVES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
THE AUTHORITY TO AUTHORIZE THAT
TO
THE TAKER POSSESSION OF THE LOST
RIVER SUCKED SACRIFICIAL.
AND THE SHORT NO SECTOR FISH.
RESULTING FROM IMPACTS
ATTRIBUTABLE TO THE REMOVAL OF
THE KLAMATH DAMS.
BUSTER RECEPTORS ARE ONE OF THE
LARGEST SECTOR FISH IN THE WORLD
REACHING OVER THREE FEET IN
LENGTH.
THE THESE THESE FISH WERE ONCE A
BUN ABUNDANT IN THE UPPER
KLAMATH BASIN OF OREGON IN
CALIFORNIA AND A SIGNIFICANT
FOOD SOURCE FOR NATIVE PEOPLES.
UNFORTUNATELY DUE IN LARGE PART
TO HABITAT LOSS THE SUCKER
PITCHER NOW A FULLY PROTECTED
SPECIES UNDER STATE LAW.
THE SHORT NO SUCKER FISH IS MUCH
SMALLER SPECIES OF SACRIFICIAL
ONLY REACHING TWENTY INCHES IN
LENGTH BUT EASILY DISTINGUISHED
FROM THE BY THEIR LARGE HEADS
AND DEEPLY NOTS LOWER LIPS.
THE SUCKERS ARE NOW A FULLY ALSO
FULLY PROTECTED SO AS SPECIES.
THE BILL WOULD GIVE THE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WHILE THAT
THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO PROTECT
THESE TO ENDANGERED SPECIES A
SUCKER FISH. PROVIDE LEGAL
PROTECTIONS FOR THE PARTIES
INVOLVED IN THE AS THE CLIMATE
DAMS FOR OUR ARE REMOVED HERE TO
TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF TROUT
UNLIMITED IS MARK FENSTER MAKER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MARK
FRENCH MAKE ON BEHALF OF TROUT
UNLIMITED IN STRONG SUPPORT AYE
WE SUBMITTED A LETTER CO SIGNED
BY SEVERAL TRIBES FISHMAN GROUPS
AND OTHER CONSERVATION GROUPS
THAT SUPPORT THE FULL
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE KHSAA WE
SEE A BEAST TWENTY SIX FORTY AS
A SENSIBLE AND PRECAUTIONARY
MEASURE IMPLEMENTING THE KHSAA.
WHICH MAY HAVE IMPACTS ON THE
LOST RIVER SUCKER IN SHORT NO
SUCKER.
BUT THIS BILL IS NECESSARY DUE
TO THE FULLY PROTECTED STATUS OF
THAT TO FISH SPECIES AND AS THE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THERE IS
PRECEDENT FOR THIS TYPE OF
LEGISLATION.
WE THANK THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL ONE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT
ANYONE ELSE WISHING NEW. ADD ON
IN SUPPORT TO THE MEASURE.
TOM MCLAUGHLIN ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CHILD FUND IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE.
WE'VE SEEN NO ONE ANY QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
COMMENTS.
ALRIGHT.
AND WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
WE DON'T HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
OF THE.
OKAY YOU GOT A HAND FULL.
REJECT CLOSE.
SPEC WE ASK YOU AYE VOTE THANK
YOU SAYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION TO ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
EDUARDO GARCIA I.
SEE I TOLD HER.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO. CARILLO.
CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU.
TRUE I FRIEDMAN.
GLORIA AYE GLORIA AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO.
KALRA.
COLOR AYE. LEVINE.
I VENE AYE. MATHIS.
RUBIO AYE
RUBIO AYE SOLACE.
SOLIS I WOULD I WOULD I.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WILL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR THE MEMBERS AT ON WE
HAVE ONE BILL A FINAL BILL.
AND THAT.
SO MEMBER KALRA.
THE BILL DOES HAVE A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION TO ASSEMBLY.
APPROPRIATIONS NOW IT HAS A
FIRST AND SECOND.
AND.
.
HERE AT GREAT PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE OF THE OPTION
PRESENT AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN TODAY AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN PROMOTE THE CONSERVATION
OF MIGRATORY BIRDS. ARE
PROVIDING GUIDANCE TO INDUSTRY
ON COMPLIANCE WITH LAWS
PROTECTING MIGRATORY BIRDS.
THIS YEAR'S THE CENTENNIAL
ANNIVERSARY THE SIGNING OF THE
FEDERAL MIGRATORY BIRD TREATY
ACT AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES CANADA MEXICO
JAPAN AND RUSSIA. TO PROTECT
MIGRATORY BIRDS THE MBTA'S ONE
OF THE WORLD'S OLDEST AND MOST
EFFECTIVE ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS AND
IS CREDITED WITH HELPING TO SAVE
ICONIC BIRD SPECIES INCLUDING.
THE WOOD DUCK BALD EAGLE SNOWY
EGRET AND THE SANDHILL CRANE.
MIGRATORY BIRDS ARE ESSENTIALLY
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL HISTORY
ABOUT DIVERSITY AND ECONOMY.
DESPITE THE SUCCESS OF THE MBTA
MOST MIGRATORY BIRD SPECIES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE IN DECLINE
LARGELY DUE TO A LOSS OF
HABITAT.
AND DIRECT IMPACTS OF HUMAN
ACTIVITY.
IN NORTH AMERICA AT LEAST FOUR
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO BIRD SPECIES
MORE THAN ONE THIRD OF BIRDS
THAT OCCUR ON THE CONTINENT ARE
AT RISK OF. A HIGH RISK OF
EXTINCTION WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT
CONSERVATION ACTION.
IN CALIFORNIA MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SPECIES OF
BIRDS ARE AT SIGNIFICANT RISK.
TO CLIMATE CHANGE AND MIGRATORY
BIRDS WILL FACE EVEN GREATER
CHALLENGES IN THE FUTURE.
AS CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION GROWS
INDUSTRIES CONTINUE TO EXPAND
THE CLIMATE CHANGES AND
RESOURCES BECOME SCARCER.
UNFORTUNATELY RECENT ACTIONS BY
THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION AND
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS HAVE BEEN
AIMED AT WEAKENING THE MBTA
ALARMING CONSERVATIONISTS AND
CREATING UNCERTAINTY. FROM
REGULATED INDUSTRIES.
AND DECEMBER OF LAST YEAR IN A
MOVE THAT CONTRADICTED A HUNDRED
YEARS A FEDERAL POLICY.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION ISSUED
ISRAEL LEGAL OPINION SAYING IT
WOULD NO LONGER ENFORCE THE MBTA
IN CASES OF INCIDENTAL BIRD
DEATHS.
EFFECTIVELY ALLOWING INDUSTRY TO
KILL MILLIONS OF MIGRATORY BIRDS
OUT THE NEED TO IMPLEMENT MEDIC
MEDICATION MEASURES OF THE PAY
FINES WERE LARGE SCALE KILLINGS
OF BIRDS OCCUR.
UNFORTUNATELY WE LIVE IN A TIME
WHERE ACTIONS LIKE THESE ARE
BECOMING THE NORM MORE STATES
ARE HAVING TO UNDERTAKE THEIR
OWN ACTIONS.
TO KEEP IN PLACE FEDERAL
PROTECTIONS FOR WILDLIFE THEY'RE
UNDER THREAT.
BY THE CURRENT FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION.
AS FEDERAL ROLE BUCK ROLLBACKS
THE MBTA HAVE CREATED A VACUUM
AND WILDLIFE PROTECTION
CERTAINTY IS NEEDED FOR BOTH
CONSERVATION EFFORTS. AND
INDUSTRY TO ENSURE THAT BIRDS
AND OTHER NATURAL RESOURCES ARE
PROTECTED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AM I BOAT
AND WITH ME TODAY AS WITNESSES
ARE MY CLIENTS DIRECTOR POLICY
BROUGHT UPON CALIFORNIA. AND KIM
DELFINO STATE PROGRAM DIRECTOR
FOR DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MIKE
LINES IN THE DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
POLICY FRAUD ON CALIFORNIA AND
ONE OF THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL.
AND IS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
INDICATED WE'RE HERE TO URGE AND
I.
FOR THE CONSERVATION OF BIRDS
IS ALSO TO CREATE A PATHWAY FOR
COMPLIANCE FOR INDUSTRIES THAT
ARE LOOKING TO MINIMIZE AND
AVOID THEIR IMPACTS.
THE MIGRATORY BIRDS WE'VE
ALREADY HEARD QUITE A BIT OF
TESTIMONY TODAY ABOUT THE
BENEFITS OF MIGRATORY BIRDS NOW
IMPORTANCE BOTH ECOLOGICALLY AND
ECONOMICALLY AND INTRINSICALLY.
TO CALIFORNIA'S BIODIVERSITY.
SO I JUST WANT TO FOCUS A LITTLE
BIT ON THE FACT THAT WE KNOW THE
MIGRATORY BIRDS ARE IN DECLINE
WILSON OF THE PROTECTIONS WORK.
AND WHAT WE WANT TO DO THROUGH
THIS BILL IS INCENTIVIZE
PROTECTIONS TO BE PUT IN PLACE
AND TO CONTINUE.
TO BE CLEAR CURRENT CALIFORNIA
LAW PROHIBITS THE TAKING OF NON
GAME MIGRATORY BIRDS BUT LACKS
AWAY FOR INDUSTRY IT COULD OTHER
ENTITIES TO COMPLY.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN WOULD
PROVIDE THAT PATH FORWARD.
AS YOU SOME REMEMBER INDICATED
CALIFORNIA MUST NOW STEP UP AS
THE FEDERAL BILL REAL FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS ROLLED BACK IT'S
PROTECTIONS OF THE MBTA AND
EFFECTIVELY GOT AT THAT.
CALIFORNIA HAS LAWS ON THE BOOKS
BUT IT NEEDS TO KNOW HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD IN AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
SEVEN PROVIDES A PATH FORWARD.
A COUPLE MORE POINTS I JUST
WANNA MAKE ON IT IS ONE THAT AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN DOES NOT
CREATE ANY NEW LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS.
RATHER IT PROVIDES A PATHWAY FOR
ENTITIES TO COMPLY WITH EXISTING
LAW.
AND IF THEY WANT TO THE NAY WILL
IMPLEMENT THOSE BMPS HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED BY DFW AND IT WELL
SELF CERTIFY THAT IT'S WITHIN
COMPLIANCE.
WE WROTE THIS TO MINIMIZE THE
BURDEN TO DFW AND TO MIMIC A
PROCESS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
WHICH SOUGHT A GENERAL PERMIT
UNDER THE MIGRATORY BIRD TREATY
ACT.
WITH THAT I'D WANT TO WRAP UP BY
JUST SAYING THAT WE HAVE BEEN IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH INDUSTRY TO TRY
TO IMPROVE THE LANGUAGE AND
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS. WE WILL
CONTINUE THAT PROCESS GOING
FORWARD.
.
WE'RE ADDRESSING ISSUES FOR
EXAMPLE RELATED TO THE SCALE OF
THE IMPACTS SOUGHT TO US OR TO
BE REGULATED BY THE BMPS. THE
TIMING AND REPORTING ISSUES AND
REQUIREMENTS.
WITH THAT I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON A KIM DELFINO
WITH DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE.
I'LL JUST MAKE THIS QUICK
BECAUSE I THINK MIKE UP COVERED
A LOT OF THE POINTS I THINK THE
OF WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO
EMPHASIZE IS THAT WHEN THE
MIGRATORY BIRD TREATY ACT. WAS
INTERPRETED BY THE FISH FISH
WILDLIFE SERVICE AS PROHIBITING
INCIDENTAL TAKE IT REALLY TRUE
DROVE A COLLABORATIVE PROCESS AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL WHERE
INDUSTRIES WORKED WITH THE
SERVICE AND OTHERS TO COME UP
WITH VARIOUS GUIDELINES. FOR
EXAMPLE THE NGUYEN GUIDELINES
THE.
COMMUNICATION TOWER SITING
GUIDELINES AND THE AVIAN
POWERLINE GUIDELINES
INDUSTRY DID THIS BECAUSE THEY
KNEW THAT THEY. WERE RISKING A
BY NOT A PRO ACTIVELY WORKING
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
POTENTIAL.
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS FOR
PROJECTS THAT WERE RESULTING IN
INCIDENT TAKE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STEPPING BACK NOW AND
REVERSING A HUNDRED YEARS OF
LAW.
AND SAY NO LONGER DOES THE
MIGRATORY BIRD TREATY ACT
PROHIBIT INCIDENTAL TAKE THEY
HAVE NOW REMOVED ANY INCENTIVE
TO CONTINUE THAT COLLABORATIVE
PROCESS.
I'M AS MR LINES ALREADY POINTED
OUT. THE CALIFORNIA CODE ALREADY
CONTAINS A PROHIBITION ON
INCIDENTAL TAKE OF MIGRATORY
BIRDS BUT IT DIDN'T DO ANY MORE
THAN THAT. AND FOR MANY YEARS
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WILDLIFE
ESSENTIALLY DEFERRED TO THE US
FISH WILDLIFE SERVICE IN THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO TO
ESSENTIALLY TAKE CARE OF THE
MIGRATORY BIRDS IN THAT SETTING.
BUT NOW THAT THE CALIFORNIA
PARTNER FISHING WHILE IT DOES
HAVE TO SET UP AND THEN STAND P
AND THAT THIS PRACTICE BILLS SET
UP A PROCESS. THAT CONTINUES
THAT COLLABORATIVE DROPPED
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT.
UP PROCESS BY ALLOWING FOR SELF
CERTIFICATION AND THE
DEVELOPMENT OF ADDITIONAL.
BEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICE
GUIDELINES AND SO IT ACTUALLY
GIVES A PLACE FOR BOTH THE
DEPARTMENT AND INDUSTRY AND
STAKEHOLDERS TO WORK THROUGH
THESE ISSUES AGAIN IN A
COLLABORATIVE MANNER. AND SO FOR
THAT REASON WE BELIEVE THIS IS A
COMMON SENSE APPROACH TO DEALING
WITH AN UNFORTUNATE PROBLEM THAT
HAS NOW BEEN PLACED AT THE FEET
OF CALIFORNIA THROUGH A FEDERAL
ROLE BACK. ON AND AGAIN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
MOVES FORWARD TO ADDRESS WHAT OF
THEIR ADDITIONAL CONCERNS ARE
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S A VERY
WORKABLE. A PROCESS I THINK
THERE'S GONNA BE CONCERNS RAISED
ABOUT DEPREDATION PERMITS I
DON'T THINK THAT WE ARE A
INTENDED MAKING IT HARD. TO GET
DEPREDATION PERMITS AT ALL ON
AND SO I THINK THESE ARE THINGS
THAT ARE VERY EASILY ADDRESSED
SO FOR THAT REASON WE WOULD URGE
HER AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THOSE WISHING TO ADD ON SUPPORT
ACT HOW JOHNSON CIRCLE
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
RICOH MUSTARD UNATO WITH THE
TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND AND
SUPPORT ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
GYRE INSTITUTE'S SEVENTH
GENERATION INSTITUTE. WHICH TOYO
SHOE MASH FOUNDATION PLASTIC
POLL CUP PLASTIC POLLUTION
COALITION AND CENTER FOR OCEANIC
AWARENESS RESEARCH AND
EDUCATION.
AND A BIRD LOVERS EVERYWHERE.
JEFFREY GOLDBERG WITH CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
WE'RE GOING TO NEED FOR THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
ONE OF THE ME DOWN ON BEHALF OF
A SUIT.
CALIFORNIA RELIEF LATINO
OUTDOORS AND IN THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
THAT DIDN'T BETH AGAIN THOUGHTS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE PARKS FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT.
HELLO GUYS ARE WITH HIM THEIR
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN
SUPPORT.
RIGHT THOSE. WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION.
TO US SPEAKERS TWO MINUTES EACH
SHOP OR LAST. YEAR THAT HE
MELISSA CORTES ROTH ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA WIND ENERGY
ASSOCIATION I'M ACTUALLY A
LITTLE BIT OF A TWEENER. WE
DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL OPPOSE
POSITION BUT WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS WITH HOW THIS BILL MAY
IMPACT TO OUR RENEWABLE ENERGY
DEVELOPMENT WE ARE WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS ON
THIS BILL WE DID SEND THE MULLIN
OF A CONCERN.
ABOUT THE DISCUSSION SO FAR
HAVE BEEN GOOD WE THINK WE CAN
GET THERE THANK YOU.
CURRENT GOOD AFTERNOON WELL
CREAMERS OF CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION. A CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE PROVIDES A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF HABITAT
FOR WILDLIFE AND PARTICULARLY
FOR BIRDS I'M. CALIFORNIA
CENTRAL VALLEY GRASSLANDS
ACTUALLY ARE THE NUMBER ONE TIME
HABITAT FOR WINTERGREEN RAPTORS.
AND WE ALSO PROVIDE RICE FIELD
HAVE HALF PROVIDE HALF OF THE
NUTRITION FOR. WINTERING
WATERFOWL SO I'M.
ALL OF THIS HABITAT THEN DOES
PUT OUR MEMBERS AT RISK FOR
VIOLATING PROHIBITIONS ON TAKE.
WHEN THEY'RE MANAGING THEIR
FARMS AND RANCHES.
SO. WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
INCREASE IN LIABILITY THAT THIS
BILL WILL CREATE FOR POTENTIAL
TAKE WERE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PROCESS THAT THE BILL LAYS
OUT. A.
IN IN THE INTERIM TIME BEFORE
BEST MANAGEMENT PRACTICES ARE
DEVELOPED WE THINK THAT AND THE
DEPARTMENT COULD STOP CERTAIN
ACTIVITIES I'M WE KNOW THAT
TIMBER HARVEST WHEN THEY ARE
TURNING THEIR TEACH PEACE IF THE
DEPARTMENT DOESN'T HAVE A
PROCESS IN PLACE. THEY. WILL
ESSENTIALLY HOLD THOSE PERMITS
WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT.
WE'RE ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT AN
INCREASING THE DEPARTMENT'S
WORKLOAD A THE LEGISLATURE RIGHT
NOW IS GOOD IS CONSIDERING A
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR INCREASE OF
THE DEPARTMENT'S BUDGET. BECAUSE
THE DEPARTMENT DOES NOT HAVE THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO FULFILL
THEIR EXISTING RESPONSIBILITIES
AND SO ADDING AN ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY WHILE WORK TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO FUND.
EXISTING RESPONSIBILITIES SEEMS
CHALLENGING WE ALSO HAVE
CONCERNS WITH DEPREDATION
PERMITS BUT I KNOW SOME OTHER
COLLEAGUES OF MINE. AND WILL BE
MENTIONING THOSE SO AT THIS
POINT WE ARE OPPOSED.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
OF THE COMMITTEE JUST AN OLD
FIELD WITH CALIFORNIA
CATTLEMEN'S ASSOCIATION.
OR ONE WHO.
CORRELATE OUR REMARKS WITH
THOSE MADE BY THE CALIFORNIA
FARM BUREAU UP BUT YOU ALSO WANT
TO POINT OUT ONE ISSUE THAT WAS
RAISED BY.
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
WE DO HAVE SOME SOME CONCERNS
THEY ARE VALID CONCERNS I HAVE
NOT SEEN ANY WAY TO RECTIFY
THOSE CONCERNS YET AS IT RELATES
TO DEPREDATION PERMITS.
MIGRATORY BIRDS
TO GIVE THE BUZZARDS
RAVENS CAN ACTUALLY AT A PRETTY
CATTLE.
AND WE HAVE SEEN INCREASE
INSTANCES TO WEAR.
PARTICULARLY PREYING ON ON
SMALLER CABS EATING OUT THEIR
EYES ARE OPEN WOUNDS.
AND SO.
.
WE CAN CURRENTLY GET.
DEPREDATION PERMITS UNDER THE
FEDERAL LAW.
THIS HAS THE POTENTIAL TO PUT A
DUPLICATIVE PROCESS ON TOP OF
THAT A WHICH WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
AND AGAIN I DO WANT TO SAY ALSO
AS WELL WE JUST SAW THESE
AMENDMENTS A MID PART OF LAST
WEEK I'D SO I KNOW THAT OUR
COMMENTS ARE NOT REFLECTED IN
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS BUT.
WE DID I DID SUBMIT CONCERNS
AND ARE HAPPY TO SPEAK TO THE
AUTHOR BUT AT THIS POINT TIME
WOULD ASK.
FOR OPPOSED THE BILL THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON UP MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME SHANNON
ANY I'M REPRESENTING A LARGE
SCALE SOLAR ASSOCIATION. WHERE
WE HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
OPPOSITION ON THIS AND I'D LIKE
TO TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT MBTA
ENFORCEMENT IF YOU IF YOU ALLOW
IT FOR JUST A MOMENT? OF THIS
BILL IS ENDEAVORING TO ENFORCE
AN INTERPRETATION OF THE MBTA.
THAT IS MORE STRINGENT THAN THAN
HAS BEEN OPINED AND AND I AND A
COUPLE OF AND ACTUALLY TREATS
DIFFERENT CIRCUIT COURTS
INCLUDING THE NIGHT CIRCUIT.
WHICH IS CALIFORNIA'S OUR COURT
OF APPEALS.
WE DO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF ANGST UM ABOUT THE
FEDERAL ROLLBACKS WE ACTUALLY
HAVE A LOT OF THINGS ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING ON FEDERALLY TERMS
OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL ROLLBACKS
BUT WE FEEL LIKE THIS BILL GOES
A LITTLE BIT TOO FAR.
THE PENDULUM IS SWINGING
SWINGING BACK TOO FAR FOR THAT
FOR THE.
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE MBTA. I
THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
KNOW HOW YOU THE US FISH AND
WILDLIFE SERVICE HAS IMPLEMENTED
TAKE.
EVEN BEFORE THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TOOK OVER.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN THEY SAID
THAT PROSECUTIONS FOR MBTA
VIOLATIONS ARE RESERVED FOR
CASES WHERE COMPANIES ARE AWARE
THEIR ACTIVITIES BECAUSE TAKE
BUT NONETHELESS FAILED TO
IMPLEMENT REASONABLE MEASURES TO
AVOID MINIMISE AND MITIGATE
HARM.
NOW IN CALIFORNIA SEEK FOR
PROVIDES FOR THAT.
AND ONE OF THAT WERE. AND AND SO
ALL OF OUR PROJECTS CERTAINLY
ARE FOLLOWING SEQUEL WE AVOID WE
MINIMIZE WE MITIGATE FOR NTTA
SPECIES CURRENTLY. WHICH LEADS
US TO QUESTION WHY WE'RE PUTTING
THIS BILL FORWARD RIGHT NOW KNOW
WHAT THE CIRCUIT COURTS HAVE
DECIDED IS THE MBTA APPLIES TO
HUNTING IT APPLIES TO TO PURPOSE
WILL TAKE BUT IT DOESN'T APPLY
TO INCIDENTAL TAKE.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION AGREES
WITH THE NINTH CIRCUIT COURT.
.
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE HAVING
SOME ISSUES ARE WHAT WE'RE
WORRIED ABOUT IS THAT THIS IS
GOING TO BE IMPROPERLY
IMPROPERLY.
APPLIED IN CALIFORNIA JUST
QUICKLY BY THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE SEEK IS NUMBER ONE THAT ONLY
THE ACTIVITIES KNOWN. TO CAUSE
YOU KNOW SIGNIFICANT HARM TO
SPECIES ARE SUBJECT TO THE BILL.
NUMBER TWO BMPS SHOULD BE
DEVELOPED A THROUGH CONSENSUS
BAKE A CONSENSUS BASED PROCESS.
A PARTY SHOULD BE ABLE TO SELF
CERTIFY AND THE BILL SHOULD
CLARIFY AND I THINK THE WORLD
POINTED TO THIS AS WELL BILL
SHOULD CLARIFY THAT I'M TAKE IS
ALLOWED UNTIL BE INFUSER DEVELOP
BANK YOU. THANKS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS JACOB LOS
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION.
PER SOLAR AND ETF RENEWABLES AND
I JUST WOULD LIKE TO ECHO AND.
ELYSEES COMMENTS AND HIGH
STICKING TO THE OTHERS OFFICE
FOR BEING WILLING TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH US ON THE BILL AS
WE. MOVE FORWARD IN THE PROCESS
THANK.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING BACK TO
DICING QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR.
SOME MEMBER RUBIO.
YES I I'VE HEARD A LOT OF
CONCERNS AND I'M HOPING THAT.
YOU CAN WORK WITH THE THE.
OPPOSITION TO CLARIFY SOME OF
THESE ISSUES.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T. AND THERE'S NO UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES WITH THIS IF YOU
CAN YOU KNOW.
ASSURE ME THAT YOU ARE WORKING
WITH THE OPPOSITION TYPE WHICH.
SUPPORT BILL. OF THE THINK
MISTER SHARON THANK YOU MISS
RUBIO ASSEMBLY RUBIO I'M
ABSOLUTELY AND I'VE BEEN. A
PARTICULAR BUT SOME OF THE THE
LAST COMMENTS HAVE BEEN
PROPONENT OF ENERGY PROGRAM
DECADE NOW AND CERTAINLY DON'T
WANT ANYTHING TO HINDER. THE
INDUSTRY.
UNDER TRADITIONAL MBTA THAT
NOBLE ENERGY DEVELOPMENT HAS
EXPANDED QUICKLY IN CALIFORNIA I
DON'T SEE WHAT I CAN CONTINUE TO
BE THE CASE. ARM WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE WILK TINA BROKE WITH THEM
AS AS SOME OF THE OPPOSITION
INCLUDING FROM THE CABS
ASSOCIATION OTHER SAID THAT THEY
JUST CAME KIND OF LATE. IN THE
COMMENTS SO THEY WERE IN THE.
IN THE REPORT.
WHOEVER COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS THE REAL
GOAL HERE IS TO ENSURE THAT.
WE DON'T.
THAT THE. THAT THE MBTA
CONTINUE.
TO OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA AS IT
HAS FOR A HUNDRED YEARS WITH OF
MODERNIZATION WHICH REALLY
ALLOWS US THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH INDUSTRY. TO HELP
THEM.
TO HELP PUT TOGETHER BEST
MANAGER PRACTICE TO ALLOW THEM
TO SELF CERTIFY OF SOME REALLY
GREAT BENEFITS FOR INDUSTRY BUT
WE CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO GO
BACKWARDS. AND TO REVERT TO.
SOBRE MOVE INCIDENTAL BIRD
DEATHS.
OF OF FROM ENFORCEMENT
ALTOGETHER THAT THAT BE A
MASSIVE STEP BACKWARDS IN TERMS
OF DETECTION OF BIRDS AND SO. I
AM CONFIDENT THAT MOST OF THE
FOLKS OF INDUSTRY THAT HAVE
SPOKEN.
BUT AGREE AHEAD THAT WE STILL
NEED THE PROTECTION SUMMERED
MBTA IN PLACE AND A SENSE AS A
STATE WE NEED TO MAKE SURE HE
PROPOSED PROTECTIONS AND IN
PLACE NOW THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
IS RELAXING THEM THAT WE CAN DO
IT AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM BUT INDUSTRY TO ENSURE
THAT. THEIR CONCERNS I AM YOU
KNOW A CAN BE NOT JUST HEARD
THAT BUT TO THE GREATEST EXTENT
POSSIBLE MATT AS IT WAS BUILT
MOST FORWARD.
NO QUESTIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THIS ITEM.
WE DO HAVE MUCH A SECOND.
MUCH KALRA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS THAT MEASURE
FORWARD. I THINK YOU'VE HEARD
THAT. THE CONCERNS FROM THE
VARIOUS INDUSTRIES.
AND QUITE FRANKLY THAT ARE
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT.
TO ME IN MY DISTRICT WHETHER BE
RENEWABLE ENERGY INDUSTRY. AND
OR THE APARTMENT COMMUNITY SOME
HOPE IN THE.
CONTAINING GAUGE AT THEM IN
DISCUSSIONS AND WE CERTAINLY
WOULD LIKE TO ALSO.
BE.
INVOLVED.
WITH YOU ON THAT.
AND THIS IS THE BILL DOES HAVE A
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION AND OUT
WILL TAKE THAT THAT LAST
STATEMENT ON YOUR PART AS TO
CLOSE. NORTHERN QUESTIONER
COMMENTS ALLOWS FOR ROCCA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO. BIGELOW. DEVELOP
NO CARILLO.
CARILLO AYE TROY NO CHOI THE NO.
CHU R. CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE GLORIA. GLORIA AYE
HARPER.
HARPER NO. COLOR.
I
COLOR AYE LEVINE AYE LEVINE AYE
MATHIS.
RUBIO. RUBIO AYE SOLACE.
SOLACE NO.
WOULD.
WOULD I.
OKAY WE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN
WE'RE GOING TO GO. ALL THE WAY
TO THE TOP OF THE FILE ORDER.
FOR.
.
ACTION ON TWO ITEMS AND THEN ADD
ONS.
FOR THE REMAINDER.
.
OF THE AGENDA FIRST ITEM WAS THE
EIGHT P. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX OF
FRAZIER SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN
DELTA.
A DOUBLE PLAN ADMINISTRATION.
WE DID NOT HAVE A QUORUM THERE
WAS NO MOTION OR SECOND ON THAT
BILL. IT HAS A NON
RECOMMENDATION.
.
WHERE THE WISHES OF HIS
COMMITTEE?
IS THERE A MOTION.
THERE'S NO MOTION.
FOR A. B. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX.
THERE'S A MOTION ON MISTER
GALLAGHER.
THEIR SECOND.
SO THERE'S A MOTION AND THEN
THERE'S A SECOND.
ALL ASK.
FOR LOCAL ON. E. B. EIGHTEEN
SEVENTY SIX.
AND IT'S THE.
CORRECT.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA NO.
SEE I KNOW GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NOT VOTING.
BIGELOW.
BIGELOW NO. CAR CARILLO.
CARILLO NOT VOTING.
CHOI NO.
CHIU LOVE BOAT.
CHIU NOT VOTING BETWEEN
FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NOT VOTING GLORIA.
GLORIA NOT VOTING HARPER.
HARPER NO.
KALRA.
LEVINE THOUGH.
LEVINE NO.
MATHIS.
RUBIO. WOULD REVEAL NOT VOTING
SOLACE.
SOLACE NO WOULD.
WOULD NOT VOTING.
AND THAT HAS
TWO THREE FOUR
FIVE SO.
TWO ZERO.
SIX TWO ZERO WE WILL LEAVE THAT
OPEN FOR OTHER MEMBERS TO. NOT
VOTE.
WHICH I THINK OF MATHIS.
ZERO ZERO TO SIX.
YEAH WELL.
MAYBE SOMEONE ELSE WANTS THAT IS
A NON VOTING.
OKAY.
WE WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN.
WE HAVE.
ACTUALLY YOU MISTER CALLERS HERE
SO WILL WILL.
ASK HIM TO REGISTER HIS VOTE ON
A. B. EIGHTEEN SEVENTY SIX.
EPA CAN SEVENTY SIX KALRA.
MOHAMMED.
KALRA NOT VOTING NOT VOTING OKAY
WE'D JUST HAVE SEX THANK YOU. AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY ONE WELL DONNA
BILL THERE'S A MOTION SECOND.
WAS FROM DOESN'T ENJOY THE.
THAT RECOMMENDATION TO APPROVAL
APPROPRIATIONS
BROKEN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
EDUARDO GARCIA OF AYE GARCIA AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I BIGELOW. BIGELOW AYE
CARILLO.
I CARILLO AYE CHOI. CHOI AYE
CHU.
CHU AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE GLORIA.
LORI I HARPER BY HARPER AYE
KALRA.
FLORA AYE LEVINE. THREE HIGH
MATHIS.
RUBIO AYE REVEAL AYE SOLACE.
SOLIS I WOULD.
WOULD I.
KING.
ZERO FIFTEEN ZERO.
MOVE ON TO ITEM FOR AB TWENTY TO
FORTY TWO. LOOK ABOUT RUBIO.
THEY ARE SO MAD ON TO.
AND THE OTHER NIGHT I THOUGHT
WAS AT YOUR CONVENIENCE.
AB TWENTY TO FORTY TWO CARILLO.
I.
CARILLO AYE CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU. CHU AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA. KALRA I WOULD.
WOULD I.
IN THE MAIL
CAN YOU.
MISS AG YOUR CREASE BILL AB
TWENTY THREE MORE DEVELOPED
SECOND.
THAT THINK WITH THERE WAS A
MOTION A SECOND WHERE AS TO
THINK HE MAKES A MOTION OKAY.
HE 23-14 AT ON. THE PRESENTED
WITH YOUR BLANCA CARILLO IF YOU
DIDN'T HAVE.
CARILLO I
CHOOSE THE. SOONER CHIU AYE
GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA.
BUT KALRA AYE LEVINE. LEVINE AYE
RUBIO AYE RUBIO AYE WOULD. WOULD
I.
TING.
FULLER.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE STONE.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I. CARILLO.
I'M SORRY WHAT.
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE STONE.
AYE.
CARILLO I.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN I.
MATHIS.
TWO ONE.
TINA ONE X. BUILD AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY FIVE. DOCTOR WHAT.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE CARILLO TRY
CARILLO AYE CHU. CHU AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE AYE FRIEDMAN AYE.
MATHIS.
ONE.
THANK YOU AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE FORTY FIVE ME GALLAGHER.
CARILLO.
I.
CARILLO AYE CHIU.
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY FIVE.
ITEM NUMBER TEN.
YOU PASS THE AS AMENDED.
RECOMMENDATION NO.
CHIU NO.
KALRA.
LEVINE SO.
LEVINE NO.
MATHIS.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE.
WOULD.
WOULD NOT VOTING
EIGHT YES FOR NO.
THAT GETS OUT.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY SEVEN.
KALRA.
LEVINE CONCERT MATHIS.
IT'S NINE
NINE TO FIVE BILL GETS OUT A
BETWEEN SIX FORTY WHAT.
GALLAGHER.
NUMBER THIRTEEN.
WOULD.
GALLAGHER ENOUGH VOTING.
CARILLO.
I CARILLO AYE. FRIEDMAN.
FIVE.
FRIEDMAN I.
MATHIS.
REVENUE TO THE BILL WITHOUT A
BETWEEN SIX FORTY NINE NAMBLA.
TO PASS A WITH COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS RECOMMENDATION.
CHIU.
RIGHT
CHIU AYE. GLORIA AYE
GLORIA I KALRA.
LEVINE.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
SIX FORTY NINE. I'VE.
LEVINE I.
WOULD YOU WERE AND I.
YEAH.
OKAY.
I THINK THEIR PROXY.
NQCS.
ELEVEN TWO ONE EVER TO WIN THE
BILL'S OUT. A BETWEEN SIX AYE
SEVEN GALLAGHER.
AND AS A TO PASS.
NATION APPROPRIATIONS.
CARILLO.
I'VE
CARILLO AYE CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU.
TO I KALRA. KILEY KALRA AYE
LEVINE.
BY.
LEVINE I. WOULD. WOULD I.
PUTTING OIL BILL GETS OUT.
AB THIRTY FORTY FIVE
I GALLAGHER.
RUBIO.
I CARILLO AYE CHOI.
CHOI AYE CHU.
CHIU AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I WOULD.
WOULD I.
OKAY.
THAT BILL GETS OUT A. B. THIRTY
ONE SEVENTEEN MATHIS THIS HAS A.
CARE NO RECOMMENDATION.
CARILLO NO
CARILLO NO.
CHIU NO
CHIU NO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN NO GLORIA.
GLORIA NO.
SOLACE.
SOLACE I.
THE AUTHOR DID ASK THAT FOR THIS
TO BE RECONSIDERS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO GRANT AN
EXPIRATION.
BY ANONYMOUS CONSENT.
NO OBJECTION THEN WE
CONSIDERATIONS GOT.
A. B. THIRTY TWO EIGHTEEN ITEM
BRA.
TO.
CHIU AYE GLORIA.
GLORIA I KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE.
LEVINE I WOULD.
WOULD I.
RESIDENTS ENCOUNTER.
AND THAT'S CONSENT CALENDAR.
SECOND.
GET WE ALREADY VOTED ON IT JUST
A COUPLE FOLKS NEED AT ON.
CARILLO I.
WE ALL AYE CHU. CHU AYE GLORIA
AYE GLORIA AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE LEVINE. LEVINE AYE
RUBIO AYE REVIEW I WOULD.
WOULD I.
TO COUNTER MOVES THAT.
IS ADJOURNMENT THANK YOU FOR
HANGING IN THERE WITH US AT THIS
MEETING IS ADJOURNED